[Music]
n
[Applause]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club they may be playing classical but
the games are racing by at Breakneck
speed at the sanfield cup in St Louis
with the rest day on the horizon players
emptied their tanks and let left it all
on the boards unfortunately for the
standings most were left spinning their
wheels with nearly every game sputtering
to a draw all except leavon aronian who
shifted into high gear getting his first
win to jump into a tie for second with
Wesley so still leading they've passed
the Midway point but a lot can happen
before they reached the checkered flag
round six of hard stopping chess coming
up
next
[Music]
welcome to round six of the singfield
cup we are here at the World Chess Hall
of Fame where you can find exhibits of
the chess history and history is being
made upstairs in our tournament let's go
back to the studio and get
started welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America as the St Louis chess
club proudly presents the sinkfield cup
day six starts right
now hello and welcome it's day six of
the sinkfield cup and the players are
back in action after yesterday's rest
day and with the tension and the stakes
Rising now is the chance for the players
to unleash their chest secrets and see
these their chances for victory I'm
International Master Ivanka housea and
it's a great pleasure to be alongside
these very strong and very fine
Grandmasters yasa San and pet fidler joy
as always a pleasure to be with you and
you as well Peter you're looking happy
to be here yes looking looking for the
for the snooker look yes you've achieved
it lovely hello everyone and Welcome to
our coverage I hope you enjoyed the rest
day we dudas withdraw in round two there
is an imbalance in games play and this
is why you see Wesley so at the top of
the table with his plus one score of
three points out of five and then we see
leavon aronian there with two and a half
points out of four his victory over Al
alira fua in round five and there you
can see a lot of players withdrawn all
their games and Ali Resa fuja and
Richard report those are the players who
have lost games and the format for for
uh the S cup Joy yes it is a 10 player
round robin 90 minutes for the first 40
moves and then 30 minutes for the rest
of the game 30 second increment from
move one no draw offers allowed which
means Fighting Chess of course and one
point for the win half point for the
draw a remaining schedule yes and the
players are playing one but very intense
hard fought game per day and they will
be playing
until Thursday November the 30th and of
course playoffs will happen if necessary
on that day and uh as we see the players
coming into the Hall they're getting
their um screenings uh security
screenings no electronics allowed in the
playing Hall and Peter uh coming into
the show we have been debling in some
statistics and you found some nuggets
for us well more precisely our uh
statistician in Chief Ben Underwood
thanks very much to Ben for all the hard
work he's doing and very appropriately
uh the man of the hour there Wesley saw
on on your screen just now and you will
see him on the screen in a moment again
because uh here are our chosen stats for
today and there will be a Common Thread
going through them as you will see these
are the shortest and the longest game in
the history of singfield cup the
shortest game and the longest were
played in the same tournament in 2019
where Wesley Drew against shakarov in
only 14 moves and lost an absolutely
Marathon 132 move game uh to yanomi and
also there is a very nice little tidbit
there in the middle the shortest
decisive game in all the editions of the
sinfield cup belongs to me because I
feel like I contributed to that game
more than more than Wesley did by
playing absolutely abysmally uh losing
losing to in uh in 28 moves in 20121 you
made history Peter that's what it's all
about abely yeah you you have to you
have to build your legacy and Any Which
Way exactly uh and apart from that we're
obviously paying a very very close
attention to the race for the final two
candidate spots and this is the ratings
watch right uh the the highest rated
player of the player is not qualified
already on January 21st on January 1st
201 24 will qualify for the candidates
and will have a fight of to to play play
world championship match and as you see
on your screen here there's been a
massive change with ala fua losing to
Deon aronian yesterday Wesley is now
leing this race half a point clear of uh
alira and Three Points clear of Anish
giri but with all three of them playing
in our tournament there is a lot to look
forward to
exactly and here we have Anish giri in
his tentative waiting pause and this is
the best part of my day of course I get
the chance to introduce woman Grand
Master Anastasia carich take it away
n thank you Peter hello everyone it's
really nice to be here next to the plane
Hall in this second Studio we have and
I'm waiting here for the players and
after the end of the games they usually
come here and tell us what what happened
in the games and also show some
variations which happened and not
happened in their games I also take care
of social media accounts and once again
I'm asking everybody to follow them and
get some backstage information and
videos uh one of those I would like to
show one of the videos now on your
screens you can see that chess fans are
waiting next to the Hall of Fame and
they tried to get autographs now Anish
giri he was caught at the last moment
and the kid managed to get the autograph
now he's running after the others yanii
is on your screens right now he's posing
for some
pictures and you know you see many many
many kids but actually we don't have so
many fans here in St Louis because the
weather is not that great like it was in
Croatia and Poland and also we don't
have spectators in the venue now you see
L is a fer running to the plane Hall
don't don't forget that players they
don't have gadgets with them so they
don't know exactly what time is it and
if you are late for the games you have
to pay perhaps sometimes $2,000 fine
Maxim V gra still found time and now
he's running to the plane venue to be on
time for the games don't forget that
also players have a security check and
we can see now Fabiano Carana Anish gir
who made it to the plane venue without
problems today um and now it's time to
get back to the studio the action is
about to start we're on the sixth round
Joy yeser it's time for you thank you
Anastasia I love those autograph I love
the way that Ali Resa like dodged and
dived and he right through I mean he saw
an opening and he uh ran for it Joy do
the honors tell our audience what they
can expect from bearings for this round
six and a very big one at top it
absolutely is these are the best players
in the world just to remind everyone at
home but Wesley so tournament leader
will be facing off against leavon
aronian who also is on plus one and well
that one is going to be big is going to
be big for the tournament and also for
the ratings and the candidates that's
what wow and then Ali Resa fuja plays
Fabiana Carana ala fuja will also be
looking to claing back some of those
rating points as well Fabby for Fabby
three blacks in a row after rest day as
well that's tough that's tough tough
yeah and there you also saw the other
two pairings and here we see Richard
reports and Vash lra and Anish giri
against lenia Dominguez and uh because
of yan Kristoff duda's withdraw in round
two yanon Mii will not be playing today
and has the buy free day indeed a second
free day uh Peter for
fua uh it doesn't get any more important
than this I mean he's trailing by a
point in the
ratings uh he's at minus one after that
and he's playing against the grand chess
Tour Tournament
leader he's got to produce something has
to happen for him in this event if he's
going to WR a ship yeah for him there is
no other way into the candidates he is
not as I understand it particularly in
the running for the for the FED of
circuit points right so this is his last
classical tournament of the year and he
needs to make sure that uh he gets the
points required to be ahead of Wesley
and Anish right uh in the ratings today
is uh obviously a very very important
game the white every game with the white
pieces assumes additional importance in
that context but he's playing against
Fabiana who's had a absolutely fantastic
year is extremely well booked up so
right not going to be an an easy game to
to to win of course but uh ala never not
tries with the white pieces but it it it
has now become a necessity exactly as uh
again the these two uh Ali Raza
grandchester Champion uh
2023 uh 2022 pardon me and uh it I mean
barring a Collapse by Faby uh he will be
the champion for uh
2023 as they're facing off uh it's not
easy to hand your title over
to not easy no but I think at the
Forefront of Ali's mind is the rating
has
to frog back over wesle so and one nice
touch that I noticed from Al Resa he's
wearing a white jumper right he's
playing with a white pieces and Fabby uh
wearing a black jack suit jacket laying
with the black pieces so something very
important for the superstitious Among Us
and there there we have the first two
moves E4 E5 and now the Knight coming to
F3 no Sicilians for Fabby in this game
it's all about playing your number one
defense Bishop
C4 Joo piano I was almost sure we were
going to see a a D3 Berlin there for
just a moment and the two knights
defense uh with Knight F6 uh Peter
Bishop C5 has kind of yeah I wanted to
say Bishop C5 has has become the goto
Knight F6 always invites Knight G5
nobody exploits Knight G5 I'm not sure
it's true and that game that we've refer
to uh during these broadcasts Without
Really discussing it in at length that
game that hikaro Nakamura has won
against fabibi there wasn't a ig5 where
right that was the in the US champ no
that was a nor was Nor cor nor where
only needed the draw I think to win
tournament and did not manage so
the the the two knights are still being
played are still being discussed and it
feels like perhaps by far the most
important and the most topical move in
this position these days is this
somewhat weird looking move Bishop G3
right uh because you you you want to be
able to play Knight E4 in response and
things get either very messy or quite
dry because the that game that Fab lost
to to Hikaru it was somewhat confusing I
think because uh fav played very
precisely got a position which he needed
to make one final precise move and it
would have been all equal pretty much
and then he committed a very very
uncharacteristic miscalculation and was
instantly more or less lost and was not
able to to save the game from there uh
so we'll see uh who comes with an
improvement first uh we are already uh
here on the live board I I think Bishop
D3 is going to be played yes it has been
properly guess there by yourself because
all of those previous moves the stories
behind each and every one of them I
remember uh studying the fried liver
attack did you ever study the fried
liver attack as a kid father that was
night takes D5 yeah my father made me St
yeah he was he was convinced that black
had
enough I didn't have to defend with the
King out there and so we played that out
quite a few times and I must admit I
could do have do have 100% track record
with the black pieces but it was not
without it scare uh this is uh a spent
teenage Hood by yours truly was Knight
takes D5 and I studied these lines which
went Knight takes F7 King takes F7 Queen
uh to F3 check King E6 and I just
reveled in uh this uh very forcing and
very consequential lines which I never
got a chance to play in my entire life
I'm
surprising nobody played 195 play me as
a as a 8-year-old
we would we would have we would have
been happy Knight A5 and I remember I
think it was olad alad there was this
move B7 B5 and do you know what White's
best answer to the move B5 is Joy again
a misspent youth here uh no it's
absolutely remarkable move so the idea
of course if you take the pawn on B5
Bishop takes B5 Queen takes D5 in the
serious compensation because the bishop
is hanging but also G2 is hanging that's
very serious compensation but the crazy
move here is not Bishop B3 which would
invite Knight D4 but Bishop F1 yeah
that's a isn't that
crazy as an amazing Lines by the way G2
G3 in the nearest game and uh he
stopped yeah SC against Len Dominguez G3
and well obviously Lena is not entirely
confused you're just wondering bedazzled
by this move he's just simply trying to
understand what his opponent wants here
and trying to just pick his approach
accordingly exactly takes Knight A5 this
has become the go-to sequence now uh one
of the ideas of Wilhelm steinet which
Bobby fiser also essayed in his 60
memorable games against uh Arthur bisu
as Bishop E2 Knight H3 that was a very
famous game that Bobby won again today
and in in later years I think Nigel
short also played also tried few Knight
H3 games but Bishop D3 has become the
most modern but what do we think about
uh Ali resa's next move so Knight D5
played as far as I know H2 H4 is all
Theory yeah this is this is a very
topical line and I think I think hikaro
went for a much more uh I will I will
fail at the move orders here but but
they reached uh in in some order they
reached this structure right I'm I'm
pretty sure and this is supposedly uh
equal if you play precisely which is
something that F did not did not manage
to do in that game but this is a very
kind of a restrained approach from White
you have an extra Pawn but your extra
Pawn is on D2 and D3 black even
sometimes gives up on E5 to bring the
knight from A5 back into the game you
often play C5 Knight C6 here right and
this is
all white never runs any risks but white
also against a well prepared opponent
wins very few games once again where a
very important game was one in this line
so it's it's not never but it's R
whereas H4 is exactly the kind of
approach that we would have expected
from Ala today ala kind of has to go all
in pretty much every single game because
if he continues making draws and Wesley
continues making draws he probably ends
up that one point behind and doesn't
qualify exactly so he needs to play very
sharply for a win and H4 does that job
uh quite well so the idea is you you
want to induce H6 we provoke H6 and then
we play Queen H5 here I'm pretty sure
and play only really starts here this is
just the beginning black normally
responds with Queen F6 it seems like
this is a blunder because yes we
protected F7 but it seems like white can
take anyway using this pin as a very
nice little tactic but unfortunately
after Knight F7 the move Knight D5 F4
works out for black we're attacking M
Queen on E5 if it takes on E5 with check
we're of course not going to take on E5
we're going to take on F7 and we end up
with a completely winning position
because we're now up a piece uh and
there is a very spectacular double
discovered check here but it doesn't
quite work it looks like my pride liver
attack Queen E8 check King takes D6 and
the king is running but running but we
don't really have attackers here we can
create one threat here a very very
important family Fork on4 but if get
spped we out of threats so after Queen
F6 white has a number of choices here my
screen currently says Knight H7 I don't
know if that's playable because
obviously uh you you need to be very
very sure it either gets out or gets
sold for a lot a lot of material and I'd
be shocked honestly if this is working
but who knows these days many things
which look like it shouldn't be working
end up working natural move here is
Knight E4 but after let's say queen E6
the third of Knight F4 is very strong
wrong if the queen goes back even F7 F5
becomes a major topic and you can repeat
but once again Fabi doesn't really need
to win this game Fabi is not in this
particular race he's already in the
candidates fa I think will be okay with
a although there will be a third rest
day I don't know if he's okay with a
third rest day uh but for res this
repetition is completely unacceptable
acceptable yeah and uh let's how do they
match up Joy absolutely let's check it
out and what are you expecting yasa and
well not this not this okay so not this
I thought it' be a little bit closer uh
like two to three maybe in one favor or
another to four one to four in Fabiano's
favor and that's quite significant and
of course the two played just recently
in the St L Louis rapid and Blitz and
there think Ali Resa won the
rapid yes and then he lost then he lost
the two Blitz Games I mean will this
also be playing on Ali resa's mind or
are the players very good at sh off
prior Ghosts no I I I think uh lossa
stay with you just ask Peter game with
Wesley so no I mean no seriously I I
think uh the players do gauge their form
and even though maybe we don't really
think too much about the Blitz and Rapid
as where classical games are concerned
we use it as a tool as a gauge of our
own um uh form H2 H4 by the way Peter
just because you were showing as this
variation
and I I didn't see the
concluding you you basically said and
wins and I thought well hang on like the
foran yeah because you were explaining
very very nicely that black is a piece
up and completely winning and you forgot
about the night on a I I did forget
about the night on A5 but then we end up
is completely winning I think it is yeah
I think when they say five you probably
on G2 and get K it it even starts with a
move like Bishop f8 D6 and says this
King on E1 is unbelievably unbelievably
vulnerable and yeah although the fact
that we apparently have to play Bishop
D6 here to just win everything else is I
mean there are many moves here which are
good for black but they aren't as
winning as Bishop D6 is that is a bit
surprising to me I thought it would be
easier because this King really has no
Defenders and I thought either Knight
takes G2 or perhaps Bishop G4 with the
idea of giving a check with this Rook
but maybe it's important Al to stop
Queen C7 check so it goes Bishop D6 in
case white does Bishop C4 check we can
simply Play Bishop E6 it seems like we
offering trades but what we are actually
offering is the queen entering the game
while theile this this collapses correct
and honestly it's a bit surprising that
Bishop D6 is the only precise move that
wins but the evaluation doesn't surprise
me in the slightest because this doesn't
really make much sense does absolutely
this really doesn't make much sense just
like this General vicinity I'm making
this very broad gesture here because
this is develop yeah this is completely
undeveloped the fact that we played H4
makes castling King side incredibly
dangerous because we've already
compromised our King side so much and
we're only two pawns up yeah it's not
like we're a full piece up or something
so no this this doesn't look right no
and whilst these players have just
played nine moves and we see Fabiano
pondering for his reply let's uh go over
to a game between the two leaders wesle
so and Leon aronian who have played how
18 moves theyve been racing at Tempo
exactly and it was a Berlin uh with
castles and rookie one and then it's
actually a system that will be very very
well known to both players and I've seen
Wesley playing at the black side of this
most prominently I I think just all the
top players today are playing the Berlin
and the players are just
uh just briefly pointing out one
horrifying trick you don't really see a
knight on C8 protecting the queen on E7
normally there's a knight on F5 doing
the job but in this particular case
Queen takes F4 not only does it protect
the queen on E7 it also blocks The Rook
on the bishop on Checkmate to cut follow
so the bishop on F4 is not hanging Rook
takes C8 and because the players are
playing playing so quickly this is all
Theory then Peter absolutely yeah and uh
the one interesting uh beit here is we
will sort of uh ignore all the previous
because this is a very very very
standard rookie One n Berlin and all of
this has been known for ages and this
idea of 93 95 here is also not new this
has been uh very much on on players
Minds for quite a while but C6 here is
an interesting new wrinkle because uh
people used to more or less
automatically go for this position
Bishop G5 very clever move using the
fact that once again this Knight is
unprotected if you wait for a move and
allow black to play Bishop B6 you're
just a pawn down for nothing but Bishop
G5 F6 and now Bishop C4 or Bishop H4
first and often you give up on B2 as
well but the positions become
unbelievably sharp and this was very
much the topic of high level discussion
for years and it seems like this is
probably a force draw but you have to
play precisely for another 15 moves from
here and you you never have any winning
Chances with black and it seems like the
the the black players in this position
shifted to playing C6 just to avoid
having to think about all of this uh
Knight E7 King f8 Knight takes C8 uh of
course the threat here is Queen B4 check
and queen takes B7 which is why Queen F6
is included mhm uh Rook D1 Rook takes C8
Queen E4 and the bishop can drop back
but Leon shows another way of uh going
from here and they're still playing
incredibly quickly uh G5 Rook takes D7
uh the the pin is going to win black the
B the piece back and now one more move
and I was going to say that uh this has
actually been played before all the way
to this current position with Rook C7
and by the way that's a visual move
isn't it Rook C7 I think the bishop on
F4 right and and The Rook can take it
but uh and one thing I wanted to ask you
because once again I cheated slightly by
looking at Yanka screen right and an
interesting part about at least up to
here up to the move Queen E4 I could see
that Wesley has has experience with this
and from the other side exactly he
played this against ler I'm not sure
exactly where but he played this against
ler so I wonder where did they depart
the game between uh lard Dominguez from
on the white side of this against
against Wesley well uh it wasn't uh
Bishop takes F2 that wasn't that wasn't
played in the game what was play so I
think Bishop C5 was played yeah Bishop
C5 or Bishop B6 are playable yeah are
both playable according to the engine
but obviously Leon has uh a new idea
also I suspect supported by
correspondence because that game on
Yanka screen does it maybe not yeah no
it's not correspondence I I was fooled
by that once as
well and I went on this whole Spiel what
correspondent J was everyone was G it's
not a correspondence game amateur game
Rook C7 looks like very very very easy
well easy ways easy and in fact my my
first impression was this is just
completely equal when you you will still
have to work I think with black for one
very very specific reason okay there is
this move Queen E5 here okay which
forces you because ideal ideal scenario
here for black would be I mean first of
all after G3 B2 is also hanging but even
if we ignore it if like if we include I
don't know A6 and C3 uh some kind of
position after G takes A4 followed by
Knight E6 in particular if the Queen
stay on the board is going to be
completely safe for black no problem but
after Queen E5 in order not to be a full
piece down you have to take with the
queen and in this position you can
definitely pretend with white because
you will win the F4 Pawn back because
let's say after Knight D6 we can include
let's say C2 C2 C3 or even the engine
goes Bishop D3 attacks the pawn on H7
and after something like H6 we quite
happily play Bishop F5 because these
types of Pawn endings no this is
dangerous it's probably lost yeah it's
not it's not dangerous very often it's
just completely lost because of how
active the white king is but the speed
with which Leon is doing this very much
indicates that he's looked to this he
knows where the pieces belong something
like I would guess King E7 King F4 King
F6 play H6 right and hold this shape um
I'm being told that this is actually a
game that this ending this entire ending
is a u from Zagreb Wesley so played this
in Zagreb rapid and Blitz uh with up to
the move Queen E4 yeah up up to here
yeah but Bishop Tak of too clearly is
something that leevon you don't do this
over the board he and in particular in
connection with Rook C7 and played
increas 132 132 for both players and I'm
reminded of the interview that leavon
had with Anastasia where leavon
lamenting that uh modern chess and the
chess engines have just shoved the
opening right into the ending this is
what we're seeing and that was where
leavon was saying Fisher random you know
I can't wait for Fisher random to become
the go-to and how do these two Rivals
match up and what are we expecting here
a lot of games certainly a lot of games
you can see 20 draws between the pair
but there you know in the classical
chess it is leevon aronian who does have
a slight Advantage three wins to four in
aonan favor uh by the way just because
you do have it up on your screen once
more Rook C7 Knight C7 Queen E5 Queen
takes E5 no Queen takes F4 Queen takes
tak4 takes takes we go King F3 and are
we playing King F King King E7 F6 or I'm
not sure if it's required but I would
yeah it starts by playing Knight E6 but
I suspect it will come around I suspect
it will actually put the King on F6
because I I really don't like the idea
of this King lending somewhere around D5
F5 and if you don't mind Peter King E7
King F4 King F6 Bishop C5 I'm trying to
get to that King and pawn end game that
we yeah we we're never no I'm playing
9896 here travel on the dark squares Yer
and uh it it's and uh isn't it the
bishop it is very much reminiscent of
that game that yasa brought up a few
shows earlier that that fantastic end
game that fiser won against imanov right
this is not an automatic draw despite it
being five against five and only one
minor piece left on the board sure but
Leon must have looked at this and Leon
must must feel that he knows exactly how
to defend like where where to put his
pawns and so on we'll we'll see how
works out let's briefly revisit revisit
our two knights in which after Knight E4
Queen E6 the position that we discussed
of course no repetitions and the move B2
B3 wow which uh wouldn't occur to me but
appears to be the best the best engine
move which is unsurprising and also the
reply by Fabi like I would have thought
Knight F4 looks very attractive but but
Fab very quickly plays G6 which is also
the suggested reply the queen goes back
to E2 once again also confounding yeah
no I I guess the point is you know we
would like to put it on F3 but we're
running into we're running into Forks
left right and Center uh and queen D1
looks unwieldy so you you choose queen
queen E2 I guess that would be the well
it's funny the lines that I'm familiar
with involve Queen D1 Knight F4 Bishop
F1 it I mean it looks really crazy but
not usually with B3 usually I have D3 on
the bord this looks terrible this looks
like great compensation apparently this
is completely fine for why and I've
already misplayed it from black
compensation yeah looks like great
compensation actually shockingly I think
we are much better off leaving it on D3
where it's in the way okay so it seems
like we're winning a Tempo with Knight
and F4 often I think we're actually
losing a Tempo because we're improving
White's position by moving their most
stupid piece looking to a better Square
which is happens to be the starting
Square you know F5 followed by Bishop G7
followed by Castle short and then we
start let's go moving things down the
the board this seems promising Queen E2
played F5 Knight 4 C3 and this is the
position on the board and once again I'm
expecting Bishop G7 because the king
needs to be uh evacuated from the center
and also it supports E5 V4
wonderfully very strange position I
think if we you know move this Knight to
any kind of a normal square you pick
black you pick black in in a hard bit
but because it's still on A5 and because
it's not participating in the game and
could maybe even become a target of some
tactics later later in the piece this is
not so obvious to me uh how to assess
this uh shout out to veran for telling
is this is actually a game where fuja
was on the black side against nepo of
all people and uh something about this
position fuia found attractive it was a
a game that was played online break this
position down for me because I'm having
a confounded time I would not find this
position attractive in any way with
either white no with white I think B3 is
a very good indication of what we're
trying to achieve what we want is to
play Bishop B2 Knight A3 and we're we're
going this way development well we threw
that out the door the moment we started
playing uh Queen H5 and queen E2 yeah
yeah no this is this is a very strange
position to discuss like the the current
that's very OB let's let's make some
natural moves on the so we get here the
bishop now has the C C4 square and I
mean white is reasonably solid white is
one move away from actually solving
perhaps the biggest problem uh he has
the which is securing the king moving
the king away from the center because
Center doesn't really feel particularly
safe uh so we get here and from here I
think play can continue in any number of
directions I kind of like the idea let's
start with the obvious Knight takes C4
yes I think I think the queen probably
recaptures because if you Rec cupture
with the Knight you're also opening
yourself up to Bishop A6 which is will
be a very annoying P so I think we take
with the queen and the same idea
actually presents itself as a definitely
as a playable move here A5 with the idea
of Bishop A6 also considering the fact
that white almost certainly castles que
inside here having A5 A4 in your back
pocket might be useful White Steel
castles cuz there's really not very much
else you can do and this is a mess like
I I don't know how else to describe it
this is just a just a mess the immediate
Bishop I
gives you a very good Square on C5 I
think this is the explanation for a
somewhat mysterious move I at first
couldn't really decipher at all because
the engine suggest playing Rook F7 I
have a feeling this is to do let me make
a let me make a stupid waiting move yeah
we're giving ourselves the move Bishop
f8 here exactly which could be extremely
useful and it's at least an immediate
draw because taking on A5 will lose you
this queen it has no long no longer has
any squares it has to drop back to D4
and because of the threats along this
diagonal you probably not have better
than a repetition but at least you
definitely have this repetition now
right uh
but clearly I'm helped by my magic
screen uh Fab is playing quickly enough
that another thing I mid sentence I'm
interrupting myself there Fabby lost a
very very painful game in this line yeah
what this does to a player who is as
hardworking as Fabby it normally you
double and triple check everything you
know about this line because this will
feel like a in your arm right it
feels like people might think ah he
doesn't quite know what he's doing there
I will be checking him again right so I
would expect Fabby to be more aware of
what's going on here than he was prior
to the game against Hikaru and even in
the game against hikaro I think there
was just some kind of a brain glitch
because he was playing very precisely up
to a point uh so I wouldn't really be
all that shocked if Fabby not only plays
everything up to but also knows about
Rook F7 mhm wouldn't rule it out wow
they are playing quickly playing Super
quickly and the position I I like like
Peter's explanation of what's white plan
is Knight A3 cast Soul's Queen side but
for the time being the White's position
looks very
clunky I mean uh again I I would be
drawn to attacking the queen on E2 with
Knight F4 also maybe even going the
other direction with Knight to B for
just because I well with well with
Knight B4 you would be setting yourself
up for that E4 and there's a knight C2
but I I'm with you 100% when you're
talking about the move Knight F4 because
you are provoking the queen back to F1
the real problem though is you think
you're doing yourself this great big
favor of eliminating this bishop and
winning the two Bishops the problem is
the bishop on D3 is such the only really
really bad piece that white has so
spending time winning it I'm not sure
who who who's getting the better of that
deal that's the problem I don't think
we're taking on D3 pretty much ever our
Knight on F4 feels like a much more
attacking piece but I spend some time
checking these things out after kn4 it
does go back to f f and I was curious as
to what happens after e54 here and this
is very interesting it's like white
white is playing this weird game of of
Corners where like you're trying you're
trying to group everything into as
compact a bunch of pieces as possible
Right but shockingly white will still
get to play Knight A3 white will still
get to play long castles and the engine
suggests we've actually moved our Pieces
away from the squares they need to be
Yanka suggestion of Knight B4 is
actually much more interesting because
you're creating a massive threat of e54
here if you go Knight A3 here you you
have not equalized anymore because after
Queen takes C4 even Queen takes C4 is
very strong but apparently even stronger
is a quiet move Queen E7 and now Bishop
A6 threatens to actually capture this
queen ouch so white has to spend two
temp just to save it and now we castle
and we have a massive attack everywhere
this is just bad for white but after
Knight B4 you can make this quad Mo F2
F3 which wow is all of this is a bit
shocking to me yes stopping e54 is so
important then we're investing a full
Tempo in just physically fighting
against the ball arriving on the E4 s
you shall not pass and then and then
once again we want to play Knight A3 we
want to play Knight A3 we want to C long
and if Black Goes castles and Rook d8
apart from castling long which is still
playable Machin says now that the Knight
is away we can actually something I
really did not expect to happen in any
variation yeah white can go this
direction we haven't really completely
ruled it out yet and then Knight C4
becomes a threat and we no longer need
to worry about our King being vulnerable
on the queen side so both Knight F4 and
KN B4 are playable but it seems like
they're not the best moves and also
something that I wanted to point out
uh why aren't we playing E5 E4
immediately for a very specific reason
my takes D5 G7 is hanging and there's
also this massive massive
threek you know Fork has four times this
has three times so it's a th we called
it a family Fork uh but I I like th th
yeah and then
two and W obiously uh by the way that
move Castle short is disrespectful on
every level
I just thought I'd get that one in there
while I could and uh we do have Castles
by Fabby Knight
A3 uh on the board again inviting all of
what whatever it is you like Knight B4
Knight F4 inviting those moves uh for
black okay castles Knight A3 on the
board and what I really wanted to point
out was the the clock times ali raaza uh
1 hour 30 two minutes he's gained two
hours two hours he's gained two hours
he's gained two minutes and 45 seconds
from the starting time control yeah I
mean he's put his free day to use he
certainly has and one thing I really
like about ali Resa style is that he's
had the most complex Dynamic games out
of everyone so far absolutely I mean
some of them you know they've been
absolutely Wild yeah he was riding his
luck against Richard report he escaped
that one and uh against Dominguez that
was incredibly wild as well from quite
innocuous position and uh here we see
him in action uh for me that um rapid
game rapid chess game against Wesley so
where he sacrificed his Queen with Queen
takes F5 for two minor pieces some ponds
and Wesley's King was racing up the
board that was uh the game the rapid and
Blitz uh game at the tournament there as
certainly this young man I mean if he
were to miss that that's what I wanted
to harp on for just a second is we we
showed that graphic of their ratings
being tied literally one point between
him and Wesley and just a few points
rating points between those two players
Wesley fua and
Anish and let's face it I mean to my
mind I've defined my career by the
number of times I got to the candidates
I've made it twice and it's a career
defining moment when you make it to the
candidates and one rating I mean that's
rough uh well one rating point so far
anything
can four games remaining exactly
absolutely especially when you see
2756 I mean come on I mean 27 that's a
lot of rating points and then one rating
Point could could be the determinant
factor it's incredibly close at the top
but moving away moving our our Focus
away from from alz a little bit this is
very very interesting to me this is a
game between Anish gir and lard
Dominguez and this is a game I don't
believe I've seen Anish do this maybe
ever right and this game really
indicates to me that Anish took a really
hard look at what's going on in the
tournament and he realized with ala
losing he actually has a decent shot if
he if he wins two games in the last four
he probably just gets in because of how
close the field is if he wins one and
everybody else draws he Leap Frogs
Wesley and gets the rating spot doesn't
have to worry about the circuit anymore
right uh and this
is uh Anish is unbelievably well booked
up and what he's doing here is he's
playing this kind of a I don't even know
what to call it it's not exactly a close
Sicilian it's a it's a you know I will
give you mate on the kingside opening a
very long name it's very similar to a
Grand Prix right similar to a Grand Prix
but the bishop is on G2 not on C4 so
it's it's a spiritual you know
descendant maybe or or relative of all
of these things right so he goes D3 here
and then he just goes in F4 uh D6 Knight
H3 which is actually something that they
do quite a lot these days because this
Knight drops back to F2 you can maybe
bring the other one to F3 solving the
problem of what to do with the
KN so Knight H3 ler goes H5 Knight F2 by
the way H5 is the
novelty but I would assume this is
already an incredibly rare position up
to night I wouldn't expect this to be
particularly well traveled it it's not
well traveled but there are some names
here playing this I I
saw I saw Richard I think I might have
seen Richard reports maybe not with a
knight on ag3 but his name was there and
then I I see other
names like federov actually he's played
a few times
moissan yeah those names I would
associate with with this because I've
played for the same for the same club
with San for years and years and he just
likes querky unusual positions right
whereas Anish just beats you in Mainline
openings because he knows them better
than you do so so for him to go here is
is really quite striking H5 is a very
clever move here because with
threatening Bishop G4 and white doesn't
really want to be have having to play
Queen so Knight F2 very logical I
expected ler to start with Knight F6
because even Knight G4 here will be a
bit of an annoying threat because you
don't quite know what to do with it
perhaps we provoke H3 and then we play
E5 but starting with E5 is also very
very logical just immediately fighting
for central control now I guess this
Knight gets developed to C3 because we
were we were given uh a Target in the
center the Black Knight probably gets
developed to E7 now right Bishop could
go to E6 Queen D7 this is very very
interesting and very uh is H4 ever an
idea I mean that was certainly tried
against me at the club level I think
we're not that unhappy about G4 in this
particular structure yes we're giving
for the time being black has a very
decent Square on E5 but we don't have to
care about that too deeply although I
mean it's certainly playable for black
because shifting black away from these
light dark squares and particular now
that t right is on F3 and not on F2 and
not on3 is not going to not going to be
easy but we have a very St structure we
can support it with H2 H3 so that
nothing hangs we have potential of
playing Knight D5 C3 D4 in some very
happy future if we achieve that I'm not
sure if we ever do but we can a good day
yeah we can we can look forward to that
so H4 is a move you can also just keep
the tension for the time you know you
can play Bishop B6 you can perhaps keep
the the options with for the Knight on
G8 in reserve because this could some
still be a useful option although I do
feel like it probably belongs on E7 now
yeah but returning to my original point
point this is Anish saying I absolutely
need to win a game I do not want to
compete with year in you know Main in
who knows some kind of a Mainline
Spanish for instance I want to play a
very very fresh position in which once
again knowing the kind of a chess player
line year is he will start thinking on
move three actually on move one as we
found out yeah and already uh Anish has
a 20 minute advantage on the clock which
is only bound to get bigger even
increase yeah yeah knowing how how
linear approaches Chess By the way KN C3
was his choice and just going back to
the chess I have one basic question
where is White going to put the
king I think even King side is not out
of the question I don't think H4 G4
unless you can immediately followed up
with H3 that would be annoying but as
long as we're controlling the H3 square
and also we don't need to decide for now
I think there is still some time for us
before we need to decide we can go
Bishop B3 we can go Queen D2 keeping
both options somewhat open mhm but I
still feel like it's probably
kingside uh we shall see uh from the
barbaric Northwest we had Grandmaster
Duncan settles who loved playing these
setups with uh F4 Knight H3 Knight F2 so
I have seen these systems a lot and
often times white does play this very
early Knight D5 the idea being trade on
D5 and I get the E4 square and
let's demonstrate so something like this
happens the white now has a very
pleasant Square to look forward exactly
exactly and usually to your question
Castle short is normally where the white
king uh at least I've seen uh head I
just want to say at the very very start
I I reminded was speaking with uh
Grandmaster Michael Steen uh Michael was
the uh second for Victor kcho in the
bagio City match 1978 the world
championship match between between kchoi
and karpov and for I don't know 20 games
kchoi had been beating his head on all
of the established opening Theory and
they were shattered they just nothing
was working against Anatoli karpov so
Michael just said to him at breakfast
Victor play G3 I mean just play chess
just play G3 and play chess and Victor
crushed him with just you know get out
of the you know stop you know having of
these main lines yeah it's very often a
very good advice play chess out of your
own way yeah yeah yeah too much mind
yeah exactly as we might say G2 G3 on
the board and uh away they have gone and
again uh Anish Gary very very much in
the candidates race for the uh rating
spot Joy where would you like to take
nice combative game and let's go back to
Wesley's game and the fight for first
they first and look in this ending of
Knight versus bishop and
Wesley uh looking around here um I'm
assuming he's going to play Bishop D3 to
E4 yeah you can you can start with
Bishop C4 but we'll we'll get back to
that one yeah well you can you can
Bishop d34 you can also start with this
sort of lure it to D3 and go Bishop D3
and then a very cute little tactic here
if black plays H6 we have this move G2
G4 moving it away from an attacked
Square and then picking up picking up
the pawn next because this actually
doesn't doesn't doesn't result in a
queen and we'll probably lose right uh
but yeah Bishop D3 is probably more
natural not not really having to worry
about all of these things is probably
pretty useful D3 Bishop take on a phonu
move I'm a bit I'm a bit surprised by by
95 I thought there were cleaner ways
right we were looking at kingy 7 and
king of six we prepared a graphic joy
for our
show uh thanks to Ben and uh he had uh
said who plays well who who's the best
player after a rest day yeah because the
rest is a very rest days are very
important because yes there are time for
recuperating they can also put a player
out of their Rhythm and well thanks to
Ben Underwood we can actually take a
look and we can see that Wesley so
doesn't play wello doesn't do that great
so here we go and uh Fabiano has the POS
highest positive jump uh in tournament
performance after the rest day sounds
good and aronia mvl show increases of
performance so whatever they're doing
it's working but for wly say well he
perhaps needs to shake things up because
he seems to perform significantly worse
in later rounds a question of stamina me
thinks nepo and garyi perform worse in
later rounds as well uh you TI on scene
we haven't done the statistics on your
career Joie but if you were to answer
yourself uh following a rest day do you
come full of themen vigor and you score
better do I do come full of like Vigor
that's the way I felt about mik but but
the results say otherwise no you've
checked your own stats no I don't well
actually I've just have personal
experience so I was just now competing
in the European Team Championship had a
reasonable score
after the rest day two losses in a row
it's like come on what the heck how
about you yourself Peter jump in on that
one as well yeah for me I'm generally a
kind of an anxious starter I need to
play myself into the tournament and then
uh the rest day the day after the rest
day feels like a second round one for me
like I've never really uh and I often
need them and it feels like in a
particular hard tournament like you you
absolutely feel exhausted you feel like
you need to recharge but then you sit
down at the board and it's like you you
haven't played the previous fight like
you once again have to remember how the
pieces move so I don't know what whether
the stats will bear bear this out but
rest days aren't particularly the
feeling is very kind of double- edged
because very often you feel like please
I I need one day to to be to be away
from the board but then but then the
return is uh Frau with additional danger
so yeah I I don't know anxiety and also
there's mind games that play right
because yeah you have a day to rest but
your opponent has a day to rest or
prare exactly I was always of that
persuasion where I always thought my
preparation was well not good and my
opponent boy I was fearful that they had
reinvented the automobile by the time we
got to the board uh how about yourselves
did you feel that you were your
opponents were were using the rest day
better than yourselves well actually the
last last time I the rest my rest day in
the European team champion I thought it
was very well spent you know I went to
setty St Stefan really which was the
scene of the iconic Fisher against spasy
1992 match I actually stood on the the
balcony above the restaurant where they
played and I was like Feel The Vibes I
mean I mean this is all the preparation
I need and then I went and uh Clank
Clank yeah you Peter uh did you ever
feel that were you worried that your
opponent's pre preparation was going to
out prepare you somehow during the West
day or I stopped I stopped worrying
about that a long time ago I know that
in most tournaments I play and I will be
the the least prepared player in the
field so I like I don't need to invest
any more mental energy into worrying
about these things I've accepted my fate
right uh for me it was pretty much uh
that I was the ill most ill prepared and
I remember very vividly going to a war
World Team Championship where we had a
coach uh Ben fold and this was great so
Ben would come to my room about 10 in
the morning and uh we we we'd prepare
all the games and the crazy part is we
never got the
prep we never got the prep I wanted but
then instilled upon me this feeling of
confidence I went to the game with an
idea an idea I didn't get to show but
because I had that confidence it was
really it was awesome I kind of like was
surfing this this wave of confidence and
I think that's very important for chess
players that they do have this feeling
that you know it's going to go well you
know I I saw an interesting tweet by a
grandmas I can't quite recall who it was
who said that there's two sins in chess
overconfidence and underconfidence and
this is of the two it's always much much
better to be overconfident that was me
the moment I had to equal ized I thought
I was
better we have C2 C4 by Wesley so what's
going on this is very interesting
because this is a very direct approach
uh night B4 we will just Play3 and there
are no good jumps forward so you have to
go back and then you lose the F4 pawn
and white is better we've improved the
naal move here is the strongest you play
Bishop Knight E3 sorry and the
interesting part for me was and
something that I intuitively felt might
be the problem with the move C4 although
I didn't expect it to be born out the
way it appears to be born out after
Bishop pitu the engine among other
things suggests that you do have to play
G3 or G4 now because your Pawn is
hanging clear and now I'm pretty sure
it's it wouldn't be true with the pawn
on C2 but with the pawn on C4 what it
now says we can go for this
position because you will have to deal
with the pawn on H2 you cannot pick it
up with the bishop event eventually this
needs to happen right and you've given
me a hook on C4 to immediately play
against wow and and this apparently
holds very very comfortably for black
now because there is just going to be
enough time for the king to go and start
attacking this this group of Pawns in
fact the king doesn't even go in that
direction whoa whoa whoa just a second
time out if I can challenge the engine
here King D4 yeah King D4 it goes B6
yeah Bishop H1 you keep going I want you
to yeah Bishop G2 you you go go ahead I
think I think we are
going yeah King E3 okay King E5 yeah
Bishop H1 I wanted you to put all your
pawns on H3 and F4 but doesn't your king
just get and now we Shuffle here because
you you can't go in this direction
because I will start entering and if you
play King G3 I'm not going to go to G4
I'm going to stand here and say please
show me a plan of some okay so go ahead
and play Bishop G2 King E5 Bishop F3
King E5 Bishop
E4 let me okay let me can you wait on F3
yes exactly I would like to wait on F3
with the bishop just because then at
least you block out the king coming to
G4 ever okay so no in this POS yes and I
want you to play so you have to play H5
this almost looks like a study right so
we do it all again and then you go H5
you go hang on a second let me you know
what I'm trying to do is get you into a
zwang uh Tom our producer's favorite
chess phrase oh I get it when I play
Bishop e my Bishop's in the way of the
king you go King F6 yeah we can we can
drop back I'm pretty sure we have enough
squares yet and what is talking about
here is that this is not actually tuang
what what what yaser is trying to
achieve is get to his King to E4 but I
can very safely go king6 here and then
return to the good Square exactly so
this is a mechanism we the the fact that
this is allowed I think makes Black's
life a lot easier and I think probably
the same thing will apply to Bishop D3
if you play Bishop D3 I'll play H6 and
after although with the king's back on
f8 I'm less sure that this works let's
see if if it completely bottoms out
here King E7 yeah we kind of need to
play King D6 already in this position
yeah it's a wow there's a big difference
I don't quite understand why it's so big
ah because the pawn gets to C5 and the
pawns get fixed on you really want them
on B6 and C5 for black you don't want
them on light squares and this appears
to be completely lost now yeah the
evaluation just says yeah here you're
actually dead because eventually white
will start wow generating threats so
there's a massive one Nuance yeah
massive
difference it looked like it was like a
sophisticated idea that maybe white can
also use in other positions as well wow
okay we just went from the opening to
the ending night ending I mean it was a
big dive uh bottom line uh I still feel
this should be a draw but it's as you
can see it's quite tricky because uh if
if you can't rely on the same tactic if
you after G3 here but but yeah but now
you have 91 this is the reason it was
playing Bish B2 because because now
after let's say H5 you still have to
invest in a in in one more move at least
to prepare to prepare G3 and if B3 I
think we can go back to and okay now
apparently I lost to Bishop B4 and King
takes F4 just straight up lost because I
play I played H5 I think the problem
here is I played H5 and this is now a
weakness wow and this is apparently not
quick enough yeah because why just goes
A2 A4 all the pawn endings up pretty
much lost because of the which we the
night's on a bad circuit right and the
night is really not well positioned at
all now this is very intricate and I'm a
little bit worried about Leon thinking
because I just want to go back to this
idea that if you if you enter this end
game and Leon was clearly aiming for it
everything up to Rook C7 included was
blitzed out he was above 130 on the
clock if you go into this end game and
then you start thinking after
C4 this is this is a very this is a very
losable end you know something this
reminds me of uh law when I studied law
one of the things that they said about
the weakness of lawyers is that they're
very bothered by
inconsistency and it's inconsistent what
Leon has done right he played so quickly
toit Spitz Blitz and now he's taking his
time it's like no no no no keep on
blitzing yeah right yeah I there's
something similar I I I prepared victtor
Coro in a very very very deep uh
variation of the Queen's Gambit tar took
over madana Bondi system tmbb as we call
it and it was like 20 uh moves of
analysis he blitzed to move 18 and
stopped it's like no Victor keep going
keep going keep go and he got side uh
sidetracked uh you mentioned a I was
saying coming in on the show because we
are our two co-leaders at plus one are
competing against each other and what a
huge game this could be for Wesley a
kind of a career game for the candidates
for the sing ratings singfield cup I
mean he would go plus two if he were to
win this game and just because of the
bishop versus night ending you have to
be careful with the night and things can
happen this is this is another thing
that I always Tred to avoid in my own
opening preparation such as it is
is I felt I should do one of the two
things you either play
aiming to get positions that you will
like right or you should be aiming to
make an actual
draw what you shouldn't be getting is an
end game you feel you will draw but
don't know exactly how because that that
I mean Leon is better than me at
defending but still I don't think it's a
particularly comfortable thing to be uh
to to be working out over the board
because you play the sun game with black
you know you will not be presented with
a single chance to play for a win
there's no fun to be had here mhm uh so
for
me if I'm aiming for this I will
actually spend quite a bit of time at
home working out exactly how the pieces
should be positioned working out all the
kind of intricacies like what I can
allow what I can't allow which uh for
instance will this will this pce
sacrifice work in which cases it it will
in which cases it won't and him starting
to think and going KN C7 by the way is
that what he did yeah he played he he
thought for quite some time and when
Knight C7 and now the engine says Bishop
D3 H6 Bishop F5 massive Advantage for
white once again it might be the kind of
a plus one that is not actually winning
it's just very enjoyable but it is it is
going tojoy it is going to be very
enjoyable for white very important move
Bishop of five there completely denying
all kinds of you know something we've
seen this quite often at the s f cup
that people have been racing through
their preparation then they pause they
get into trouble M uh not a good sign
for levon's fans let's just uh continue
because I I think there was a couple
games that one game between Richard
reports and Maxim vasher lra and guess
what they have uh really been zipping
themselves okay we have a sicilian or an
attempted a sicilian with an laughing
with Bishop E2 Bishop E2 but we have to
show the big trick yeah this was taught
in all the English chess circles here
well I've seriously I mean I believe
I've made every mistake possible in
Chess at least
once I usually tried to do it twice just
to be sure it was a mistake the first
time and I think I've fallen for this
particular one about 12 times in my
career I mean it just it it never gets
old it never gets old the old check and
I think it was you versus Gary Kasparov
tilberg tournaments where you was the
inspiration offered Gary a pawn he
didn't take it no he didn't take he took
it later uh that was a very kind of a
late decision to go for this and uh It
produced a kind of a famous in in narrow
circles quote after the game Gary said
if we start looking at C3 Sicilians
we'll never get anything done and and
that was sort of exactly the point
because I felt that you know competing
with Gary's knowledge in the nidorf and
I play I actually played some nids
against him in my life but that that day
I didn't really feel like it and very
close to the game I found this obscure
game I think uh
uh Jean Mar deg gra I think with white
played this Pawn sacrifice and Gary
played KN B7 which I I still think is a
very good move here specifically aiming
to provoke D2 D3 early now the pawn is
of course hanging it needs to be
protected and then you play B6 before G6
just to seemingly completely stop D3 D4
castles and you play G6 and if black
gets to play Bishop G7 castles you know
I start honestly start preferring black
in these types of positions but my idea
for that game was was this this Pawn
sacrifice with D3 D4 and
yeah it still still brings a smile to my
face that it was a nice victory that was
that was a very pleasant day yeah yeah
yeah bitting somebody I idolized my my
entire life in our first tournament game
that was that was a good day what has
happened instead though yeah G6 Bishop
G7 is a very very logical approach here
but it's forever been considered to be
slightly inferior compared maybe to some
other things specifically because of
Bishop B5 check and this is a kind of a
strange line you've spent a Tempo on
Bishop B2 and now you're giving this
check in two moves
right but the point is you will get to
play Rook E1 and D4 or even the
immediate D4 in one tempo as in the game
for inance after Bishop D7 we're going
to take and they even because of how uh
annoying these types of positions are
although the engine doesn't say it's
annoying but it feels like in human
terms this big this big Center does
something uh so people have even started
doing this just to kind of immediately
sidestep it develop the Knight to C6 and
have more play against the White Center
and if if kn 6 which is what uh mvl
played you get to play D4 in one tempo
because now this pin is really going to
cost you a piece and mvl castles D5
Knight A5 and he clearly he's playing
quickly enough he's only just started
thinking basically that this is
something that he at some point clearly
thought about and figured out that this
is the approach that he wants to take
Rook E1 looks very logical the pawn is
after all hanging mhm E7 E6 is I think
logical here but he prefers to start
with Bishop D7 I think it's very
instructive actually how Maxim handles
this position because if you give um
Richard one move then white is going to
go A2 A4 clamp down on any counter play
on The Queen side and then just enjoy
the space advantage that the pawn on D5
gives
him Bish Bishop F1 and by the way uh mvl
my pick for the tournament with a 50%
score all draws still only Trails uh by
half a point I mean if he could get a
win or two to be honest so close that
any if anyone notches up some wins then
they are going to be right there it's
not how you start it's how you
finish Deep Thoughts uh continue the uh
so after D7 I think it's logical not to
trade on D7 because trading I think
makes Black's life after both 97 and
queen G7 easier so Bishop F1 and mvl
immediately goes B7 B5 stopping ianka
correctly said A4 is a threat even C4
giving this Knight a very very
comfortable Square on C3 is I think a
good idea but I I always thought the
Knight on A5 was misplaced and the idea
behind B5 as we see in a lot of Spanish
is is to give it squares whether it be
Knight C4 or just as you pointed out C5
C4 now again if I'm in white shoes and
I'm thinking to myself if I were black
and black plays E5 looks like he has a
perfectly acceptable ruy yeah so I play
E5 I think E5 is very logical you could
also wait for on it a little bit because
I'm not sure uh let's say if we go H3 I
don't think you're currently threatening
E5 because after d takes E6 you will
find yourself having to choose which one
you which one to blunder you know you
the B5 or the D6 yeah you will either
blunder that yeah so E5 is not that
prepared yet we can also include Bishop
F4 which is the ideal Square for the
bishop I don't know something like this
perhaps Knight B2 to follow and
eventually but E4 E5 is a very very
thematic uh thematic break in all of
these structures of course which Richard
has played and Richard yeah why prepare
it if we can play it already Okay and
what's the result going to be after I
guess a capture trade on the Cent I I
also assume D5 is more or less Force but
you can actually if you want a really
sharp position you can play Knight G4
here because I think this is just an
improvement for black I would be very
happy about The E points coming off the
board this now feels like a more open
diagonal for this bishop B5 B4 but
becomes a topic you also have the E file
like I want to play Queen B6 perhaps
play Rook E8 fight for the E file seems
like a very very playable position for
black so the question becomes how do how
do all of these lines work and I don't
really have a good answer because after
F takes C6 you probably want to throw in
H3 because D6 Bishop C6 you've given
black seemingly quite a lot of play
against the king side this feels like
initiative black so you probably play H3
drops back you go D6 Bishop C6 and for
instance there are these ideas now that
there is this very unpleasant uh Pawn
right in
heart of Black's position you can land
your knight on F7 and ask black how do
you like dealing dealing with that
particular piece feels like a wedgie so
very understandably the engine suggests
going KN B7 I think with a very specific
threat of something like Queen C7 the
queen C8 let's say we make a move yeah
and the queen goes here and then we want
to play Knight d8 and with the Knight on
d8 we can start chasing the Knight away
from G5 but these are very very sharp
S4 D5 Knight E5
this feels playable for black because
once again apart from this very nice
looking knight on E5 everything else is
back right on first rank yeah uh you
would like to play once again you would
like to play probably C4 Knight B7
Knight C5 or Bishop D7 F5 is a useful
move but you have to worry about the
pawn on B5 so let's say we go A7 A6
preparing Bishop
F5 seems seems fine to be honest it
doesn't seem like this should be a
massive problem because the pawn on D5
is actually quite vulnerable if we make
a waiting move it already can only be
defended after Bishop F5 by tactical
means and I'm not even sure if tactical
means are particularly good for white so
white needs to be more precise maybe
even the move like C3 C4 here is
required but then we get to a kind of a
position like this which feels like a
pretty decent bco to me the a pawn is
still on the board right first of all um
it's it's I mean white is also
completely fine it's not like white has
done much wrong but this shouldn't be
too bad no I'm I'm not a big fan of
pushing that pawn to E5 I I would much
rather developed my pieces gone H3 let
the tension Brew I liked your Bishop F4
as well uh I always thought in this
particular position with the move E4 E5
what am I doing at its most basic I'm
opening up the position excellent Pat
myself on the back I'm opening up the
position opening up the position for the
side who's best developed in this
position Maxim obviously is much better
developed I mean all of White's pieces
seem to be on the first rank so a move
like E5 opening up the position might
simply Boomerang and I love that
variation that Peter was mentioning
Knight
G4 Fe if I'm black I'm embracing this
position with both arms I'm thinking to
myself Black's Bishops look good the
Knight on A5 is temporarily offside but
what I've just done wait a minute just a
you know exactly Rook takes Rook F3 so I
have to include H3 as Peter was
mentioning to in order to drive back the
Knight now here there was actually a
moment I I even considered Knight E5
Peter looked at Knight F6 takes Bishop
here and Knight G5 I have to tell you I
I feel like I've gone wrong it just
feels like you know white is attacking
with the Knight on G5 and nothing
else okay maybe H7 H6 is a little bit
awkward for black to get in but it just
feels like I'm uh I've helped my
opponent and so I would avoid this uh as
wonder whether after moves like Knight
G5 maybe white shouldn't get tempted by
the faray with the pawn e E6 and instead
just try to maintain the tension a
little bit more by going Bishop F4
that's what I would be doing okay Bishop
F4 because I mean if you can trade off
some minor pieces then at least you've
got a great you're going to have a great
Rook on E5 and you've got a Target on E7
exactly so bishop and I got some thumbs
up there and a smile from our grandm
absolutely no Bishop F4 uh feels uh like
a much better choice uh just uh
developing uh I if you don't mind I I'll
just take a pause and uh oh uh how do
they match up these two let's check out
standings GES between standings ahead
and uh well once again this is somewhat
surprising mvl with a lead with one
point to Richard and four victories for
maxim bash theph eight draws though yeah
that's a lot of draws uh could we go
back to the Ali Raza Fabby game because
uh I'm more than curious as to how uh
Fabby
handled we got to the position we were
discussing after Bishop C Bishop C4 the
trade happened and instead of our
somewhat computer is A5 Rook of7
sequence which I quite liked but once
again you know we're conditioned now to
like what the machine tells us uh fa did
something quite human he went Rook B8
Rook B4 the queen will now drop back to
E2 I don't really see any reason to put
it on F1 and queen C5 Bishop D4 isop not
great so it goes back to E2 I'm pretty
sure and now you have to figure out how
you're going to uh generate counterplay
you pretty much always I think play A7
A5 which just makes a lot of sense
because you you do want to be at least
hinting at A5 A4 in all of these
positions and somewhat interestingly to
me uh the engine suggests that basically
the setup for
Black is very difficult to challenge
there are no I would be looking at moves
like F3 or I mean I can't play D3 but my
idea here with white would be I need to
to break to dig to dig yeah like this is
this is a chain I would very much like
to start dismantling Brick by Brick
right uh whereas the engine says no it's
much more important to get pieces off
the board while also improving the black
structure because this is obviously even
more harmonious with the with the pawns
potentially streaming down the board it
goes D3 here which is maybe a partial
explanation for it and the position
remains very very sharp and I think you
need to play very precisely here with
black because yes this looks beautiful
but it's a pawn but it's a pawn and a
lot of pieces have already come off the
board this is not really a middle game
uh
by any stretch so if you imagine white
getting to play I don't know King B1
Rook H E1 the queen probably belongs on
dark squares here so Queen C3 you will
at some point run out of active things
to do and you will start struggling but
for the time being apparently Queen E5
with the intention of meeting King B1
with with Bishop B6 and then maybe A5 A4
starts coming in uh this still gives
black just enough right this moment this
appears to be enough but after Queen
D2 you either have to allow D3 D4 which
stops your counterplay but also really
secures your structure or you can go in
for really really sharp line starting
from here which to my eyes I mean it
currently says it's a completely dra
drawn very
dry obvious obvious troll no I would say
that my I mean but black has
compensation black has won the pawn back
won the equal material equal material D4
strect is the only move everything else
loses Queen C7 check you have to play uh
King G8 but this is massively sharp
because you have moves like Queen C6
attacking the entire King side and then
follow it up with H4 H5 and this king is
not safe either so this is a very very
messy position that will be very
difficult to to assess in Practical
terms if you don't have access to
engines which they obviously don't uh so
no this is this is a fabulous uh
fabulous game to watch because I have a
feeling they might both be on their own
now mhm the position is uh uh very fresh
you don't really have very many
templates in your head as to how how to
how to play setups like this this is a
kind of a Martian landscape you don't
get these structures very often so this
is a very exciting game for us to to to
be in the front row seats for and it's a
very clear cut one side is attacking the
other side defending I mean who does
this psychologically
favor well I mean uh from Ali raz's
perspective he's got a in the pocket if
he's going to suffer an attack if he's
going to if he's going to be uh on the
back foot on the defensive he's got to
have something to look forward to and an
extra Pawn in the end game as we know
that could be enough uh to win it I'm
just thinking once again of the position
after Queen E2 and Knight takes D5
because in a certain way you know we're
just we're just training Peter not to
play moves like Knight takes D5 and
support our opponents yeah your two
instincts are very much fighting against
each other here because you are under
some pressure your king is not entirely
safe
so removing some pieces of the board is
very much something that they tell you
is is is good idea is good you strive
for it but improving the structure so
dramatically for your opponent is going
to be a bit of a challenge I think right
and on on Yan's question I wanted to say
and I've been kind of returning to this
over and over again in uh when I talk
about Chess
because something that Magnus kind of
mentioned off hand in one of the
interviews after the match against Fabby
in New York kind of stuck with me
because I'm sure I maybe understood it
on some incomplete level but he just put
it so cleanly in that mat as you
remember they were playing the Sicilian
with with Fabi on the white side where
uh Fabi would play 95 against the vesnik
if we can since there's a pause in
action this this will be better I think
with a demonstration they were playing
the structure called constantly it
became a very focal point of their match
a tabia yeah yeah
where by move
12ish in particular in the Knight E7
lines not Knight B8 leads to C positions
but in particular in the Knight E7 lines
they were playing this really weird
positions
where black would Castle short and
actually belong in ib8 as well but the
point here is uh when white wins here
White wins by winning something on the
queen side like perhaps winning a pawn
somewhere and and uh or or let's say in
uh in in these positions yeah like if
you uh if you discuss the other
structure they were also discussing
quite quite yeah and now like some
position like this obviously I'm mixing
up the more it doesn't matter so what
white is trying to achieve here is
positional advantages on the on the
queen side right whereas what black is
trying to achieve when when when this
happens and this happens is mate is
and he said he found that this imbalance
is actually a lot more important than
people give it credit for because it's
just a lot more comfortable to be
playing for the end of the game like
your threats are sort of higher in in
the pecking order than white threats
right and I thought I thought about it
for a while I thought yeah that that
makes perfect sense to me
because you you just feel like you're
doing more you feel like you're creating
a lot more pressure on your opponent
eventually both things win
like wh you will dominate me
positionally yeah White's end game also
wins if it succeeds right but it doesn't
feel as visceral it doesn't feel as
immediate as this idea that if I do
something wrong on the king side now I
will just get m in 10 minutes uh and I
think very similar things can be said uh
about this position right where honestly
I think it's more comfortable to play
with black for the exact same reasons
because we're trying to do something
against the white king our ideas are
pretty Direct
and it is white who needs to work out
how to maneuver against it avoiding
Checkmate very very important Jo we get
ready our uh break uh first uh tell us
our current standings before we go on
yes and uh you can see at the top of the
table is Wesley so with three points out
of five but in second place is leevon
aronin with two and a half points out of
four the game imbalance is because of
young kristofh duda's withdrawal in
round two EXA and everything to play for
yeah and a lot of uh story uh lines uh
here with the ratings and the candidate
seats up for grabs as we go on break
we're going to check in with our friends
at uh qti stl.com and we have today uh
the SFI cup jacket this year s f cup uh
jacket can keep you warm for years to
come I love this jacket by the way it's
really really nice uh with this
amazingly comfortable jacket it features
an embroideried 2023 SNF Cup logo on the
left rest the St Louis chess club logo
on the back of the neck and the 2023
Grand chest tour logo on the right
sleeve the jacket is in stock in both
men's and women's Styles please do check
out qti stl.com for all your chess
shopping needs and it's unbelievable we
are having a holiday sale discount J
absolutely you can check out the store
in person or go you do your shopping
online but QB stl.com is the place to be
and uh we are going to take a a short
break and after the break well we are
going to be joined by a special guest Dr
Paula Knight will be joining us here in
the studio but earlier on we asked the
players how did the snfi cup impact
their chess careers so have a look and
enjoy this video
[Music]
what role has singfield Cup played in
your chess career yeah it's I mean
singfield cup is of course Very known
and very prestigious tournament yeah
it's indeed my first time in you know
classical classical chess and when I was
younger it was definitely you know like
the most Val valuable to play the strong
guys and you know and to win some games
especially in beat and Rapids well it's
one of the strongest tournaments in the
world so obviously it's always nice to
be in the tournament I played um only
couple of times but it's place in a
tournament where I tend to play well so
I always feel happy to to be here again
in 20 2013 it was the first uh time for
me to to come to the Midwest before I've
only been uh you know to California and
I didn't know really what to expect I
don't know somehow we created such a
relationship I think with the chess club
from from that first tournament that I I
felt like home here because uh here uh
really I mean the people working at the
club and Rex and everybody involved in
chess are so very friendly I think this
is the Midwest type of friendliness that
I feel comfortable with my performance
in the in the singfield Cup history has
always been up and down I mean playing
since
2015 you know you're playing against the
very best players in the world it's a
very very tough very strong tournament
and it's it's fun to play I think I
played here
for one okay for several times yeah I
know it's very challenging otherwise
yeah it's just a tournament when where
you can you can face like arguably
strongest opposition and one of the most
challenging events every year so
normally I'm happy to to come and play
here well it's been a special tournament
for me I've won it twice that was really
quite breakthrough because I think it
was the first Super tournament I one
I've been playing here since 2014 I
think I've only missed the first edition
which was only four players the way
we've been treat it's also set a
standard for elite chess tournaments in
terms of how to treat uh the players and
how to make a tournament great I have um
great memories here um you know seld cup
is one of the fixtures in the chess
calendar I I don't think I've won it yet
but I'll I'll give it a shot this time
I'm looking forward to add St Louis to
my small list of fixures when I started
chess it started here to be the first I
the first time 2012 or 13 so I was
following it since I started chess
everybody was playing here and we were
watching by internet and it was really
like motivational for me and I always
learned a lot from here well I think for
me it's rather unique because the first
event that I played in the United States
after a long break from because I grew
up in uh in New York I was born in
Florida and I I started my chess career
in the United States in New York and
then I moved to Europe so for many of my
formative years I was I was living and
training in Europe and playing in Europe
and then my first event back 2014 my
first big event back was the sinkfield
cup so I I hadn't uh come to the US for
a long time I hadn't played in the US
for many many years and then I came to
St Louis and I didn't really know much I
didn't know anything about the city I
didn't know much about the chess club it
was a chess event that was at the time
the strongest in the world with Magnus
Levon they were the first two players in
the world I didn't have so many
expectations but it ended up being my
best event my best performance I've ever
had and so yeah I have like a special
kind of memory of the singfield cup and
since then I've played every Edition so
from 2014 onward uh some events not as
well some events quite well but I always
have very good emotions being
[Music]
here hello I'm women's Grand Master V
janova I will be creating content for
Grand chest store follow us on social
media and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today yeah um it's amazing what the club
has done for chess in general because I
mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless uh national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping gr schools and they've just
grown the game so much across the United
States I think if I look at my own
career and I look at American chess in
general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr junor
singfield and Rex sing I would say that
St luia Club is like a rock in the ocean
of chess and we know that it's it's
there it is there it will be there I
think it sense a hope that the the game
of chess will always stay Al flat by the
mere fact of its existence I think it it
it sends positive waves across the
[Music]
globe the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess is has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
bouti stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area area
active in over 100 schools throughout
the St Louis city and county the St
Louis chess club has been able to reach
over 85,000 students in both in school
and after school programs we view chess
as a valuable educational tool learn
more about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education hello I'm women's ground
master ranoa I will take you behind the
scenes of the grest store follow us on
social media and miss out on players
interviews and more content from the
playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex singfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chess
piece sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
familyfriendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
awardwinning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit worldes
h.org
[Music]
hello and uh welcome back to round six
of the sink Phil cup and as you can see
it's we have a very special guest in the
studio Dr Paula Knights who is the
superintendent of schools in the
Jennings School District district and
you are a staunch advocate for the
Scholastic chess initiative oh yes yes
and tell us how is the school year going
and tell us about your school district
yeah so the school Year is off to a
really really good start so we are at
that time of year where we are coasting
into the holiday season so right
everyone has on their wings we're
coasting but to start out this year this
was probably one of the smoothest starts
that we had to this school year um you
know I'm going into my third year as a
superintendent and often times the
research says third year for
superintendent you can kind of start
seeing everything fall into place okay
and so um so we you had a really good
year really good year how many kids are
in the Jennings School District
approximately 2 200 wow 2500 um really
really super proud of the fact that you
know we've expanded Early Childhood so
we're getting kids as early as three
years old okay and they are going to
school uh and they're in school all day
every single day so uh so we're growing
so just growing the district and just
really getting out here and getting back
on the map and in the school district
how many get exposure to the chess oh my
goodness um this the program has touched
hundreds of kids um and that's the whole
intent right of that is the intent and
then starting early uh getting them in
getting them in early um early exposure
um mean you don't have to be afraid of
Chess and sometimes you know you hear
people say oh my gosh when it comes to
chess I don't know how to play but when
you expose children early in having a
consistent plan of exposure goes a long
way absolutely as so we see some of the
uh Boll there yeah you can see some of
the children learning chess that and
this is such a wonderful site to see but
uh well recently a a research study was
completed in your District about how
chess positively impacts your students
what were the key takeaways from this
study the key takeaways two big
takeaways the first one was mathematics
and um the ability to solve problems and
so that's critical thinking and that's
what chest really you know um instills
within the player you know how to take
your time and think um and within
mathematics when they take their
assessment every year there's a lot of
word problems where they have to really
think through the problem and then the
second is um the discipline infractions
we've seen our discipline infractions go
down they've almost plummeted right um
because because you know with chess it
also um teaches kids how to regulate
themselves that
self-regulation um and to take their
time and to you know
self-discipline um and those are the key
takeaways um and and kids are coming to
school every day right right so you know
we talk about coming to school we talk
about teaching and learning they're in
school especially on the days they know
they have chess exactly and so it has
yes and so it has gone through the roof
when we talk about our attendance um but
it's it's been phenomenal well that's
very unexpected takeaway for me actually
that it certainly impacted on the
attendance rates absolutely absolutely I
always uh use chess As a treat uh I
raised in Seattle Washington and went to
mini uh middle school and Garfield High
School and I was actually a chess
teacher at the meanie middle school and
the kids came and for me one of the
things that was really wonderful about
Chess and introducing chess to to uh
kids was it forced them to read Because
in chess you have to write down your
moves and then you know I want to beat
Joy so I'll go get a chess book and I
would read the chess book to try to get
ahead and learn a trick or two that
maybe she didn't know so for me chess
was a real treat in the Reading
Writing era fascinating areas I love it
I love it wonderful thank you so much
for joining oh sorry you have one more
question please question you're not
getting away Dr Knight not without it as
long as you need
me because we do have the strategy
across the board Gala coming up on
December the 2nd which supports the
Scholastic chess initiative and what
does it mean to have such a support for
your students yeah so you know this is
you know this is almost personal for me
right because when we're talking about
children um um black children um who
come from varying economic backgrounds
um you know it's important to always
Expose and to expose early and with the
Gayla it shows that there is a
continuation of support um within our
district so much so that we are able to
possibly look at expanding right um you
know I have really been a staunch
proponent of uh girls in chess black
girls in chess um boys black boys and so
this gives us the opportunity it it
tells me the community is behind school
districts and ensuring that chess
doesn't go anywhere chess is here to
stay right and that we can have chess it
doesn't have to be after school it's
part of our instructional day and we can
continue that same pattern and so with
the Gayla and you know seeing hundreds
of people come out in support it tells
me that they are indeed supporting
school districts to ensure that this you
know it's it's not an initiative this is
a fabric of what we do um when we offer
chess and there we have it on our screen
that Saturday December 2nd here in the
Central West End uh we will be having
that very special Gayla and it's our big
big funraising uh event for uh the
schools as you said yeah absolutely
beautifully said that thank you very
much Dr Knight for joining us here in
the studio and talking about how chess
impacts in your Scholastic District
thank you thank you thank you again and
here are our standings as we are in
round six so these are the games that
have been played after five rounds again
Wesley so has played more games than
leavon aronian they're both standing at
plus one and that is because uh Yan
Kristoff Duda withdrew after round two
so there you see that some players have
played more games than others and that's
why Ali Rea uh with two points is listed
at the bottom because uh the people with
two points who have uh played uh four
games are listed above him he's at minus
one and here are today's pairings and uh
there you can see it is a contest
between the two players on plus one Wes
liso and leavon aronian they are facing
off and fighting out in an end game and
then we also have alira fua and Fabiana
Carana it's a very complicated position
they have on the board for Richard
report and Maxim Vash gra also very
complicated middle game and Anish giri
faces off against Lena
Dominguez thank you and uh we see in the
game of Ali Raza Knight takes D5 is just
a very difficult move to find has not
been played and in fact uh I've been
while I was listening to this interview
and it was a very interesting interview
to me as well and I have some thoughts
on the whole chess and schools thing but
right this is not why I'm here so I will
I will shove them for now uh spoiler I
think it's good and and valuable and
should be done more but yeah I'm not
going to be a contrarian there but I had
one specific thing I wanted to ask Dr
Knight but didn't have a chance but all
four boards actually had developments
while we were sort of away on a break
and then uh talking to Dr Knight which
were quite striking and here Rook H E1 I
think it's just a bad move it looks
extremely natural and useful I feel it's
very harsh to criticize it but it just
does doesn't work out on a tactical
level and one thing I will say it's one
of those strange moves where you brought
a piece closer to the action you brought
a piece on a Central Square it's very
logical I was talking about trying to
dig something out but it falls to a very
very specific thing and Fabi actually
he's done sort of the right thing but I
I suspect in the wrong order which might
give ala a way out fby played A4
immediately and instead of that Knight
F4 was very very strong I just want to
spend a moment here explaining Queen F1
yeah and this is is the point let's say
we make a move after
A5 I don't know I don't know what the
pass is here but even let's say Rook H
F1 my point was if you go Knight F4 here
I can and I will play Queen E3 because
you're not taking on G2 you're losing
this Knight having put the Rook on E1
you're absolutely locking yourself in to
playing Queen F1 because this just costs
you a whole a whole bunch of material
and after Queen F1 we can play A4 and
now there are two problems here for
white
one is very straightforward if you play
Knight A4 Rook takes A4 and there's a
very beautiful shot there in the end
it's not Queen takes A2 which is
playable but not that great but we take
on B2 we give a check along the long
diagonal the King has to go to B1 and
now Bishop B6 is winning but the most
beautiful way to win this position is
this move Knight D3 and then Bishop A6
followed by Rook B8 check and look at
this group of people doing nothing to
protect the King on B1 very very
beautiful and a very similar threat is
also being developed here because you
would ask yourself why can't I just shw
this Knight away and then start
collecting a Tak P3 obviously allowing
btx A2 is a bit me so you do this and
then you lose to 93 once again Dem and
you you you can do this to prolong the
game but you will not save this position
it's just a completely lost position
it's not what you wanted so after A4
here the way to go forward here would be
something like D2 G4 trying desperately
to close things down and take the D3
Square under control but after a takes B
A takes B even Queen E7 and then perhaps
some line that the engine likes here is
putting the queen on A7 attacking D4 and
just having a very big attack and also
always Bishop A6 this queen is really
really awkwardly placed but an even
faster way to play this is to play C6 C5
once again with the intention of putting
the bishop on A6 then perhaps delivering
the check on D3 and collapsing the White
Queen side this would have been very
very dangerous for alira having played
uh instead this is very strong and along
the similar lines but it does once again
give white the same
bailout we can start removing pieces
from the board and then playing
something like D3 and yes of of course
black is happy to include A4 because you
can remove you can remove some Defenders
from the white king you can open the a
file black is doing fine yeah but F was
doing more than fine had he found the
sequence of Knight A4 Knight A4 and A4
he would have been I think in the driver
seat completely I think it would be
difficult for ala to even maintain
balance and I I have a question so a lot
of the lines we saw wh position
collapsing on account of Knight F4 to go
to Knight to D3 what happens if you just
stop the Knight getting to F4 with G3 so
after A4 yeah I I the current position
in the current position with rookie one
with rookie one included rookie one yeah
so A4 yeah G3 I think G4 G3 is playable
yeah it's maybe not the best move but
it's very playable because you do need
to stop this I think uh it's it might be
second best choice but you you you
better off actually just taking some
pieces off the board because here uh
Queen E7 is strong and kind of weirdly
the engine suggests after H6 H5 black is
better which I don't quite understand I
guess you secure the king side and shift
the entire focus of the game to the
queen side but I don't really understand
why it's currently saying H5 is Miles
better than everything else like I'm not
even going to try to explain that the
reason I'm saying I'm suggesting G3 as
go to Knight takes Knight Knight takes
Knight is a move that you play when you
realize you're in trouble right I agree
when you you think that you're Rock
Solid after all I mean take a look he
has a knight on A3 on C3 Bishop you know
defending the king you're more likely to
stop the Knight getting to F4 I agree
let's take a look at one thing though
can we maybe now take on A4 does there I
guess it says there's just no difference
Rook A4 B A4 Bishop takes B2 King takes
B2 I thought maybe it's slightly better
for white compared to the position with
Knight on F4 and the Queen on F1 which
it is but wow this is very striking
Bishop A6 here and if you take a give
Rook B check oh my and I go Knight B4
and it it wins on the spot after both
King C1 and also after King A1 you can
get the Queens off but it doesn't it
doesn't help very much may yeah and if
you go if you go Knight B5 here you
still lose to the very same move night
before and then your entire your entire
Queen yeah everything collapses uh so
Knight a A4 appears to be uh not great
feels like a nightmare yeah and and the
choices are as I see Knight Tak D5 is
the best move and second best is you
have is G3 because this needs to be
stopped if it lands on D3 in all of
these positions sorry there was a
misclick if it lands on D3 the game
pretty much ends as we've seen uh in in
the line so let's let Al res a stew stew
here a little bit because there's
there's things happening everywhere
right let's start with the dest game of
the today but maybe the most important
in terms of the standing tournament
talking about the standings we do have
an interesting graphic that was composed
by our resident statistician Ben
Underwood says if the grand chest tour
finished stop today exactly this is what
we would have in front of us Wesley so
would be a co-winner of the tournament
that would give him a lot of GCT uh
points keeping in mind that Leana is a
wild card he takes points away but
doesn't ACR them himself yeah and you
can see Fabiano would comfortably win
the ground chest tour Wesley so would be
second with a $50,000 bonus $50,000
$25,000 bonus for Max Maxim V and the
top three finishes get an automatic
invite into next year's Grand chest
store very very nice so that was if all
of the results that the event was over
right now and the grand chest T would
end in it uh current uh that's not the
situation because so going going this is
an important game uh we left it so yeah
Knight C7 was played and understandably
Bishop came to D3 then white took on F4
and Leon continued making very very
committal decisions here this one the
engine also hates quite a bit although
it's very understandable from a human
point of view I apologize it was Bishop
F5 by the way that the engine was saying
how big was Wesley's Advantage instead
of King takes F4 actually yeah maybe
maybe this is Bishop F5 Bishop F5 it was
screaming the bishop F5 is cleaner than
King takes F4 I don't know if that is as
big of a difference as it suggests but
it definitely was the preferred move
here cutting off squares from the Knight
but King F4 the Knight still didn't go
to those squares which is I think
questionable and C6 C5 now it really
does resemble that fisher man of game I
feel I don't like that move and and I
left it running Knight King E5 King E7
Bishop F5 B6 was played and I I left it
truning here for a second this is uh a
position with one minor piece and five
against five it's currently giving white
a almost a plus three Advantage I was
about to say isn't this borderline
winning yeah yeah I think it is it's you
can still not win it because you have to
be very precise there's a lot of tangs
that you will have to go through because
currently if if you look at this
position if black could never move this
might be a draw right you could just say
pass but he need if if you could
actually just say check you know check
check pass pass but but this is not how
things work and eventually black will be
forced into committing more more to more
weaknesses because you just can't one of
the obvious plans is if the Knight moves
away from C7 this this very simple plan
of getting the king through the D5 C6 B7
squares just wins uh you also have to
worry about your king side so if if you
ever play F7 F6 check you provide the
king with a very very juicy Target of
the G6 square and yeah it's not for
nothing that in a position with complete
material equality the advantage is as
huge as it as it says on our screen I
don't particularly like the move H2
H4 I would not be committing to any full
pawn moves because like it feels like
this is a position in which you might
need a lot of waiting moves to create
those two swung A3 we' Burn yeah we've
burned through two temp here right
because we could play H3 and then H4 and
it might become like I'm I'm very
prepared to say it changes nothing I
suspect that given time because the
engine had no time to analyze this
particular end game so it's not as deep
I suspect if you give it time it will go
back to plus three I don't think this
throws away anything right it wouldn't
have been my first choice though I
probably play B3 just to make sure
nothing nothing is hanging on the queen
side and saying okay so how are you
planning to pass here for black like
what are your moves mhm and I'm not sure
there's a good answer at all because you
can't move the Knight A5 doesn't really
improve your case if you play F6 check
you mentioned we play we play we put the
King on e4 we dro the bishop back and we
start hinting at going in this direction
and you continue continue running out of
M time and time and time again you have
you can
wait quite a bit with can and uh Force
white to use up some Tempo so for
instance you go Knight A6 forced me to
play a33 there and then I go back right
and then it puts the bishop on H2 and
here here is interesting because I did
wonder like whether you could play
something quite risky which is
age five five no I I know it's very very
risky but I do have a concrete idea
behind it and that's actually to go
Knight E6 oh no it doesn't no that that
end game is still lost still lost I
wanted to fix the pawns no I need to do
it with a Pawn on H4 that's what I
wanted no and here we we have a very
simple idea of mish Pani too and just
collecting no this is just by the way
Knight E8 on the board this is this is
all very aggravating to me because
leevon of all people will
know on a very kind of intimate level
just how dangerous he I mean he won won
games like this with white he many times
yeah he he understands so not only did
he go for this end game he also then
passed up some opportunities not to play
exact this scenario he could have he
could have gone Knight E3 and could have
played for I think he's really flirting
with danger here I think this is more
than a flirt really really bad and again
as we started the show we were just
saying what a crucial game this is for
Wesley so's career I mean again Wesley
is in this race for the candidates all
he needs is well uh to finish ahead of
Ali Raza and Anish and he's in the
candidates and a win today he would
knock his rival he would be sinkfield
cup he would be the sinkfield Cup winner
almost uh it feels and there you see
before the round this was before round
five there will be there will be a shift
and round five after Ali res a lost to
leavon AR there was a shift Wesley so
did leap frog and uh well he's now to
2756 one point separates them yeah and
there he is uh Wesley at the board uh I
wanted to say if you don't mind going
back to the Ali Raza game for just a
moment because G3 Joy uh Ali Raza
decided he wanted to stop Knight F4 but
he didn't want to take on D5 and Fabby
has achieved a fabulous moment there of
trading off the a A2 and A7 pawns
actually for whatever reason and this is
also very difficult to understand and I
think in F shws I would also instantly
snap on B3 just to have Clarity right I
think chess players very often value
Clarity quite a bit in these types of
situation the engine suggests it's
actually very valuable to keep them on I
don't understand why uh it says ab3 ab3
has improved white situation
considerably I really wouldn't wouldn't
Venture an explanation for this I have
no idea why that would be the case uh
this is now somehow playable for white
not that bad uh
H5 I want to say disappeared of my
screen but it hasn't it's it's now back
yeah I have a feeling it has something
to do with Bishop H6 somewhere but I
really can't imagine what that scenario
is otherwise I don't really know uh this
is still very pleasant for black a move
like H5 is playable a move like Queen F7
perhaps hinting at Bishop B6 and Rook
fb8 perhaps heting at some Queen A7
Queen A7 is just generally I feel I see
it a lot as a as a good Square for the
queen just putting a lot of pressure on
various points of the white position
also reintroducing the idea of Bishop A6
I think a lot of it is about trying to
play Bishop A6 and just to confirm the
opportunity for playing Knight takes D5
has passed yeah you probably don't yeah
with with the with the pawns on the a
file gone yeah you are now in particular
with the bishop coming out to E6 and
then D4 Bishop takes B3 being introduced
as a very very important threat yeah you
no longer really want to do do this in
particular after Queen F7 this is still
you always take black hair I'm pretty
sure in in Practical terms when this is
a human playing against a human he
pretty much always take black hair it's
just so much more pleasant to create
threats than to bury them move after
move after move but it could have been
even better all of those lines Peter
where you were talking about a knight
coming to D3 that was really oh Knight
F4 Knight D3 that followed by Queen
takes B3 those were very impressive uh
lines I must say all of those variations
where you were playing Bishop A6 and now
I'm looking Bishop D3 can I play a move
just a simple move Knight C7 it it it
it's kind of one idea one idea want to
allow D2 D3 I don't want to allow no I
think I think allowing something like
this allows white to actually
regroup I'm not in time for any of these
beautiful sacrifices on D3 with the
queen on F7 maybe this would have worked
because you still need one more move
before you can create a threat of e
takes D3 yeah and white has sort of
connected the queen I was kind of
fixated uh frankly with Bishop takes D3
and queen takes B3 but I understand
actually the only move that wins here is
the move Knight A4 which I think is very
myal that wasn't on my radar I was I
must admit nor nor mine I'm just I'm
just a you know a
reader a reader I'm a reader of the
screen yeah I I don't really claim any
credit here uh so yeah this is the
situation 40 minutes against against an
hour for ala so ala is still doing fine
on the clock but yeah this could have
been worse and it's still not
particularly Pleasant I'm thinking about
the Egyptian scribes you know I'm just a
scribe reading the
Scrolls wow elsewhere there's a lot of a
lot of things happening as well in our
game between rard rort and M mvl mvl
made a move I really really dislike here
which is a move C5 C4 we were talking
about the ideas of Knight B7 and Knight
C5 but I I was trying to figure out why
it drops the evaluation so much and I
think it's actually very understandable
on a human level this this Knight on A5
is not an oil painting but it's
reasonably secure at the for the time
being because it cannot really be
attacked very much mhm what the move C5
C4 does is it immediately it seems like
it's fighting against it but in fact it
makes the move before before possible
Right rather than the other way around
right and it was instantly played by
reard but maybe even stronger and this
is missable this I understand why he in
particular because before is strong but
maybe even stronger was this very quiet
move G2 G3 uh something I was talking
about when we were discussing this
position previously prior to the move C5
C4 this is vulnerable mhm this is the
one target black can play against so
after for instance the move A7 A6 even
more than Bishop F5 a threat that black
has here is repositioning the Bishop
from D7 to B7 and exerting a lot of
pressure against the D5 Pawn so after C4
playing G3 and then Bishop G2 just says
no I'm going to protect it so well that
you it will never
trou and also eventually I will play and
then there will be a lot of threats
connected with Knight C6 so G3 was
extremely harsh and if you play Bishop
C8 here now before before is pretty much
completely winning it just blows black
apart you can no longer play Knight B7
you just straight up to Knight C6 and if
you have to go cb3 ab3 everything is
hanging now on B5 is hanging b34 yeah
like you you losing material here you
you not even at a stage where your
position is bad you know in spirit
you're just you're just going to start
losing material here uh so I think G3
maybe would have been an even bigger
problem but what uh rard did is is also
very very understandable this is just a
very logical uh continuation the engine
was suggesting you have to kind of close
your eyes and play A5
here wow uh I understand why mvl didn't
because you have to calculate both let's
say a B5 Bishop B5 Knight C6 and you
will have to take and play this which
looks like you might be losing by force
here if it doesn't work out for you and
also the immediate Knight C6 where you
have to go for this position also and it
also looks like you might be losing by
force if it doesn't work out for you but
apparently you don't apparently
something like A5 A4 Rook A8 Queen A8 is
sort of just okay because B5 is hanging
and we end up in many cases we end up
actually swapping everything down this
seems man no I'm with you on that and
instead he played A6 which is also it's
an autopilot move your your queenside
was threatened now I can protect it now
we we see the reintroduction of this G3
Bishop G2 idea white has a massive
Advantage here G2 G3 Bishop G2 lend the
Knight on C6 Force black to take we have
a passer on C6 which is also protected
by by the bishop the bishop pair
Advantage everything this is just a very
very unpleasant position for MV now
thank you Peter for that and then
finally we do have the game of Anish
garyi as well uh versus lanir that was
the Knight H3 Knight F2 game how has
that progress
uh L chose to put the Knight on F6 white
played H3 as I mentioned allowing Knight
G4 is pretty much never particularly
good idea so H3 is logical uh Bishop H6
is maybe a little bit artificial uh
already here I think he takes F4
wouldn't have been a mistake but I guess
ler wanted to hint at H5 H4 being a
threat Knight E2 is a clever move here
keeping things under control Knight D4
castles and in this position I think
it's kind of impossible to play the kind
of idea that the engine suggests because
in very many positions here it just goes
KN H7 and honestly I don't really know
how to explain it it's on a pretty good
Square it's controlling Central Central
fights and like does things seemingly
right and the engine does does play
Knight H7 either immediately or after
castles and then it plays Knight H7 I
don't really know why I okay I'm washing
my hands off of this instead 96 was
played which I think is a logical idea
once again reintroducing ining the idea
of H5 H4 and and here an interesting
thing happened
because this whole opening concept by
Nish I think was a very big signal that
you know he wants a very sharp fight he
wants to play kind of Allin for a win
today right in that spirit I think you
go a five right I think you go a five
and let's say Bishop C1 Queen C1 is even
stronger than Rook C1 because this is a
useful diagonal and after Knight G7 you
can choose between various things but
like FG FG maybe this is why he didn't
do it actually looking at this queen G
the engine says white is a bit better
but if you have to take on G6 My Hope
was we can get to play G we get to play
G4 but can't you not switch to like the
positional way of playing it and go
what's a position uh the Knight C3
Knight D1 Knight E3 come in to D5 mean
you mean after after the trade no this
is a bit better for white and probably
precisely for the reasons you're
suggesting this KN will go back to C3
the other one could go here it could
also it could also be aimed at this
Square my close Sicilian hat came back
after all these years this is this is
pleasant but I'm more curious as to like
in a situation where he had a rest day
to decide on a strategy to decide on an
opening he clearly decided that he wants
to push prop properly push for for a win
today right and I thought sort of
spiritually once like conceptually you
want you much rather play F5 but he's
gone with this uh which I think makes
linear life
simpler it's not that this is not a
sharp position but it's a lot more
defined the knights stay on good squares
because we haven't really chased any of
them away black would eventually like to
play H5 H let's let's make a stupid
waiting move something like this becomes
a topic you know just trying to land a
piece on F4 I see and just generally I
think this is just simpler to play for
black compared to those very messy
positions which could arise after F5 so
I was a bit surprised by F5 it's not a
bad move but I thought F5 was more
logical and More in keeping
with how Anish was approaching the open
know I mean I'm also surprised because
in these type of structures you do want
to be playing F5 but I'm also really
anxious to put the Knight on C3 and
stick a piece into D5 yeah also
something I wanted to point out uh
somewhat weirdly uh I can't really
pinpoint exactly where it happened but
Anish actually
overtook lineer on the clock oh lineer
is on 40 on 41 minutes here and Anish is
on 39 so uh somewhere between this
position where he was still definitely
in control in terms of time time usage
the last say three four moves three four
moves took Anish a lot of time to to
decide on yeah and if F takes C5 took
him 20 just that one move alone to I'm
sure he was considering those lines that
you were talking about with F5 and G4 if
you don't mind the current position
takes on E5 takes on C1 if you will
probably start on C1 uh Queen takes C1
takes on E5
now I play the move H4 because I don't
want to see H4 G5 as you said and I'm
thinking yes that was my question is
your yes that was my question is your
king completely comfy yes Bishop H3
mobilize the Knight on F2 you you can't
get the Knight to G5 without allowing me
to play Knight G4 I think those things
kind of cancel each other out right also
I control the H3 Square so I will be
snapping it off once it appears there so
it feels like black will actually play
Bishop E6 will play Rook C8 there is a
Target on C2 eventually if I'm really
really worried about this queen it looks
slow but I can play like Rook E8 and
then get the queen over to f8 but the
bigger issue for white is is how do I
how do you get the Knight to G5 I can
even just trade them by playing Knight
G4 I don't know if I want to immediately
but if I feel panicky enough I can just
go Knight G4 and without that Knight
you're not giving any mate on the yeah
well that's a whole point was the this
idea of can I force you to panic you
know Bishop F3 King H2 Rook G1 and you
know I'm advertise what advertising what
I'm doing you know yeah exactly you know
I'm trying to get my uh Pawn to G4 yeah
I have to play Rook C1 and yeah again's
go Rook E8 it's just it's just very very
slow it's just not going to
happen right as well oh no Queen yeah
I've got this beautiful ignoring it yeah
it like continues ignoring it says yeah
I don't I don't believe any of this is a
threat but that's the that's the engine
a human M no and now it goes takes G4
and takes H4 check there's a reason
right there was a reason that you
weren't worried about G4 no I don't
think I don't think this is this is fast
enough honestly I'm very
much on your team on this because I
think I think if I had this with black I
would give serious consideration to
going King of8 King G7 just to stop just
so that it doesn't happen and I don't
have to think about it right but it's
not that great it's do we have to
capture with the queen I mean cuz I just
what I really wanted to go is yes and
then you can guess my plan I'm not very
very subtle I've been advertising it for
last 10 minutes but okay and then I
don't want to allow Knight F4 that's my
issue that's the issue letting that
piece land on F4 is probably not going
to be a dream right can I jump in anyhow
go for it Knight D5 yeah Knight D5 okay
I can take it's not really you're not
you you might eventually be able to give
me one check on F6 but it will cost you
my yeah what did it cost you
for a check what did it cost you
everything yeah just a pawn just a pawn
bishop takes C1 plate we'll leave this
one for a second because uh rard did
something I don't know if I like because
after G3 MVR yeah black played 96 he
cashed his and Richie decided to cash it
in here which I think
is a little bit early I would have very
much liked to play Bishop G2 follow it
up Bishop F4 let's say develop the
Knight maybe this if this Knight lands
on D4 the game ends that's the game ends
so let's try to maybe at least attempt
it you know right maybe it doesn't work
but let's at least try instead he's gone
with ab5 ab5 took on A8 took on D7 and
yes the pawn on E7 fell but it feels
like in some position like this even if
I don't try to win anything back I just
say you know we get we get to this
structure you keep you can keep your
Pawn on D5 but you have this really
really stupid Knight on B1 you have this
Target on C3 I have very very decent
blockading uh pieces of course white is
a bit better but I would feel like I
sold it short honestly I would feel that
I probably had more and now I will have
to play a very long game with no you
have to guarantee of success you have to
understand uh Peter's past I mean he's a
grunfeld player who's happy being a pwn
down so long as he has Dynamic play and
his Bishop on G7 is really working in
this Cas this case it reminds me it
reminds me of some grinfield I can't put
my finger exactly on which but it does
feel Grill due to me but what you were
what you were building up and saying
that in if if Richie doesn't cashes
chips this is just such a nice position
I think I think you just go for this
it's just so pleasant night A3 nightc 94
either this way this way yeah yeah yeah
we we ride at
dawn I like it okay so if we play too
slowly there will be some Shenanigans
with Knight H4 coming up at some point
so it actually says you will have to
commit to Knight C6 but this is not such
a you know okay this is completely
winning knight6 black has to play Knight
F5 I'm just trying to figure out how
difficult the moves it tells me are the
best moves are here because what it
suggests we play here is a little bit
inhuman like if this is really the only
way I can understand reard not wanting
it cu the currently the best line here
is Queen F3 already a bit of a
mysterious move I guess we've protected
against I'm not I guess we've
yeah we all protect C6 to be able to
take on E6 here but then even more
weirdly after Bishop takes C6 it goes
back yeah that's to stop Bishop D5 okay
you lost me on that
one and if if this is absolutely
required okay then yeah okay we
understand why we CES I I withdraw my my
OB criticism I think I think that's fine
okay well that's the other thing too and
I really want to emphasize this point is
that it's so hard getting a victory in
this field
and you you have this feeling that when
you've won a pawn and at the moment it
still feels like white has a bit of an
initiative to go with this Bond you're
so inclined to take the material and say
thank you very much I could be winning
every level right at every level but
especially this I mean especially that
game I mean because if you look at it on
a purely objective mathematical logical
level you have an extra porn Bishops
what more do you want you just get
developed and also you have this
beautiful Pawn on D5 cutting the board
in half so you just feel like the world
is your o I am sorry I want to go back
to our tournament co-leader
situation because I'm
thinking Wesley is close to clinching uh
he's got his King on D yeah I don't
understand this all you got to do is
play B3 and King C6 Peter and I I
checked it just now I checked it just
now uh we left it here Leon played
Knight d8 played Knight D6 the bishop
dropped back to H3 easy and yeah for now
we're not threatening King C6 but we
because of C4 the Knight cannot really
get rerouted to squares which control
the C6 Square so we will get there and I
I asked the engine like what what it
felt was best moves it plays Knight d8
and I wanted to play B3 and then it does
this and for a second it pretends that
maybe we can lock the king out on A7 and
maybe it doesn't get out but it does get
out once again Tu swangs will come into
it the threat of creating a passer on
the H file will come so we play Bishop
F5 and then we put it on D3 and we start
hinting at this and we also very much
will play three and B4 at some point and
start opening up the queen side it's
just bad I don't I don't like it just
confuses me because Leon knows this is
bad again uh I don't if you're going to
play Knight E8 voluntarily I don't even
have to play B3 anymore uh the current
position if you if you start with what
do you do exactly what do you do yeah if
E8 you can go F6 then I will play B3 but
then we were transposing to the same
like if you want to prevent the king
from Landing there you can go like
Knight Knight Knight B7 Knight d8 no but
this is this is how you lose like you
you will just run out of moves here F6 I
I go back I mean I don't care and
eventually one of the big pieces will
have to move and then the king will get
allowable and and and this is well known
this this this has been sort of the very
un easily understood truth about these
end games forever every certainly after
the fish games but even earlier than
that I think pan won games like this and
won games like this it's not it's not
news is it not possible instead of f has
the pawn already been on F6 no no but
you will eventually just have to do
something oh yeah no I'm just
thinking if I can get the Knight to
E6 so you go you start with Knight B7 so
King B King C6 can be met By Night 85
check okay night here and now you wait
and now this is where I want to go you
wanted you wanted to the with with h I
think this is still lost right I mean
this is this is still very trivially
lost uh outside pass pwn yeah this is
just yeah my decoy versus your decoy
your decoy wins no it's you can pretty
much never offer this Pawn ending I
think I I struggled to create a scenario
in which this Pawn ending will be from
very very early days uh we thought in
this bishop at night that's why I
thought it was a very dangerous
confounding cu thing was Leon's Choice
well again um Joy do the honors and tell
our viewers why this result a victory by
Wesley so would be so huge it's massive
I mean looking at the standings Wesley
so is at the top of table with three
points out of five having won his game
against Richard report leavon Ronin is
on two and a half points out of four
those are the only two players who have
won a single game exactly but he's
played four games because of young dudo
withdrawal so this is not just um a
matchup between tournament leaders those
players on plus one but it's also
massively important for the ratings
because on January the 1st the player
with the highest rating who hasn't
qualified into the candidates will get
that candidate spot and as we saw after
round five Wesley leap frogged over Ali
Resa fua Ali Resa came into the
tournament with a rating lead but again
thanks to that Victory by Wesley the
loss by fuja boom they switched places
and by the way Wesley we think is
winning and when we left it we thought
fuer was in a bit of trouble even though
he was Pawn up against Fabby uh Fabby
playing his third consecutive black uh
in this round against Ali Rea let me
just bring that game up on the board and
see what has happened we left it uh I
think um confoundingly we got to this
position and Peter was explaining to us
that the engine actually thought that
the move A4 takes B3 was imprecise and
you never got around to telling us
precisely why that
waser because I couldn't even figure
that out because I don't know and I
don't like I gave up trying to
understand I was looking for the
clarification goes to show what kind of
complicated position this is it is a
very complex position after
ABAB you know there was something about
the move H6 H5 I really liked from
Black's perspective first of all you you
you're cutting out any undermining
efforts with H4 but you're also cutting
out G4 and you're giving yourself the
option of Bishop H6 Fabby played the
move Queen D6 Queen D6 which left me
scratching my head because I'm thinking
the Knight on A3 is off sides and you're
encouraging me I think we are actually
actively trying to encourage Knight C4
because it makes playing Bishop A6 so
much easier yeah I think we're provoking
Knight C4 and I think the problem is not
really Knight C4 the problem is we've
now allowed F2 F3 okay and this should
be done sort of post haste even though I
think que6 queen6 was probably played
specifically not to allow F3 but it
somehow seems to work out after Rook G1
specifically I think it's it's this move
that maybe fa misunderstood because it
looks like we losing the entire bunch of
Pawns on the king side but Queen F3 Rook
takes G6 is just good for white because
suddenly there's a lot of threats
against the the king the black king ef3
is stronger but in this position after
Queen D3 once again you will have to
give up on G6 and whose King is more
vulnerable in this case very importantly
The Rook can be switched over but now we
can very very typical thing to do here
is just to get rid of this very
important bishop and then our Bishop on
B2 is
playing and after C takes D5 Bishop G7
and queen F3 is playable Queen takes D5
is playable this is suddenly a position
you can definitely imagine white even
playing for a win in because who King is
worse I don't know exactly and uh
forgive me F3 makes the most sense but
explain to me why Knight C4 is actually
a bad idea because I mean bringing the
Knight into the game with a gain of
tempo let's go Queen C7 yeah you
probably don't actually want to play
bishay 3 and if you don't want to play
bishay 3 you now have to contend with
the IDE of bishay 6 which is going to
hurt if if it if it lands I I don't want
to play I do want to bop Queen A7 yeah
it just it just does that Queen A7 no
take work
yes no no honestly I I think this is
once again this is something you can
explain because this is not a safe king
and the reason we're not getting mated
in many of these lines is because this
bishop on B2 is alive and if you remove
it you like this this is probably just
like ma m five or something isn't it
like not not yet but it will be soon
yeah yeah looks terrible 82 mate is a
bit of a threat here and you have to
start you have to start committing a lot
of material to not getting m in the next
three so I think yeah Fabby I think is
very much provoking Knight C4 because
the queen could have been aimed at A7
more efficiently I was giving the move
Queen F7 instead but Fabi is really
trying to lure the Knight onto the C4
Square shouldn't be done F3 is by far
the best move the second best move is
Knight a B1 completely you know saying
no not going to C4 not tempted and
perhaps it also what it does I think D3
is maybe yeah overprotecting C3 and
creating finally a
possibility to play to play and also
saying to the opponent you're never
going to Checkmate me mate never look
how well defended we are uh we're
getting ready for a break what are we
doing on our our break yes first of all
let's check up on the standings after
round five w liso at the top with three
points out of five but also on plus one
it is leavon aronian with 2 and A2
points out of four remember remember
there is a game imbalance because of yan
Kristof duda's withdrawal after round
two Han pomi and maxing Bor gr on
50% and we do think Wesley so uh is
winning the game uh by the way if you're
anywhere near the Central West End it's
a must uh you you you got to visit the
jingle bar the World Chess Hall of Fame
go to uh uh the World Chess Hall of
fame. org to understand what it's all
about but bring your friends hey a
company outing that's what we're doing
with the uh chess club employees is
we're having an employee party AB at the
jingle bar and you can to love and uh
what's not to love there is hot
chocolate there are cookies you can RSVP
now at the World Chess Hall of fame. org
you speaking y's language there yeah I
heard cookies hot chocolate I'm in I'm
in I'm in and we are going to take a
short break but during that break we do
have a video where Anastasia spoke to
Maxim Vash graph so enjoy that and we'll
see you after the
[Music]
break Maxim welcome back back to St
Louis welcome back to Grand chest tour
what what do you think about the in
general the State of Affairs in the
Chess World you know with Dingle ran
absent with Magnus who is like lost some
points lately with hikaro who showed
quite good result I mean in general what
is your opinion what's happening now is
someone who is inside of all
this a lot is changing uh these days um
especially the level of preparation of
every top play but even the players uh
one uh I mean one circle behind like
from 2650 let's say to 27 uh 20 uh
everyone's been opening preparation has
improved drastically because of
computers so that means the difference
in level is starting the Gap is reducing
a bit especially in classical I think in
Rapid and Le there's still uh like quite
some difference um between some
players and
um yeah I has been showing spectacular
results um for the past two years um
well well done to him of course it
doesn't change the fact that uh Magnus
has been absolutely dominant for the
past uh 12 13 years maybe in classical
is less dominant this year but I
wouldn't say that uh that is a trend and
that uh
and that it will uh keep on forever and
I and for instance this year the most
impressive player I think has been
Fabiano because he showed the same
performance basically as iaru but over
many more
events uh so Fabiano has been doing
great and you know I mean in general I
would call him the second player in the
world for the past 10 years uh there's
no doubt in my
mind um as for at least In classical
chess of course in Rapid and it's
another story uh and that's for ding U
well he won this world championship
match uh I think he was dominated
throughout but he found some great
resources and then played extremely well
in the tie breaks uh since then I guess
he's been trying to
recover um because physically so much um
I mean Magnus has spoke spoken about it
so D also has sort of spoken about it
it's tough it takes a t on you I do
expect to to see him back in 2024 and
you know I mean he's always been a great
player so again I I expect him to come
back at full
strength no you mentioned that many
young players many players from this 650
to 750 I mean are getting uh up uh do
you think someone else in the nearest
Future will cross
2,800 who knows probably it might happen
at some point of course uh I didn't even
mentioned that there were so many like
the generation of course from 1990 and
let's say to
1994 uh with uh closing with Anish has
been absolutely
dominant um then the generation from 95
to 2000 I mean there's been some great
players of course there's Richard
there's uh Duda and some others but uh
it has failed to leave you know to the
expectations compared to to this 1990
and of course now we're seeing this new
generation coming let's say from 2002 to
20067 and I mean they have uh great
peges great uh absolutely great players
uh especially from India but not only
from usbekistan as well and so
on so yeah I mean those guys will uh
likely fight for the top spots in the
next few years do you think somebody can
replace Magnus on the first place on
top it will happen inevitably So like um
you know but for now I wouldn't even
count out U um players from uh from our
generation to to keep fighting for the
next few years um then of course there's
Ali
Resa has had a few tough tournaments
lately but is still the only one of this
generation who is already established as
a top player and will prove this worse
in this uh you know uh huge um
tournaments like singfield cup and so on
so you know I mean I still expect ARA to
do great as well yeah and just last
question coming back to grest try to
name like three players from Young
Generation who might participate soon in
GCT and will be full tour players yeah
well I
mean it's very possible um I mean hard
to say but I do expect which one but I
do expect someone from India so like GES
or
prag or boss I don't know if they'll be
playing already next year but I mean in
the next few years that's certainly
almost a guarantee there's of course
Abdus and then from the even younger
players you have uh
COV um who up un coming and I mean you
have many others you have Vincent K also
is on the verge of 2730 I think so you
know that's quite huge yeah we have many
good flare States for sure yes thank you
so much Maxim for this interview and all
the best of luck for you in both events
yeah thank
[Music]
you
hello I'm women's Grand Master V janova
I will be creating content for Grand
chest store follow us on social media
and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership today the World
Chess Hall of Fame located in the heart
of St Louis's historic Central West End
want to know why chess has intrigued
people around the world for nearly 1,500
years stop by and learn about the impact
of Chess from our three floors
showcasing the art culture and history
of the game the World Chess Hall of Fame
has something for everyone to enjoy for
more information on current exhibits
please visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education hello I'm women's Grandmaster
R to janua I will take you behind the
scenes of the grand chest St follow us
on social media and don't miss out on
players interviews and more content from
the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess Club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken's cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership
[Music]
today here here we go and welcome back
to round six of the sinkfield cup and
it's been a very exciting start to the
day already but first of all let's
remind ourselves and any new viewers of
the standings after round five at the
top of the table is Wesley so with three
points out of five leavon ronian is also
on plus one but he has two and a half
points out of four there isn't imbalance
in games because of the withdrawal of
young Kristof Duda after round two we
have Nashi Maxi Val go also on 50% and
these are our round six pairings Wesley
so faces off against his closest rival
leavon aronian FIA plays against Fabiano
Carana and Richard report plays against
Max Vash lra whereas Anish giri takes on
lenia Dominguez and it's been very tense
in every single game a lot of surprising
moments uh for me uh I was going to say
leavon uh playing the way yes he's got
himself in a losing position these two
Co leers Peter what a huge Victory this
could be for Wesley and the fact that
the engines are saying plus three it's
close to four now I left it ring I left
the raining for a bit yeah this is the
carent position I was a bit surprised by
uh wesle choosing choosing the C2 Square
over the H3 square but I guess he feels
that he's absolutely no hurry whatsoever
and in terms of taking away the squares
from the Black Knight C2 is a very very
good choice because yeah you you're also
taking away the idea of jumping to E4 to
C3 uh it's very controlled black for now
the difference will be black can go King
D7 and for now stop the advance but then
we just continue passing we we pretty
much always playing B3 that's the one
pawn move I don't think white ever saves
on right we pretty much always playing
B3 and then eventually the moves just
run out because if you play King C7 it
doesn't do it instantly but I would
already be very interested in the go the
other way yeah King E5 get it to G7 win
only move Knight E8 and now we can maybe
even start like they the machine likes
putting the bishop on G8 but I'm also
wondering if I can just go G4 G5 H5 H6
H7 and I suspect like if if we leave it
running it will just completely bottom
out because dealing with threats on both
flanks here is completely impossible for
black and I keep on just really not
understanding how we found them this is
move
34 uh and if we go back to say Leon
started thinking on move 24 10 moves ago
M up to here leevon had more time than
he started with this is very very
obviously his home prep mhm and at this
point I gave a speech about it was
Wonder for me personally I would only go
for this if I knew exactly how I'm
making the draw and honestly I was I was
expecting to Leon to never start
thinking I thought he will just show
exactly where the pieces belong and the
game will end in a draw and I will sort
of eat my eat my words there a little
bit but no this is this is move 24 and
and this is now and this just looks lost
most
frankly experience tells us these
positions are not holdable if white does
what knows what they're doing exactly
and and Wesley clearly does know what
he's doing so I I just don't understand
what what happened there uh a stunning
re reversals Of Fortune or a great
Fortune for Wesley and then the game
between Ali Raza another one of those
Joy you were saying uh tense positions
and the last move by Fabby Queen D6 was
intended to prevent looks like he was
specifically trying to stop F3 yeah but
three uh has been played best move by
far in the position position remains
very playable it's not like this is now
horrible for black but uh suddenly white
has play real threats yeah we we
couldn't really challenge the black
setup in any way shape or until this
moment but now finally something is
happening to the black center the best
move remains Queen takes G3 but the line
I was showing uh prior to the break
which starts from here and gets really
really sharp I think is extremely
double-edged and I could very easily
believe white was better in the final
position that we got there uh and for
some reason the second best move here is
what Rook B7 which I just don't
understand and Fa did something else
altoe he just played Queen C5 which is
also I can see also a decent move very
direct move trying to uh take on C3 and
of course black pretty much always
welcomes this trade we've established
that I really don't want to do that
Bishop Rook takes B3 here is winning by
force not surpris but even completely
ignoring it yeah she takes D5 you're
also a lot happier because now your your
Center is back to being completely
protected this will not be
played has a direct threats KN takes
night win material which is why we're
going to seize the defensive with that
move exactly night night night a3s B1 if
there was ever a time to play Knight B1
now is it and here we have a
reappearance of a move that we like very
much because machine keeps suggesting it
and we have no idea why here maybe I can
say why because okay no oh okay
apparently I can't right this is so
beautiful I am oh thank you thank you
thank you magic screen look at this what
will you look at
this what Perpetual check
Perpetual will you look at this what a
bailout will you look at this now that
is not okay this is I I thought the idea
was FX4 and we gave ourselves the G4
Square so rewind that one again because
I I blinked and I missed it so okay sir
Knight a ab1 it suggests it actually
suggests H5 as the best waiting move
because apparently F4 F4 Knight E4 is
not a threat because we can take with
the Rook freeing up the B4 Square for
the Knight on D5 because you need it but
but show her how you got it Fe Rook
takes E4 Knight takes E4 Queen takes C
and then and then Queen takes it to what
you doing again am I playing a
beginner and as usual we are completely
sng wine about about giving up this
exchange we we perfectly happy just
playing this position because this is
just not a safe King and Machin already
suggests the only way not to get M it
more or less straight away is to start
giving material back with D2 D4 and
probably taking with the Rook if it gets
ctured so uh after Knight B1 which I
expect to happen I think uh it's it's a
very logical continuation from here you
don't really like it feels like Knight
A4 will just be immediately lost you can
never play that terrible you can never
play that feels like you know allowing
black to take on C3 twice also feels
wrong is that so clear though Peter I
take on e4 Fe right now and you take
twice on C3 I no I can also take here ah
okay I can also take I mean you can
maybe go for this position actually from
a human perspective this looks
unspectacular but very solid right
because I'm a pawn up I mean am the
extra F and so hang on a second so what
happens if okay I'm going to bite I like
this right so we buy we trade I guess
and then we go Knight B1 sming it away
we kind of have to take on G3 and now
for it goes Queen D2 Rook G1 which yeah
I'm trying to win the G6 Pawn you got it
I hate this for black I absolutely hate
this for black I mean you can like
survive the onslaught by going it's not
it's not the end it's not the end at all
in fact machine suggest was is still
manageable but look at the relative now
you get the Queens off in human
perspective
I I
could oh okay or queen G5 maybe this
this sun game is very unpleasant though
because it like you you will have to
Queen G5 sorry yeah Queen G5 is probably
stronger yeah let's go Queen
G5 uh still you're you're fighting for a
draw here you probably make it but
you're fighting for a draw here 9 be1 in
the metime has been I
understand you know get those Queens off
when your king is under it's funny
because I I I completely forgot it in
other situations like get to the board
and then you forget your own gold rule
that's not that's not allowable
uh uh by the way the clock times also
indicate something else Peter yeah very
important uh difference
there Fabby has played he's had a
terrific year he's had a fine tournament
d d da but I haven't seen him in time
trouble time management
today I saw him in time trouble in the
games that he lost against Hikari
Nakamura and they were very similar you
know he was
the in the grand Swiss you know hikaro
proposed a specific set of problems over
the board and Fabby just burnt time on
the clock trying to solve them trying to
find adequate resources and he didn't
quite manage
right and uh just to remind our viewers
who are joining us late we have been
talking about his exploits this year I
mean it's just fantastic you know winner
of the grand chest tour in Romania
$100,000 in his pocket in Croatia he
came forth at the World Cup he secured
his candidates spot by coming in third
place and also US champion also recently
just a few days ago won the St Louis
rapid and Blitz and then he's played in
other tournaments he almost won Norway
he was first going into the last round
Norway he did very well at the Grand
Swiss as well he was leading right until
the very end so fantastic year but at
this exact moment after by the way
Knight A3 to C1 a very human move I want
to say uh Peter looks like Oli raises uh
for choice and again Bobby down to his
last 15 minutes of this time control you
are going to show I I I I do want to say
that you know if if not for that pesy
hikaro he would have just won absolutely
everything this year
right that is a good way of putting it
uh at Knight A3
C1 and well these are problems3 C1
pardon me Knight A3 B1 uh uh really
uh I I I'm thinking this is a very shaky
position suddenly for five yeah you you
I guess you have to see that F takes C4
is not a threat specifically because
takes what I'm what I'm reading and I
should stop reading on one on one hand
it would feel very interesting to to
analyze this position without the engine
but we would have this idea which is a
stunning idea and it also feels like
it's at the core of what's Happening
here because we really don't want to be
taking ef3 that's that
really immediately improves the position
a great deal for white so we don't want
to be doing that and if we don't want to
be doing that then we have to have a
reply to fe4 you don't want to play E3
you don't want there's there's a lot of3
just doesn't work out because there's
with the KN on B1 there's no mate
anymore and things start falling apart
exactly and if you don't understand that
you have F4 Rook E4 reply to the capture
right you might panic and start doing
something stupid here right where the
currently the quote unquote best move is
H5 second best move is Rook D4 which is
also something that you don't consider
because
here again you need to see it exists
could you reinforce the control over E4
like for instance Rook E8 doesn't feel I
mean it's playable but it doesn't feel
quite right and weirdly in this position
compared to in a yeah like I'm trying to
figure out why this is different because
suddenly now the machine is much happier
about this for why it still doesn't take
on before but it feels a lot happier for
some reason about these positions it
feels like somewhat strangely putting
he's played Rook by the
way just at those various moments when
we're a little bit undecided whether you
should play moves like H5 you made
suggestions for moves and they've come
out you know like six out of 10
dentist well actually I'm trying to like
know when when Peter spells out the
problem attacking E4 and then you think
okay I haven't seen this spectacular
Queen takes C2 I I think that one's very
I think it's a very understandable move
yeah and uh it feels like uh you can
include H5 G5 but once again I don't
know why you would think this is in your
favor for white to include H5 G5 I
wouldn't be looking to do that no
because G6 was kind of vulnerable we had
more than one variation where it was
hanging on G6 so I'm not at all sure
it's easily humanly understandable that
this is good I'm not even sure it is
good and then there are Bish 3 Lines
which are very very uh difficult to
assess because uh now it says for
instance that we can go for very
specifically this position and play
perhaps D2 D4 here using the fact that
if you take on D4 Queens come off very
very important Knight on B1 covers all
of the checking squares and once Queens
come off there's still some counter play
but it's not going to be enough right
most likely so after D4 black very
calmly just says okay I play the will
play a position full exchange and pawn
down but I have this very very nice
Central setup which will be very
difficult to shake your king is still
very unsafe The Rook goes to A8 the
bishop joins the Party by a different
diagonal
now I don't know who I would take here
in a practical game I'm not happy no as
white with white you feel very very
unsafe yeah yes uh precisely so um got
news from VAR that uh the lvas made
progress like I just thought I I had all
but given up on the B position finished
I'm not sure I'm I think this this is
just maybe uh depth perception because
yeah it's so it takes a while and then
appears to suest suggest it's still very
bading up the advantage yeah uh we did
get uh leavon was was provoked to
playing the move uh
F6 we did he bring his Bishop to G8 or
no he just played F6 volun I think I
think he he feels that he can't avoid it
and there is one particular line I
really wanted to show because I I was
checking various ways for black of
trying to keep the shape trying to get
get balance and after Bishop G6 here I
thought what happens if we go just King
D7 King E7 King C6 King E6 I suspect
King C7 King B8 also wins but there is a
very instructive way of winning this
position we start by playing G4 and H5
okay that after F5 I suspect the pawn
ending is losing so now everything is
completely pinned into place you like
Knight E4 yeah I just wanted to check
with Knight E4 you just lose this uh
this Pawn ending I guess it becomes a
queen ending but we're going to be uh
winning in the in the eventual race once
black takes here F Pawn runs we take we
take yeah we take two and and the C pawn
quins and eventually it results in a in
a queen ending that it assesses as
completely winning yeah and if black
stays in spot in in place with King E6
the the way to win this is just to play
A4 and then
A5 and once we attack B6 both B takes A5
King takes C5 and allowing us to take on
B6 is just completely lost because the
Knight has no moves right we've just
completely denied any possible Square to
that Knight and the position just falls
apart so that is very instructive as an
illustration of what happens of what
happens if you stay passive eventually
you will be denied all possible sources
of play not even counter play just play
you will have to you'll have some one
move somewhere to repeat annosum and
then your position will collapse
so this is bad well I very much do that
breaking news of yeah I very much do
that myself when I'm calculating is I do
get to these situations where I say well
what my opponent is on the back foot
what if he just tries to do nothing what
if he tries to keep and that sequence
where you just showed a A4 A5 very
instructive breaking uh black uh there
is no Fortress Yeah finally you find you
find one weak point and considering how
passive black is basically one weak
point will be enough the moment we
create one threat we win yeah A45 for
now this is the position you can go
Knight d8 try keeping the shape this way
but we discussed this L this this setup
it it it keeps for one move right it
keeps for one move and then you have to
once again move something and allow an
incursion and yeah the the first
incursion win and in these King and porn
endings sometimes it's just simple
enough just to count because lots of
people go oh you know it's very
complicated to calculate no you don't
have to calculate just uh play out the
moves in your head with your fingers if
necessary exactly let's jump to uh the
other two games uh the one we had left
some time ago was the one between Richie
and mvl in that particular game I mean
the maths were very much in White's
favor he was a pawn up and he had the
two two Bishops but as um Peter was
arguing uh a great blockade uh a great
um Dynamic play against the pawn on
C3 uh maybe the position isn't as
one-sided as uh you might suspect it
would be um you would you would expect
that white would win this one exactly
easily if I'm on the white side you know
like I'm way past equality therefore I'm
much much much better exactly I
mean I I would be I would be already
visualizing the future I would be like
okay the poem will go to H4 maybe even
H3 just to tuck the King on H2 and then
from there the bishop goes to F4 and
then you know that Knight on D6 it's in
the way so therefore let's get the
Knight on e4 let's change the blockader
right get rid of the blockader and all
is well we'll keep an eye on that one
it's going to be a long Pro uh process
let's jump to the game of Anish Gary and
lanir we came into this wild yeah we
came into this um sin Phil cup armed
with all kinds of prep that us
commentators love doing which is stats
and much to our surprise well maybe not
that big a surprise we discovered lanir
Dominguez has never lost a single game
in uh singfield Cup history and that's
still the case and he's just played
these mov G5 Knight F4 Peter and you
were advocating for this some while ago
it's interesting because I gave this
exact sequence Anish played Knight D1
instead of my completely arbitrary mo4
but I just wanted to show the the idea
from black and even against Knight D1
which is a much stronger move than A4 uh
ler still went for this Clarity H4
provoking G4 pretty much needs to be
played you are not opening the H5 for
this Rook ever right so G4 G5 Knight E3
Knight F4 uh and for now included Queen
E1 and after Bishop B6 he's taken on F4
pretty much I I don't think we're ever
taking EF I don't although maybe we do
yeah it's very specifically uh I think
dependent on how how E5 comes out
because Queen D I started by thinking I
started by thinking this is not great
but this is actually kind of likes for
white weirdly because I think the pawn
on E3 will become a weakness more than
it will be will be a strength like f f
take C3 just go C3 and says this is not
fun greedy get get mega greedy and go
Bishop takes
B7 here you mean yeah yeah yeah we can
but I
think uh you're actually activ
activating some pieces
black greed is not enough the operation
was a success but the patients died yeah
but but but G GF was chosen I'm curious
because my my first thought was this
this isn't great but actually the Knight
has such poor squares that I think it's
very very specifically contingent on E4
E5 working or not working for white your
your choice of EF or or G takes F4 G
takes F4 is a more stable move of course
because now you have this this very very
nice setup the Knight will go to D5 I
suspect Knight F5 also exists but it
feels like an inferior Square because
you do want to exert some pressure and
after Knight
D5 you can just custle H4 isn't really
hanging uh because we we go Knight Tak
D5 and the Queens come off and we
recapture on D5 in the end so this is a
very comfortable position for black uh
so you can actually castle and then
perhaps for black the ideal kind of a
setup would be king G7 Knight H7 let me
once again just kind of make some moves
here so I think what I want is this yeah
this is probably a dream where I want to
end up and then F7 F6 and I've
completely uh safeguarded my king side
it's very slow though and even in this
position uh the machine indicates that
we've actually made some progress
towards towards what white wants to do
yeah and what what white wants to do
here I think is some kind of a plan with
C4 Follow by B4 and just playing on the
queen side because the white king is
also reasonably safe I don't think the
sacrifice on G4 is coming anytime soon
we can more or less both sides can more
or less forget the king side exists
right white I think would quite happily
accept black taking on D5 in most cases
so we're playing in this kind of a weird
situation where
this looks massive but can be sort of
ignored right and white wants to open
something on the queen side and
play but it's not it doesn't seem like a
winning threat right I would have a
genuine fear that my Bishop on G2 is
going to be a uh lost piece like if
Black Goes Knight D7 don't worry about
that yasa no bad Bishops good Defenders
good PS yeah no I'm with you yes I'm not
really all that worried about this right
this
happen sort of continues it continues
thinking there there's targets there to
to to be created but honestly I'm not
buying that all that much I think we
Queen G5 King G7 and just stay chill
stay I think I think it's fine uh and
just very briefly we don't have to
return to this this position but if you
want a vager wager on the outcome of
this game I'll take draw I think this is
perfectly fine like I'm not I'm not
buying this idea that white slowly but
surely and kind of ex ably wins this I
don't buy it for a second well H4 I
suspect was inaccuracy yeah I I just
your maths Peter remember your maths I I
don't know I don't know I I think
there's a lot of potential for White's
position you know put the King on H2 the
bishop F4 start chipping away yeah feels
kind of rock solid and the problem is
the moment he moved the Knight away from
B1 I will be attacking the pawn on C3 so
it's just going to be very difficult
to get get away from the base like the M
the moment you go KN G2 I go Queen A1
and you have to solve this problem
because you really don't have very many
pieces that can even protect the PA C3
apart from relevance because if you
break the bade how dare grubers
Association president you cannot say so
so you're arguing that something like
this will lose to 94 yeah that's my I
know the computer laughs at this but uh
I I yeah I mean if for instance in this
position I would give you these two temp
as well then maybe yes but you have to
and the reason I'm saying this is here
black takes on e4 and if you take with
the queen this comes to G4 and it's
black who's winning okay okay so we can
we can delay with the Knight coming
Tok I guess I guess the plan here is
actually to Play3 King G2 instead of
King H2 yeah but I can actually put the
queen on A1 sort of preventively yeah
and and just in this position we're both
chilling you're chilling I'm also sort
of chilling you know and yeah please
find a way to play Knight G2 Knight D2
is not I'm not getting there just yet
yeah no this is an incredibly sturdy
setup and in my experience it's just
very very difficult has put his Knight
on F5 in the I'm not sure I'm not sure
what that is about but but I guess he
wants an even like he wants the same
setup but with the Knights positioned
more actively yeah the the other one is
now coming to D6 I think he was also
provoked a little bit by the move H4
which now signals that the KN on F5
cannot be smoked away with H3 and G4
gotcha so you can you can also do this I
would be a bit worried about like one
thing I would probably want to avoid is
trading this bishop for any of the
knights right I'm always happily trading
this bishop for a knight on D6 right
because it leaves you with a like
chronically indefensible Pawn on uh C3
this one less so but I think the way the
white pieces are if you try to take on
F5 with this bishop your Pawn on D5 will
be so vulnerable I will just be able to
pick it up quite quickly can you play
very Mega slowly so first of all like
Queen B2 okay I'm stopping your queen
Coming in and now Bishop F3 love that
plan I'm a fan let me let me not make
any moves for a while show me G
show yes uh King and now you're maybe
ready to
go King G2 give her everything yeah okay
by this by this point by this point I'm
in trouble but
honestly a further argument I wanted to
make is I have a feeling even this is a
troll because I'll put the second one on
D6 and I think I will not lose that
position I'm less sure about that
because I think if I play properly I'm
probably not going to even allow this
but even even this position really I
don't feel like black should be losing
it that's a heck of a blockade is yeah
it's just it's just so sturdy but okay
this is not the this this will go on for
for quite some time we can go elsewhere
for now right uh not very much okay I
would say not very much happened in
Wesley's game but actually we are
progressing towards the king has
infiltrated the position the eventual
conclusion yeah actually for for for me
that's the the Bell uh sounding right
there that move King C6 and yes you can
go with the opposition King B7 King D6
and try to block but I'm picking up the
pawn on a76 play but he eventually will
get will will get shaken away from this
we discussed what happens if you stay
like if Wesley goes Bishop G6 here we
had this position on screen
I go G4 I go H5 just to make sure
nothing ever moves and then A4 A5 just
wins is there reason why in the current
position I'm not playing G4 we are
playing G yeah no no no no not Bishop G6
I mean in the game position to right now
just cuz I want to play
H5 and get the position that you yeah
this is this is still fine yeah my
initial reaction was why are we allowing
this but this but I you to take this
loses faster yeah I think this loses
faster yeah just go a for here wait for
you to take and now we have an
additional an additional Trump yeah I
don't hate this at all I don't hate this
at all so if we do see the move G4 break
Break Down The Dilemma that leavon is
having yeah you probably have to go KN
Knight of Knight of seven and King here
yeah maybe this is slightly more
difficult to win because now you have to
worry about the pawn on G4 so when the
Knight comes to E5 it will be hard if us
to organize A3 and B4 but it still feels
winning I apologize Peter with the with
the current position I play G4 you play
Knight F7 and you U uh edicated me with
a move A4 and A5 yeah but now we
actually oh sorry is there am I
blundering seems like we've thrown it
away for some reason yeah because the
night can come to F3 oh no but this is
just a draw now because I was trying you
know I was trying to get that A5 MH I
well I guess I need your knight to be on
D6 yeah no you need I think if if our
plan is to take on A7 it's very
important for us to preserve the option
of going A3 before because that might be
the winning the only winning plan once
we get to those structur okay another
words I'm not heading immediately to B7
and A7 but in this position go ahead G4
if you don't mind sure Knight and I'll
go B A3 okay just uh asking you how are
you going to kill me or what are you
going to do if you go Knight D6 then I
wanted to go A4 and A5 no this this
doesn't throw anything away I'm just not
sure if this is the f
yeah I I think um this is a kind of
position
where it's definitely possible to
misplay but misplaying it in such a way
that win becomes impossible takes a
takes a very very committal decision
which you miscalculate somewhere because
like the only re real line where we
actually threw away the win was this one
where we went G4 and then we went A4 and
once we get here we can no longer
actually create a break uh on the queen
side and this holds because for instance
even let's say in this position even if
I if I'm forced to uh give up on A5 I
will probably hold this very comfortably
because I will establish a dark spare
blade and also remember that as more and
more pawns come off the board happier
this is this is not the right this is
not the right uh corner for for the
bishop on uh F5 but this so far has been
the only position where the evaluation
suddenly went to zeros everything else
is just you you make your work like
more uh difficult but then you can
return to the previous plans and whereas
black is just holding and hoping nothing
bad happens to them but eventually
something will most likely Joy I I
noticed uh not for nothing but this very
difficult ending Wesley has gone down to
12 minutes it does mean that uh from
Wesley's per perspective is it is not
trivial no it's not trivial but on the
other hand Wesley is now going to make
his n 39th move yeah oh only two moves
for the time control so that's it's
insignificant time control right uh all
right once again uh because the
tournament co-leaders at plus one are
competing it's such a huge game uh for
the singfield Cup itself but also for
the candidates and the ratings uh let's
go to one of those players playing for
the ratings Ali Raza versus Fabiano and
we do have some
I think we've missed Rook takes E4 yeah
Rook Rook B takes E4 hasn't been played
here I'm pretty sure considering the
tournament situation and the rating
Chase alza would once he realized it it
wasn't actually a two move blunder and
Fab hasn't gone insane he would play
Queen F1 here and continue playing for a
win and if the resulting outcome after
Rook takes C4 just is all four Rooks
coming off he'll be very very happy but
yeah machine goes kn4 keeps keeps this
kind of a shape and uh this is still a
mess which is around equal I'm pretty
sure the idea of P2 just never occurred
to either of them yeah if you could show
for to any of our viewers who may be
joining is late the spectacular Queen
sacrifice good enough for a Perpetual
check thanks to the bishop this is a
very very unusual construction I don't
think I've seen this before absolutely
but Fabby very understandably he played
Rook E8 to protect it he went F take C4
and finally Bishop A3 has been played
and now Queen A5 is still playable I'm
very curious about the movie 43 because
generally I think you would like like to
try and soften up the Knight on on C3 so
I think it's a human choice but it very
specifically uh is not not great because
of I think D4 might be by far the best
move in this position I notice in this
position with played by the way yeah
que5 is very good yeah que5 is a very
good choice I notice in the position
with E3 for just a moment here uh the
the the G6 Pawn is very soft so that
after for example D4 and if you do take
a
one Bishop takes D4 yeah but that Los us
exactly to what you're talking about
right and G6 and everything all at once
yeah and things start falling apart
dramatically before the queen still has
to run away and this is actually having
given it some time to think it it it
doesn't even hate it all that but say it
says this is not horrible yeah not
horrible the inclusion of e3 and D4 I
would think should be in White's favor
but still says it's perfectly playable
very sharp but uh how is white going to
untangle mean we actually we actually
position we actually accept this and go
let's say Rook D3 and and here the only
the only way to continue is completely
unfindable because you you go H5 but you
don't go Bishop H6 here cuz Bishop H6
Queen D2 you have actually lost on the
spot I will recapture with the king and
the spin will do nothing for you not the
Eternal you can do it in the other order
in the order that actually looks
losing and in this position you pick up
on G3 and this is somehow still very
much a game because Bishops are just
better than knights in these positions
where a race will at some point start so
we get here we're just in time to also
stop the checks unbelievable and the
outside passer is so strong with the
bishop against Knight that this is
somehow playable unbeli but okay Queen
A5 is just a very logical move I like
what yeah what f is doing here is the
remedy still Knight takes Knight in this
particular position
not in the top two I think you can
actually take this Rook it looks scary
but you can take this rook and now with
the with the F pawns gone you have the
queen C4 check move uh which normally
would just after bishop6 you would have
to go back but now you are taking on e4
this is not great so so after the check
uh black just goes King H7 prepares it
for a move and then whoa oh my God take
it to take first line is first line is
unbelievable if you take on e4 the point
is no we just take and go Bishop F5 and
take one
C2 looks too scary for me pieces are
coming off the board more and more
pieces are coming off the board but the
remaining ones are very good for black
and this King remains not being safe
remains unsafe so you you you still have
to actually be a bit careful maybe even
with white but the line I wanted to show
you is Rook e three what uh just kind of
waiting for now I guess maybe trying to
play Rook D1 and create some squares for
our King and then it does something
absolutely spectacular it goes Bishop B6
and in this position it goes Bishop
takes B3 and if you take on E8 it goes
Knight A2 Knight A2 Bishop B2 King B2
Queen A2 and then you have to go up and
apparently it's a draw because it cannot
Escape yeah it can't escape can NE
Perpetual it goes no it's not even
obvious that you can't escape because
you you get to F6 and to E7 but that
doesn't help either somehow because
normally you know Common wisdom would be
if you get there yeah there's no prop
yeah it it will it will actually Escape
but no there is always enough checks
from the side somehow that's completely
you can't find that that's ridiculous
you might blunder into
it I think kind the accident but wow wow
Queen
A5 but yeah but in the meantime eight
minutes for hubby by the way this is
move 27 it's they've progressed quite a
bit it's only 13 moves to make but it's
8 minutes in as we've seen and an
unbelievably messy position so not going
to be not going to be easy to we do have
Bishop takes B4 Knight takes B4 on the
board P they are um playing actually
very very well from a certain point on
both talking about messy positions um
well this one is incredibly exciting we
keep an eye on this one can we go to
Anish giri against lenia Dominguez
because because lanir did recapture on
22 on 15 minutes Anish on 13 minutes and
KN take a look at what's Happening Here
Castle Queens side Queen A5 I
mean what is happening I I I I'm still
getting my bearings uh Bishop versus
knight I was about to say the light
squared Bishop the one that I was
absolutely fearful would become a dead
dead wood if the Knight didn't get
captured is now
roaring on the long diagonal and this
like last move threatening Queen takes
A7 uh really is asking a very San
question what are we going to do here
how do we uh defend if we go King B King
B keep it simple keep it simple all
right shall I uh tickle the B Pawn Queen
B7 be my guest Queen B5 threatening
another Rook can go B D7 where and then
Rook a
E1 you up to some Mischief there
I'm aspiring for C3 driving the queen
away this is absolutely the correct plan
but maybe the inclusion of Queen B5 r D7
actually helps black more than it helps
white helps black so starting with Rook
A1 maybe is is I was worried a little
bit about Queen B2 no Rook b11 is just
yeah that's ridiculous and it's very
evident because actually it suggests
going Rook D7 anyway and then we we can
go Queen B5 but we can actually start
with C3 and this is the kind of a shape
that I think it tries to keep here with
black s Queen D6 perhaps the other one
goes to either C8 or to E8 this is a
very sharp position because uh my
honestly my initial thought was this has
to be better for white but currently it
says that unless you immediately commit
with B2 before you might have to fight
for equality and against B2 before
before it gets incredibly messy I
thought it was better for black to be
honest with you I thought this bishop
was I thought I will find a way to open
the B file and then this bishop will be
very very Troublesome for black but
seems like black has things under
control here uh and here there's a
choice you can you can take C takes
before but even more interestingly you
can do this mhm suggesting that
suggesting that you can actually uh
afford to abandon a lot of material the
point being you actually need to throw
in B7 B6 potentially the point being
that without the Bish Pawn G2 the moment
we create any threat at all wow he in
trouble it costs it costs quite a great
deal so after Queen check this is still
manageable but this is very dangerous
for uh for white potentially yeah so you
have to be you have to be very very
accurate here with white uh kingba
hasn't been played yet it it'll resolve
itself oh there you go it'll resolve
itself you know each other so well
you've been you've been uh we've been
partners for for a long time me and the
life chest F you know it it was very
strange that final position that you had
because I wanted to say that King
vulnerability when the kings are cast on
opposite sides uh is Paramount I mean
often times you can be uh massive
material down but uh vulnerable King I
thought the King on H1 was nice and
protective exactly and this is why I
liked white initially but but this line
I showed with this double Pawn sacrifice
just trying to remove the most important
Defender this bishop PA G2 as Yan said
bad Bishops are very good Defenders the
moment it gets straighted away and black
attacks the white king side once it
suddenly starts looking like it might be
a very very big problem and before we
return to our two main dishes of the day
I just wanted to point out mvl actually
explained why he played Knight F5 which
is we're grateful for it because he
after Bishop F4 he played 9 D6 and then
he just went Bishop H6 which is just a
very concise explanation he says
pressure against C3 all good and well
but what I really want is to make sure
I'm left eventually with one Knight
against this really horrible Bishop on
F3 so this way of course Richie gets get
to play 9 G2 because attacking C3 is now
we don't have pieces to attack C3 right
but we are very very solid and you can't
you can't kind of go Bishop E4 and then
trade Bishop we're not going to allow uh
the trade I think yeah you go Bishop E4
he'll run away concretely here I was
going to say D5 is falling but because
of the fork it's not but yeah we we can
just move it away I guess I don't know
anywhere yeah and then put it back on a
51 to Bishop because without the threat
of KN but you have a knight f three
Knight to D4 yeah you have to oh no I
have problems already you have to you
have to watch out for tactics yeah I
think five yeah from exactly that's a
bolt out of the blue wait a minute my
centralized Bishop just got trapped like
that wasn't fair this this seems very
solid but we can let this keep this will
be played out for for quite some time uh
let's go to uh ala versus FIB because
this one is uh heating up very very
nicely and uh the clock times uh in that
game of Ali reses as well when we left
it uh Fabby was down to 8 minutes
although he has just played uh Knight
takes B4 not nothing has happened after
Bishop takes B4 Knight takes B4 Ali Raza
has been deep
in thought we have been looking at Queen
C4 check this is the most obvious move
with what else will what else would you
consider yes sir like if you had the
position with white H5 funnily enough H5
yes cuz the there are lines where maybe
I take on e4 and you play Bishop F5 mhm
and then you play Bishop take C2 on you
have to wonder if you have enough time
for that but maybe you do another move I
think you would consider here is D2 D4
right just to try to close down most
certainly yeah close down the bishop on
G7 so D2 D4 with just as you said the
idea I'm a little bit worried that C6 C5
might not keep that diagonal as closed
as I like what's wrong with H5 uh
nothing nothing in particular no I
think so we were looking at no actually
there is something wrong with H5 and
this gives us our first clear picture
picture of what's going on because H5
engine says E3 is now a borderline
winning threat and if if D takes E3 just
very simply Bishop takes E3 and then
Queen A1 and we've broken through
because the king can never come to D2 it
gets M from d8 right and we have force
it to go to D2 and then we win a lot of
material got so this this kind of
establishes what we what we're dealing
with E4 E3 is probably a thread that
needs to be dealt with uh sorry just to
continue line H5 E3 take on G6 take on
D2 finish me off nope for now we go
Bishop
A6 now I have to go somewhere yeah then
is actually just very very
pric it just say 82 mate
is a problem right this bled over hand
it over
yes my good and this is a very
picturesque way to box everything in and
like self SM smothered M but not not the
kind you've ever seen before yeah right
yeah so E3 is I think with this line
clearly established as a thread after D4
E3 is still playable but without the
bishop participating in the attack
immediately we get a hugely important
tempo do something uh
shockingly the list of things to do here
includes the move G3 G4 I guess maybe
bishop 5 is such a strong threat that we
need to deal with it no this is an
absolutely confounding position but okay
come on from the human point of view
from the starting position Queen C4
check is by far think what he's
calculating what he's calculating is
he's making sure he doesn't lose to
Bishop B6 like if he convinces himself
black will play King H7 I I think he
goes Queen C4 in a hard bit okay he's
making sure there's nothing here that
kills him like Bishop B3 some kind of
Bishop B3 or some kind of Knight A2
check or something he needs to make sure
that this that this is fine okay and
once he once he establishes that I'm
well he's gone D4 okay interesting so he
he wasn't convinced that he there wasn't
something there lurking very very
interesting that he's gone because this
I think is a much harder move to make in
a
practical because uh the idea of
shutting down the bishop on G7 seriously
perfectly sensible at the same time you
realizing that the move d4 is in some
ways provoking C5 and proving C5
provoking E3 Bishop F5 and just giving
black giving black a Tempo another thing
to consider here is our our old friend
the move H6 H5 reappears here with with
additional Force because Bishop H6 check
and Bishop G4 both are very very solid
ideas there are some things that white
can rely on as a response to H5 like for
instance Bishop H6 you got King
B2 that's in the bag well sure by the
way e E3 play E3 is very good very
quickly too I mean doesn't have time to
uh to burn so he needs to rely on on
intuition and the things he's already
worked out while while there as I was
thinking so yeah and what is the
currently uh best play I'm thinking
Bishop F5 is a serious threat tery but
pin is also playable somehow I guess
with the intention of meeting Bishop B6
with a rook takes E3 of course yeah and
this is another thing that you need to
assess properly because I'm not sure
about that because yeah King King F7 and
you need to understand that you can play
Rook D1 and the threats you have in
particular of Rook E7 check followed by
Knight E4 check are strong enough to
give up this piece Queen
for well currently black is just a piss
up for now yeah well yeah but but rookie
794 is a massive massive threat to such
an extent that the engine suggests
taking on D4 and now we get to some
position like this uh which is after
Queen A1 apparently the forest draw
needs to give a Perpetual I guess the
important thing here is that if you
continue chasing it it is actually
reasonably safe somewhere on the H3
Square you will run out of checks once
at and this is something we were
discussing I can't remember whether
whether it was on air or off air about
shogy and and crossing the river and
getting behind getting behind the Enemy
Lines there just suddenly completely
winning so the way to give a Perpetual
here would be to go Rook E6 and after
King F5 here uh okay yeah I don't know I
mean this this maybe you can understand
because the bishop just Falls you
exactly the reason I paused and started
once again shrugging and saying I don't
understand was that the engine actually
prefers starting with
this and after Bishop takes E3 G there's
Rook there's Rook F4 made oh yes so it's
demonstrating its you know full command
of the geometries of the board but but
the bigger point is of course the king
can go back and you do have to give this
Perpetual gotcha uh speaking of breaking
through and invading the enemy's Camp uh
let's go to Wesley so and uh leavon
because we're getting conflicting news
uh on the one hand we thought that
Wesley had the game in the bag and uh
well the game is still going on it's
still continuing because I think he's
done the respon ible thing which is do
nothing until move 40 and they've
reached move 4 this is move 41 so now
eventually he will have to figure out
how he's going to win this right I
suspect he will I don't think our
general evaluation of he will finally at
some point find a way in changes but
yeah he can't pass for much longer this
is this is all very good and well but at
some point you need to start collecting
pawns right and how is he going to do
that Peter this is this is winning it's
just that it's sort of trickier than you
maybe would have liked it goes King A6
you want A3 and B4 as I said if the KN
goes to E5 you can also consider going
King B5 and the4 A5 I'm sure in some
positions right and yeah I mean if if
you give the engine time here it just
says I don't quite understand why I'm
not winning like it just says I I am a
pawn up with a bishop against Knight
what's what's the problem and A3 and B4
is on my agenda as well what's the
problem exactly is this a difficult
ending for a human to assess you know
the king is off R A6 it feels a little
trick tricky trappy and and you almost
do have the fear that you you you may be
throwing things away youring your your
your king uh is in the wrong Square on
the other hand but you you have to make
progress exactly there are no points for
style you right you're not going to be
playing King takes F6 anytime soon so
you've got to be playing King takes a
yeah I think Leon has sort of nailed his
colors to the Mast here he said okay I'm
defending this way I'm I've completely
abandoned the A7 Pawn I'm not letting
you take anything else please take one
A7 I will lock it there right show me
how you win that position and some point
you do have to show how you win that
position it's unavoidable Fair uh going
back to our very key match
up play King B2 yeah I don't like King
B2 well and H5 is a very good response
by by F once again Bishop G4 is now
massive threat H5 has always been uh
sort of on our radar but now finally
we're reaching position where I can
explain in human language why it's
strong because Bishop G4 is just so so
unpleasant to meet Bishop G4 is yeah it
was funny I actually thought H4 H5 for
white uh could be useful just to stop
this bishop G4 but also kind of to stop
Bishop H6 here I'm I'm not happy if I'm
white uh Joy because the desirable Queen
C4 check is running into Bishop B E6 and
I really hate playing Queen C5 I I'm
just opening up that dark Square Bishop
I running for a bit I left the training
for a bit it's just lost for White Queen
C4 Bishop E6 is losing yeah Queen C4
Queen C4 no longer works because the
same variation after The Rook takes E3
Perpetual yeah there will be why are you
not yeah Rook E3 we get here King F7
Rook D1 but Bishop takes D4 you've also
made yourself much more vulnerable to
this because Queen A2 Queen takes C2 is
now a threat which wasn't wasn't as well
in some lines we were doing that so this
is now completely unplayable and the
engine suggests the only way to kind of
keep it a flow is to play Knight A4 and
black can even not obvious black can
even invest a Tempo on King H7 I don't
how easy it is on on on8 minutes but
it's very useful to sidestep all the
checks so you do this first after Queen
C4 I'm just checking the line that wins
here is maybe not like it's very
playable but maybe but maybe yeah maybe
in the process you will not be entirely
sure you're winning but these are all
very makeable moves and then the White's
problem is the king is still unsafe but
you now have additional problems of
really misplaced pieces vulnerable Pawn
on G3 because the queen will drop back
to C7 and start picking it up there's
also a very strong passer on E3 MH we're
still in exchange on the pawn up so
perhaps from some way away you can be
excused in thinking that this is
playable for white but yeah the engine
says like you play Knight A3 black plays
Queen C7 and things just start falling
apart here it's it's hanging on G3 we
also have Bishop G4 any two coming in
it's just bad I mean can you go KN C
just to kind of try to keep the game
alive like how about Rook G1 Rook G1 I
was afraid of D2 yeah can already yeah
it says we can come just G4 is strong
Queen E7 is even stronger apparently
Queen E7 yeah I mean obviously we're I'm
doing this with the machine which
instantly points out to me that things
like this are working but but but
frankly it looks like they will be
working because like look at this the KN
or yeah they should be somewhere here
they should be on E5 and E4 right they
should be stopping this from happening
and they're and they're all the way over
there and not doing really very much oh
my so yeah this is Shifting to kind of
conclusively in fabi's favor the only
problem is he's on 8 minutes and this is
still a massively sharp position which
is very easy to misplay there's a lot of
very precise calculations will be
required and let's remind our viewers
that this if Ali Raza were to fall into
defeat in this game this could very
easily knock him out of the candidates
race uh because he would lo you lose yet
again another five rating points and uh
well he's gone
and for if that happens you know he
still has three games to play but not
good here's the ratings watch and what
we're talking about prior
to uh the start of the tournament Ali
Raza came in with a lead in the race the
player who yes cuz the player who has
the highest rating on January the 1st
who hasn't qualified for the candidates
will get that spot into the candidates
tournament and before the tournament
before round five Ali Resa fuja had
2761 and there was Wesley with 2750
against Richard report but came round
five Ali Resa loses to Richard report
and he drops down and uh Wesley Leap
Frogs by one in the rating list and
here's what we mean by that changing of
the of the rating position Changing of
the Guard and with with the round
panning out the way it's panning out and
I will show you one additional position
uh in a moment it really feels that if
Wesley converts his he just more or less
locks it up weirdly because look at this
we we we stopped discussing the uh gear
Dingus position somewhere here L instead
of Rook D7 made another perfectly good
move Rook h8 always useful to protect to
protect the one vulnerable point and
here something like Rook E2 was still
completely playable white is fine uh but
Anish committed himself to playing C3
and queen takes C5 lineer played Queen
G3 Rook D2 is a massive massive threat
if4 is a threat thing is a threat and
here white is already in trouble but
after Rook G1 you can still fight Rook
G1 you're only really worse if black
finds Rook D3 everything else you're not
even worse okay but Anish instead played
Queen F2 and now linear took and played
Knight H7 this looks lost this doesn't
even look worse no this black will play
F6 black will play 9 G5 and look at this
pair of passers right and uh well
incidentally if Leno wins he will
overtake Anish giri in the ratings and
and potentially even ala if ala loses
today so everything to play for but
Wesley will lanir wasn't even in our
race yeah but Wesley should Wesley win
it feels like he might be locking it up
10 points ahead of people yes locking it
up because he he is winning and they're
losing they were all very close right
but ala is in Desperate trouble and
Anisha is in even more trouble today
than ala both with white pieces as well
is quite quite shocking so very much you
know dependent on on how this comes out
and Wesley is doing it slowly he's
played A3 a bit earlier than expected
but once again he's using the fact that
this Knight you know wherever you jump
this this just takes away all the all
the squares so he's doing it slowly but
I think he's doing it correctly and I I
still feel like he probably gets there
and uh with the other positions of the
round the rating spot could be more or
less on lock after today it feels it
feels like uh help me out here Peter
understanding how the engine thinks
because as you were talking that bar uh
actually goes A4 A5 for the king C7
we're making the argument that we will
need to take on A7 but I think Wesley
found a way not to uh but I I I I I keep
seeing this bar going up and up and up
it's like the longer the engine thinks
the more it realizes the position yeah
this is exactly the kind of position
where you you you let it run and it just
realizes how how hopeless it is because
it reaches a certain Horizon Beyond
which there's no salvation and this is a
very cute plan by the way he goes A3 I
think you kind of need to go Knight D6
now to maybe at least try to like dis
balance it somehow because Knight E5 and
this is I think why he burned a Tempo he
wants to be playing A5 with a knight on
F7 right and you cannot allow A6
actually maybe you can yeah well I'm
just going to take twice yeah take tce
maybe before C5 and just Cen the C Point
that's much cleaner and and this is just
lost right this is is just lost because
we will take on C5 and then we will once
again start joking for position and you
will start having to give me squares
backing up yeah and and the C Pawn just
runs and the Knight continues having no
squares to look forward to this is maybe
a very very clean conversion actually by
Wesley I like those're very clinical
says I don't even want to get involved
in those positions where my king is
sideline and I need to spend a lot of
moves bringing it back I'm just going to
win this one uh a lot of technical uh
chess but also in the game between fabbi
and Ali Rea uh tactics at work too
because I noticed that okay we we we've
seen Knight A3 B1 but now we went and
saw a knight on B1 back to A3 in the Ali
Raza game he played King B2 H5 Knight A3
G Bishop G4 this was a check King H King
H7
Y and uh yeah just to interrupt you see
arbit should be more careful with those
clocks because I'm pretty sure this has
just been registered as black wi okay
well it is a draw between Richard report
and we are not wor yeah I see what you
see about about the black king there uh
but we are not worthy uh you called this
draw from a long distance uh good
Dynamic yeah I think I think andil did
did a very clever thing there with
training the Bishops off which which
also feels like maybe rard after after
he saw the Bishops disappear he kind of
lost lost hope in winning position
because after after that trade the game
didn't really last very long M also
brought the queen all all the way to E5
where it really dominates everything and
it just doesn't look like white will be
able to create a single thread here so
they found a repetition and uh the game
was taken off off our screens I'm sorry
I want to say that's impressive
understanding uh I mean joy and I were
you know doing our Mass like uh good
pupils and uh I also like being a this
is not not a very impressive and this is
a very very impressive blocker exactly
great let's not let's not lose sight of
what do we have after uh okay I go Rook
A1 uh yeah Rook A1 now you actually now
you actually just lose to Bishop B6
among other things but this is the most
direct because we've lured The Rook away
from the D5 and and the D4 Pawn is
falling and even Queen C5 like you after
Queen C5 I very happily actually enter
this end game and after 91 this is
painful yeah like you never Eternal pin
yeah you're never unpinning yourself
yeah no this actually I think it goes
King H6 with the intention of including
including the king in the
attack no no I understand I understand
why it goes King H6 it it one thing you
can blunder here and shouldn't is Rook
A7 takes G7 so it preventively unpins
the bishop to be able after Rook A7 to
play Bishop B5 and not allow white to
give that that Bish that Rook away you
Cann and then everything just starts
getting he play Queen F7 though yeah
Queen F7 is maybe an attempt to create
uh some kind of Mayhem um hang on a
second let me okay looks good find my
place uh my intention of course was to
be able to meet Rook A8 with Rook A1
Queen F7 hits the rook and kind of
invites you if you like you're not
invited M say queen d8 and I think it's
actually a very playable move even in
severe time trouble because Rook is
still hanging I am now threatening to
take with the queen on D4 which
basically I think will lead immediately
to mate I'm also hinting at the move
Rook E7 which will show away the one
active piece white has uh and yeah
things are just completely falling apart
you can try playing Knight E2 okay
Knight E2 but yeah the best move here is
Knight D5 which I don't think many
people play but what people do play is
Rook f8 Rook F2 y that looks rooka
played instead of all of that anyway
yeah
start I think so I can hang around was a
more natural move because it's this
actually this actually gives white some
hope but now I can hang around Queen E7
E7 I I don't like this I think the PO E3
is such a valuable asset that I I don't
like leaving leing
touch oh could you now come in with the
Rook no we're still we're still probably
winning like takes takes we go C6 C5
very understandable playable move cu the
bishop wants to breathe it's still bad
second just a second hold on I'm trying
yes Knight C4 we drop back to
A8 but no yeah okay no this is this is
very this is very very hanging this is
very difficult um instead of this is
very difficult instead of C5 I mean what
about Rook F2 I want to keep it as
simple as possible she isn't hanging
though well there's a big trick though
if you take the pawn with the queen that
is very beautiful though yeah that is
very very
beautiful
Cho coffee and
apparently I think actually I I want to
compliment Yanka because I think in
Practical terms this just wins on the
spot right because the only move here
which apparently saves the game as C3 is
just to give up on C2 is check what no
way so B4 is hanging and this is yeah
because I I'm actually trying to pick up
your knight on B4 you can you can play
Queen F5 and now the only move that
doesn't lose is Knight takes E3 but
that's easily but from here you can
navigate because yeah like everything
else will immediately lose of and then
after Queen F2 I can take on B4 I'm
still not winning despite being a full a
full piece up but I'm also not losing
because we have that's a good but that's
a good sign Queen E7 on the board yeah
and queen E7 played yeah no this is a
this is a very dramatic turnaround
because it does it make sense not to
take on I like your move Rook F2 I'm
wondering if I don't have to take on D1
but now yes with the Rook on E1 and the
bishop on G4 alive we can actually go
for this position we're going to be a
bit worse but because the the queen is
protected because uh we end up because
the Rook is protected
the the queen on E3 was protected by the
rook and also we are now taking on D1
with the Knight which is something we
weren't doing there and like is still
having you know the better of it but
this should be a draw tonight but this
is not the uh killer this this is
killing this is selling it a bit short
yeah wow and the players are down to 7
and 1 half minutes and
five minutes for Faby and I have to tell
you again if you like um you know the
world of class IC Le chess and Tents you
cannot find a game that has more
consequence than this one I mean this is
this is the determinant game for the
candidates uh for Ali Raza and he
absolutely needs this game he's an
exchange up he's two minutes ahead on
the
clock it feels like struggling to make a
draw and struggling to make a draw
struggling to make a draw and without
Rook a eight Queen E7 I would have bet
on him not making a draw but now I think
it's very possible because that line
that the engine shows as winning yeah
which one Bishop D1 Bishop D1 is Rook D1
yes C5 C5 yes yeah I feel like it's
pretty much unplayable because after
Knight C4 you have to put it on A6 or8
let's let's put it on A8 just for
clarity okay yeah and you have to
realize that after Queen takes
C5 uh you you are still doing extremely
well because you go e32 okay that's a
Tempo against if the Rook goes somewhere
along the back rank uh we have Rook F1
yeah and A1 is yeah and landing and uh
you you can't take the pawn on E2
because que check check one yeah Rook e
two queen after E2 the best move is Rook
C1 okay uh and even more weirdly uh Rook
F1 now uh isn't winning at all because
of Knight takes E2 because of Knight
takes C2 and we've protected the C2 pawn
and we aren't getting mated anymore
lucky us yeah but instead of Rook F1 the
engine suggests that both Knight C6 and
Knight A6 are winning which I think is
just completely unfindable Knight A6 is
winning Knight A6 is minus
three yeah because I would have never
yeah he's Bishop takes Rook yeah he's he
started by Bishop D A6 yeah the point is
the Pawn on D4 is just getting picked up
this is the the explanation after KN A6
this is the Crux of it yeah you cannot
you cannot keep control of the D4 D4
point and once it get once it falls your
position starts collapsing massively but
yeah I I don't think this is realistic
wow we will not see this so we do have
Bishop takes D1 on the board as uh the
start of it all I don't see another move
then Rook takes D no he he he has to
take on D1 uh Knight takes D1 loses on
the spot because there's an x-ray along
the A5 V1 diagonal of course he will
take on D1 there's no choice and I'm
pretty sure Fabi is intending to play
Rook uh Rook F2 uh because it looks
winning yeah it just it just looks
winning yeah uh but we know that it that
it's not specifically because of Knight
C4 and ala will have seven minutes so
Rook to to find Knight C4 uh
inviting the delicious Queen takes A3
Queen takes
A3 uh CH Knight takes C2 for king king
and queen but it's Knight C4 that's the
Savior yeah yeah by the way that's a
that's marvelously
isn't and the time control requires six
moves for uh for FIA and five Fabby six
yeah six M for Fabby way five mov
fora wow the best move here by far is
that line starting with
C4 play I was pretty sure that was the
intention C5 would have been and and the
and the second best move is also
completely uh unplayable in a practical
game because instead of Rook F2
black is borderline winning after Knight
D5 just trading an attacking piece and
giving up on E3 this is also something
you just like like Knight takes Pawn
takes Queen D5 Queen E3 Rook F3 Queen D5
Queen E3 Rook F3 and it says this is
massively better for black just because
the Knight is so Knight is horrible your
entire King side is is about to get
picked up your king but nobody plays
that it's I just wanted to mention it
because uh it's a good to know it's an
outlandish enough position to to to
bring up but yeah but Rook F2 again that
is such a well human move because you do
see that you're hitting C2 you do see
that you're
defending uh tactically your Pawn on E3
and you think I've got this in the bag
until you see Knight C4 which is by the
way strictly the only move everything
else loses everything else loses yeah
the threats are just so many Queen F5 is
a threat E2 is a threat you resign or
you play Knight C4 but you have to fight
every instinct yes that you have because
you're allow takes C2 with a check as
Peter's highlighted and maybe you just I
mean is there a direct threat like for
instance if you if I go G4 yeah like G4
rookie one I mean I'm just trying to
find a iose I suppose Rook D2 might even
be something pretty nasty but C5 once
again the win is the win is very strange
after G4 goes it actually goes E2 Knight
E2 Knight D5 and says you have to start
dropping material because of how strong
let's show this on the board E2 E2 92 95
E2 yeah once again giving up giving up
our pride and joy right I mean 95 and
the point here is the queen is H oh this
is just so beautiful if the queen goes
anywhere let's say queen E4 or queen E6
doesn't matter looks like a nice Mo we
take on E2 Rook E2 Queen E2 yeah we give
a check on C3 I I have to choose a
square any
[Laughter]
Square uh A2 Queen takes
D4 get lost
yes this is a this is an appropriate
response to this what no no no okay Rook
takes Rook might
take okay and then I have to walk and
you played G4 as well meaning that
you've created a pastor for
me thank you for hanging uh my king
no this is this is also not happening
but after G4 after G4 there are other
Moves In
fact H takes G4 Queen takes D4 is a
visual yeah I just wanted to show that
line because Queen C3 takes D4 which
happens by the way against both King A2
and King B1 having an additional C1
Square changes nothing I still go Queen
takes D4 well but here's the point I
mean it's very easy to see that G4 is a
Desperado Rook E1 just simply doesn't
work because of Knight D3 check you come
to the conclusion you have to play
Knight C4 and you just hope that Queen
F5 Rook F2 and queen
F5 feel like that yeah so you're you're
absolutely obliged and the crazy part is
that this position is actually
salvageable yeah it holds but if you
miscalculate yasa you're going to go
down in the history books as the person
who just literally threw away his
candidacy I I get it but I in this
particular case the the Knight on B4 is
a is absolutely uh critical to the
attack uh The Rook will be hanging and
no not found he didn't find it he played
Knight
E4 he didn't find that yeah this loses
to a number of things including Rook
takes C2 this is what I was wondering
this wasn't blundered but it wins I'm
pretty sure he means instantly by Fab
King B1 though this wasn't a blunder he
will play King B1 instantly and Fabby
will have to find the only move that
wins which is to put the Rook back
Knight F6 check needs to be stopped yeah
he's played King
B1 as you've said yeah ala didn't miss
Rook though and the point is Ali Reza is
looking for pepet Knight F6 check and
Knight G8 check will be his perpetual
and what you just said Peter is stop him
Rook of two wins Rook of Two And if
wind's reasonably no Queen no but he
have Knight G5 Knight G5 and King h8 is
Knight
G5 King why do I have to go King H6 K
six Queen takes E3 it still wins it's be
your paring Queen E3 so King h8 yes King
h8 and now my question was why can't we
go Queen E8 and queen takes G6 right but
then we lose the end game Queen F5 check
and the ball only E3 decides so Queen E8
check Rook f8 for for example Queen
takes G6 and we just trade Queens yeah
we go Queen F5 Rook F5 and there's just
no defending against C2 Rook F1 it's
just completely
lost wow completely lost E2 followed by
Rook F1
resigns yeah I think Fabby gets there
because there's just no other way
properly to stop Knight F6 check he just
gets there by process of
elimination wow tense moments right
here well unless he's thinking of Queen
but even then that doesn't work Queen F5
Queen F5 takes you to we may have lost
yeah it's a lot of material exactly well
Rook F2 the only move well the thing
that uh stops me cold is just that
Knight F6 check will be an instant
perpetual and if I'm thinking I'm
winning with black I'm playing Rook F2
just to
stop
wow
let's just quickly just as as we're
keeping our eyes uh peeled to this game
we do have one draw but what's happening
in the lineer game yeah uh I think I
think Anish did the right thing in this
position if you uh if you allow F7 F6
here you will die a very painful death
because black will never have to worry
about anything he played the6 himself
trying to at least shake this away right
mess it up but n N9 G5 and then ler very
uh carefully prepared to take on F6 you
you could already take here but this
allows Rook takes F4 but is still better
but no reason to allow it he's going to
King d8 before and he's taken on F6 now
and now the king will uh return to B8
and we can start start finally pushing
our pawns down the board this looks
winning for black beautiful and nothing
much changed in in our end game here but
we we kind of know this is winning it's
just that Wesley needs at some point to
commit to a winning plan he is still he
is still waiting and yeah Rook F2 played
by by Fabiano so let's go back to
watching that
wow and I
just this could be I mean we we we
started with so many draws at the start
and uh suddenly uh the the bubble burst
exactly well the St gotten higher
right after the resid all of those
thoughts completely bogus 48% in round
one who said that not me it was all
draws and what happened after the rest
day well today today is and I mean
statistically speaking Wesley uh plays
terribly after the rest day yeah well
maybe not so terribly not according not
according to this no not according to
our
scream Rook F2 Joy that's a that's a
very very nice move because it just
leaves all kinds of questions yeah the
simple the simple idea is Knight takes F
two yeah knight5 check has to be played
Knight F two queen A3 is basically made
right and now Fabby still needs to be a
bit precise because King H6 looks like
like it's cleaner than King h8 but
allowing Queen takes C3 is unnecessary
you don't need to uh have that in your
life exactly yeah you're you're probably
still winning but there's no reason to
to give Alo this Ray of Hope no but this
line that we saw with King h8 and
trading queens that was a very
impressive but uh there Queen takes E3
though at the end of that one well in
this particular case A3 keeps hanging
right in all of these
we we don't have time for the desirable
my bad yeah no worries I has a minute
and a half for three moves but really
there's only one final difficult
decision to be made has to choose
between King h8 and King this is our
current position the Knight just went to
G5 how much time did
did Ali Resa has just over three and a
half minutes whereas Fabby is ticking
down to the minute Mark and they'll move
38 these professionals are so used to
this 302 increment it's not something
that I grew up with let's put it that
way whenever I got down
to this a minute uh not panicking but
butterflies and
tension all kinds of things precise
Until the End King h8 feels like he wins
from here because after Queen E8 really
only move Rook f8 you're never playing
bishop f8 and after Queen takes G6 white
is actually threatening m in one he will
St he will be forced to play Queen F5
check and he will also reach move 40 at
that point and that end game is easily
winning it's really not not difficult at
all yeah it's just wow game completely
over there well for Fabby
uh first of all it brings him right back
into the mix of uh winning the singfield
cup very very nicely kind of deals with
some ghosts of uh I say the two nights
defense where he lost to hiar also with
this win yeah does he secure himself the
win of the grand
Chester I suspect you're right I suspect
that he will right that absolutely just
does it because mvl theoretically could
surpass him if he if Obby were to lose
but I suspect you're right yeah such a
consequential game for fuja as well
weirdly in the current position Forza he
needs to realize that end game is
completely lost and a way to actually
ask Fabi one final pertinent question is
to take on E3 here
against which the only actual clean win
yes is Rook
fate that case I may be taking on he
need he needs to make this move he needs
to make this move ites I would be afraid
of que takes A3 Queen E3 is just black
is fine but you're not winning after
Queen F2 Queen B3 King C1 there's
apparently no ma there I this holds no
kidding this holds I would not have
guessed that black is maybe a bit a bit
better but but this holds the thing is
after Queen E3 we go Rook f8 A3 is still
hanging and we just go Rook A8 next move
and we collect the full piece I'm pretty
sure fa will find it but it at least
asks a question Queen a check asks no
questions whatsoever after Queen a check
you're forcing your opponent to win the
game because both moves are only
moves an interested shall we say uh
Wesley so coming into view there as
Queen takes E3 Rook f8 clean win yeah
yeah because the point the n on A3 is
completely indefensible there you can't
do anything
gotcha that makes a great deal of sense
of
course this Knight on A3 what o and ala
also taking down to the minute Mark um
boldly stating the obvious uh Ali raza's
last two games have been
disastrous right or close where did it
really start going wrong I mean the game
with lanir well his game against Richard
was very shaky right he he took a lot of
risk in the opening and uh yeah he could
have won against lenier but that was
incredibly sharp and yeah I guess it was
a bad game against leavon yeah oh it
feels like he was maybe the the one
player in this tournament who was
generating the most chances both for
himself and for his opponents but he
finally goes Queen a check and now as I
said Fabi it's impossible to not make
those two moves and then that end game
is like you might at first think that
maybe I will be in time to somehow
control the but you you really aren't no
you really really aren't
wow wow um control Big Stuff Queen takes
G6 Queen F5 check the players will have
made a Time control and that will be a
winning ending for Fabby uh inform us
again what's going on in the is Gary
game well I I assume ler should now be
winning by force but I haven't checked
it in a while
yeah ler is very much in control here so
after Rook D7 checking B8 Anish played
C4 the pawn started running on their
March towards the queening squares L
also invested in in a Tempo on the Move
A7 A6 Anish tried Rook D6 even Rook to
D6 is winning but I think this is a very
understandable decision not giving white
the passer on D7 is worth more than an
exchange and yeah the engine just takes
takes another one says three are not
even F3 no it just says I'll take one H3
I put it back on G5 and then I will push
three of them while you have zero
counterplay whats he's G he's gone
Knight F3 which is uh a bit unexpected
but doesn't really spoil very much
concrete idea yeah Rook G8 just going
for mate yeah this is also very strong
yeah very very strong and lineer is
doing this on kind of low time but this
is move 39 he doesn't really 19 seconds
for Anish doesn't really have very many
decisions left here for for lineer oh
pardon me this is move 39 yeah should
win from here 11 seconds and counting 8
second
six two played because what else do you
do he did it with two seconds on his
clock yeah and Rook G8 is not the only
thing that wins but it wins very
conclusively so I'm pretty sure ler has
done like he he played Knight F3 to play
Rook G8 I'm I'm very very certain
so yeah this one is is being concluded
let's go back to
our end game between
uh looks like Wesley has collected the
A7 Pawn under the best of circumstance
yeah he's actually gone gone for that
winning plan and now he can play I think
he pretty much always start by playing
Bishop B4 just to make sure that the
knight uh has no good moves and then we
play before next move exactly and we
give black very unpleasant choices like
let's go knight6 before and the issue
for one here is if you take on before
you will eventually probably Force white
to do this maybe but the problem is it's
not that the C Pawn is winning on its
own it's just that eventually you will
have to allow the king to get to the
king side while we are never going to in
fact white probably at some point just
plays H5 Bishop
F3 I would I would actually not be
against this at all just play H5 Play
Bishop F3 indicate to your
opponent nothing nothing will ever hang
on the king side right and then there
will be T swangs like N9 G5 we go Bishop
F3 let's just just to illustrate like
okay I I may have thrown it away but
yeah if we if we go King B5 here we're
still winning right King B5 King C5 and
now King C5 yeah so you do this and for
for the moment I have no way in but I
play Bishop G4 and you have to start
giving me giving me away giving ground
yeah yeah and and then and then the
whole thing collapses so impressive
should be should be very very
convertible from here by the way no Rook
not sorry yeah here we go here is the
ratings watch is the highest rated
person on January the
1st so the idea here is just one rating
list the January 1 rating list is the
rating list that will Des decide a spot
in the Toronto candidates tournament uh
the highest rated player who's not
already in the candidates will get an
invite and because of the switching of
places that's occurred since fuja has
lost his game against leavon and is
likely losing the day Wesley looks like
he's punching a ticket and by the way
there was no Rook G8 uh lanir is
just second best second best move still
wins very very comfortably we want to
play 94 and then of three of three and
like we we just break through knight4 a
bit surprising that he chose this over
the other one cuz the other one felt
like it was winning faster but it really
is a matter of taste I don't think it
matters a great deal and there we see
Wesley so did Wesley make the time
control I'm sure they have this is
actually 14 minutes for the for the
final time contr okay exactly I just
wanted to be sure Anish G is looking at
a lost position this last move Rook E4
sets up yes play of one second left on
the clock I saw 32 seconds yeah and I
right I oh laner played yeah yeah
no no you're telling me that lanir
played his 40th move cuz he had 40
seconds he left himself he left himself
a second there it is I don't know if
through the magic of Television we could
actually see this but this is ridiculous
Rook E2 so you have Rook G8 and you have
Rook E4 yeah both are winning both are
and you take it down to one second to
decide like what if there's some kind of
a you know motor malfunction like you
drop it you drop it while driving it to
E4 exactly like yeah this is this is way
too unnerving for me to even contemplate
rookie for one second he played that
it's there I always had that you know
like I don't know if it's a nightmare
dream where you know your opponent okay
we're playing MH and you've gone down to
a few seconds and you're about to make
your move and I suddenly go a you yeah
making a terrible sneeze this doesn't
really happen very much in top level
chest you know what I mean we lost
Joy well we but like seriously you open
yourself up to to all kinds of all kinds
of gamesmanship yeah I I don't really
understand why why you would do this to
yourself then you overstep obviously
because my my my sneeze just threw you
way off yeah there was a very famous
example of this I remember the first
time I was introduced to this idea in
reasonably high level chess there was
this grandmas who I'm pretty sure you
probably played against The Grandmaster
from my hometown
constantina I did not play him very
famili you knew him yes uh he was
probably and you must understand that
I'm a lifelong friend of Alexander
grishuk yes he can't hold a candle to
what I say if was doing in every game
like it's just like he would
consistently be like on a minute by move
20 right always in time uh and that's
very very old school no increment there
was never any increment and he was
playing in an aof flot open I want to
say 05
thereabouts and uh he played against a
very young
player uh who if I think very hard I can
probably name but I think it's not
really that necessary in particular
because I'm not going to be
complimenting him very much uh and a
safe was playing his pet open pet
opening with black and he outplayed them
completely and uh
uh and and
uh but as usual he's down to absolutely
last 3 seconds or something right and
it's move 39 his position is completely
winning okay and he is on on on hooks
waiting for a move to reply to and then
he can finally get up and he has a king
on G8 and a knight on F6 okay and the
guy goes Queen F5 H7
check so the intended King G7 no no no
there's nothing protecting it right it's
just it can be taken in two different
ways but you have four seconds to take
it right and I say it went like uh and
lost on time right yes so so you sort of
open yourself up to this stuff right you
you you might not want to be in that
position uh what ler has done I mean
obviously in a game with increment it's
not as bad because as long as you
continue making moves you will continue
not being a 3 seconds but yeah Queen H7
yeah I I remember I still remember it I
remember the square and everything cuz
like very clearly that player chose like
he thought okay if this game actually
reaches more 40 I'm losing I'm losing it
so why not just there have been
incidences where people have like people
been trying to promote a porn and
they're looking for the queen and their
opponent has the the queen yeah no was a
very famous Bernie zukerman his opponent
had gotten the queen and was ready to
promote Bernie made a move grabbed the
queen across the stage I am not joking
Rook E4 on the board I just wanted to
see uh what has happened in the Fabby
game right into that ending that we
described completely winning now for
Fabby as those two as both players of
made yeah Rook E1 is the only is the
only serious uh serious question to ask
here alza has already played Rook E1
Rook F2 is winning uh just in a moment I
I'll show the two relevant variations
right um but rookie one okay attacks the
pawn yeah first first thing to first
thing to realize after Rook E1 is that
the pawn on e4 E3 isn't actually hanging
I can play Rook F2 if you take I will
give a check from F1 I will take on D4 I
will collect absolutely everything
correct so it's it's not actually
generating any threats which is why Rook
F2 is so strong maybe Knight C2 was yeah
and taking away taking away Knight C2 is
a very useful thing to do so Rook Rook
Rook F2 is completely winning right but
there's also a more direct way we can
take on D4 as long as we realize that
after Knight
we have this move Bishop C3 oh Jo and
again I have to work one way further
because you do have Knight takes E3 yeah
and then I guess we switch over to to
giving mate from that
side
or actually Rook F2 is cleaner because
Rook F2 creates maing threats which are
harder to Parry I don't know we were
ready to resign after
Rook on our behalf I was ready to resign
the game because Rook A1
Mission takes E1 Rook F2 is maybe the
cleanest cuz let's say if Knight E4 we
can even sort of introduce this idea and
I'm not even threatening the Knight so
much as I'm threatening Bishop takes D4
and Rook
A1 yeah so there's just too much going
on as long as Fabby keeps his head here
he is winning this game and this really
does is there any margin for era here
for Fabiano so I'm
thinking Bishop takes Pawn we've
established is fine yeah so in this
position you you cannot not play Bishop
C3 everything else just throws
everything away Bishop C3 is a a
beautiful winner Rook E3 Rook f one
that's that's toast it's not very
difficult yeah and you can take it
whatever you want exactly well then it's
just a disaster for Ali Resa and let's
go and take a look at the No No move has
been made in the Anish giri Lena
Dominguez game either again
made with one second on his clock by lir
Dominguez I just love your sing trick
again that's going to go into my
playbook dirty to dirty yeah yeah it was
how to cheat at chess by Bill hartston
absolutely brilliant brilliant book by
the way what exactly are we promoting
nothing nothing nothing just saying that
don't do this don't go down to one
second on your clock cuz something can
go wrong I mean wow uh this has turned
out to be an incredible eventful round
we came into today's um round two
victories out of 2021 if you're counting
so two victories out of 20 but every
single game here has been uh brilliant
and we're going to have a lot of
Victories it would but all three
remaining games look like they should
end in a decisive bringing us to 5 out
of 24 which is still not not a lot but a
lot better than three than two out of 20
we take 10% yeah yeah take the very
exciting games from the technical to the
dynamic I I mean what can what more can
we ask for and every player has made the
time control so we are going to take a
quick break don't go anywhere because
we're going to be back in a few minutes
with a lot more of the chess
[Music]
action
hello I'm women's Grand Master V toara I
will be creating content for Grand chest
store follow us on social media and
catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess hf.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at at Q Boutique you can
shop both in store and online from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education hello I'm women's grandmas R
to janova I will take you behind the
scenes of the grest St follow us on
social media and don't miss out on
players interviews and more content from
from the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit St
Louis chess club.org to claim your
membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the part of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chess
piece sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
familyfriendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q bouti stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy
welcome back to round six of the
sinkfield cup and yesterday it was a
rest day and it seems the players have
come in a fighting sure mood a lot of
the positions have been very explosive a
lot of them a little bit mysterious but
uh let's take a look at the results so
far and it was a draw there on the third
board between Richard report against
Maxim Vash lra and for yanchi he did
have a buy because of yan Kristoff
duda's withdrawal in round two but all
the other game remaining games we're
looking action and we're expecting three
decisive results let's start from the
top between uh Wesley so and leavon
these are two players who came into
today tied for first if you think of
them as being plus one well guess what
look at the position White's a pawn up
but it's even worse than that it's like
what white has the the the better minor
piece the better King position and he's
a pawn up three advantages Peter you
only need two is good right yes it is
math is excellent and we were discussing
the fact that even uh the end game uh
like that which cannot really be avoided
I'm pretty sure he's completely winning
but you can even get a better version
because in this position and you pretty
much get this position you can also Play
Bishop D5 included nice and make passer
one the one file further away from where
the game will actually be won because
white isn't planning to win on The Queen
side white is planning to use the the
outside passer to destruct the black
king and then go over to the other side
collect everything and queen one of
those two exactly Bishop D5 just very
very clean here exactly and then in the
other one uh we have uh Ali Raza uh
Fab's played a tremendous game yeah
let's just stop there there were
mistakes in it but they were very easily
understandable human mistakes which I
think most of us would make because uh
the things the engine was showing us
were frankly unbelievably beautiful but
also very very difficult I would say
borderline impossible to find so I think
he will be very very happy with today
despite the fact that it will be pointed
out to him by his screen right that
there were better moves on offer at some
at some at certain points uh and yeah
we've discussed this end game he chose
Bishop takes D4 there was nothing wrong
with this CH this Choice nothing wrong
with Rook F2 the threat actually is
Bishop C3 that is driving The Rook away
and queening the pawn if you go Knight
knight4 the simplest win is just once
again remind white that back rank issues
back back rank issues are no joke here
Rook F1 is a threat if if Knight D2 we
can play Rook F2 and now Knight D3 is
also coming in Bishop C3 is coming in
and in the final uh in the final game
there was a Intrigue where none should
have been available because in this
position uh choosing between Rook G8 and
the move Rook E4 that ler actually ended
up making he left himself a second yeah
two winning choices and I guess he
couldn't decide yeah but he did with one
but he did andjust in time but yeah we
were discussing on break imagine imagine
actually not getting there somehow
mechanically something something breaks
down but he is very very good
mechanically one thing I will say to ler
he is incredibly good at making moves
quickly and precisely and pressing the
clock button but Rook G8 yeah I thought
Rook G8 is just so clean because Rook G2
we obviously just trade and play E3 and
the game ends on the spot so Rook goes
somewhere here we give this check we
play Knight E5 we go Rook G2 check we
Queen once again we just Queen the pawns
right very very unclear what he could
have disliked about this to be honest
seems Seems like a it was ending the
game on the spot Rook E4 is still
completely winning but it's slower we
will have to play 9 D4 we will have to
play F3 and so on and so on right uh
coming into our show today we had all of
these marvelous graph
about you know like who does well and
performs well after her break break it
down for our audience what we had in
mind for them Fabiano he was in
impressive shape today and he is the
person who has the highest positive jump
in his tournament after the rest day
for they are showing an increase in
performance after the rest is terrible
well apparently so I mean the numbers
don't lie he says performs significantly
worse in later rounds and nepo and giri
do perform worse in later rounds which
is actually quite key because Anish giri
he needs a good tournament he needs to
also catch up in the rating race he was
very very close but we think lanir is
actually winning or has won uh the game
at at the moment because this last move
by linear uh Rook E4 is a winning move
again I'm just going to go to the
current position oh we do have a move by
uh I'm going to go to the current
position between leavon and Wesley
because Wesley has just played the move
uh C5 as you Wesley Wesley decided to go
for the purest for the simplest
conversion from here there were faster
options available once again and I'm not
going to use this as a criticism I'm
just going to show another plan here
which was winning very very comfortably
you can play something like G4 and then
actually we're intending to play
uh in a in a good spot we hang on uh I
was looking at some lines G4 after kn6
it goes King A7 and basically it says I
am now among other things threatening C5
B takes C5 B5 B6 B7 B8 gotcha so I have
to go back so you have to go Knight D4
we go H5 here and now you're in Suk
Swang right and let's say even after
Knight B3 we are now just instantly
winning by force with C4 C5 uh and
there's really like the engine starts
going King D6 here which is just just
give me the PA you you might as well
resign if if this is your best option
but instead of the all this and I kind
of endorse this decision Wesley says I
don't really particularly want to
calculate I know this is winning
eventually it will take longer I don't
care everything is completely under
control eventually the king gets over
here it will take a while but it will
get there because it have to walk sort
of slowly around all the way across but
as as I pointed out with the pawns on H5
and G2 and I think we do play H4 H5 at
some point we put the bishop on F3 they
cannot be attacked totally and
eventually the king will uh find a way
to the other side of the board and then
will decide the game so Wesley is saying
I'm in no hurry Joy this is absolutely
huge result for Wesley so because again
boldly stating the obvious it would
bring him to plus two in the tournament
uh which is a fantastic result when
nobody else is winning but far more
importantly it also gives him that
rating Edge that is so critical for the
January very rating list uh I mean you
almost start to get a little bit nervous
thinking about this you know you've got
a winning position and there's no way to
spoil it but wow uh a dream a dream
coming for Wesley actually the whole
game has been a dream because uh leavon
played the opening very quickly got
himself into trouble and by the way we
do have a result we have a result
Fabiana car did did win his game against
Ali Resa fuja so big news there very
very good game there from Fabiano truly
uh a very impressive win and by the way
the the Finish was also rather nice uh
after Bishop takes D4 Ali Raza tried to
move Knight C2 and we were saying Bishop
C3 that was The crucial move you just
remind white that he has a back rank
problem you can't play Rook takes E3
because of Rook F1 Fabby played night
take C3 with which is the the only real
attempt to do anything and Fabby chose
the most practical decision here he just
took on G5 and said yeah I'm I'm a piece
up I don't need to calculate anything
stronger it's probably the third best
move in the position but in terms of
forcing immediate resignation it was
perfectly good enough exactly uh
anything that forces resignation you
can't criticize saying it's I I I was
thinking that for ourselves Jo V once uh
Peter uh presented us
with our move after the move R I made
the decision to collectively resign on
our behalf Rook A5 but rook2 you
actually are going to still work a
little bit I think Rook F2 would would
be was probably the optimal but Rook
takes G5 was enough and Fabby uh climbs
to plus one and uh then of course
there's lanir yes talk about that uh
game we do have A2 A3 on the board yeah
finally uh I made a move uh A3 and yeah
the engine suggests that we can even
invest a Tempo on King C7 do we need
after Knight D4 white goes Rook E1 and
there is no immediate way to start
pushing because F3 suddenly we've we've
just made a draw or Rook takes D4 as
well yeah I mean black is still winning
you can go Knight C2 Rook E2 and even
take on A3 if you greedy reintroducing
the idea of a four3 but this is also why
I'm so mystified by Rook E4 because
calculations after Rook G really seemed
like they were simpler than this if we
go if we go back to this position like
I'm I'm threatening Rook G2 followed by
F3 there's really yeah like Rook C3 I
guess to stop it but after Rook G G2
check like if you go to F1 I will I will
E2 e just quins yeah it feels like there
was really nothing even to calculate I
I'm pretty sure he will still get there
it's not like this position he's played
Knight E5 by the way this is also
completely fine we will get to play F4
F3 and yes after some something like
this we're maybe not winning on the spot
there's no way to give a check to the
King on F2 for instance after we play
but you you can just play King C7 F
white can't really move or or F7 F6 here
just just to have everything protected
and eventually we will create one threat
somewhere and the position will fall
apart collapse but I'm still I'm still
unsure why why this was the choice it
shouldn't matter though right uh remind
everybody of the results so far I will
do Yesa and there you can see two games
have finished it was a draw between
Richard rapor against Maxim Vash lra but
for fua he lost in just doing a very
impressive Fabiano caruano was a great
complicated game full of twists and
turns but well Fabiano just emerging the
superior
and and for uh fuja what a painful
painful loss this was uh because before
round five this was their circumstance
yes uh before round five before fuja
lost to leevon aronian his live rating
was well this is after round five
apologies his rating sunk down to 27
55.7 and it's now sunk down even further
so now is Wesley is trailing sorry fuja
is trailing Wesley but in the meantime
let's go over to Anastasia who is there
in the studio with a
guest thank you Joey and indeed I'm with
Fabiano Carana congratulations Fab on
this Victory did you know actually that
you performed better after three days
and actually you had two of them so what
did you do during those days I didn't
know that so I think we should have a
new tournament format where every game
has a rest day after it good yes or two
or two I mean world championship have
this format but anyway we speak about it
later what what happened today was very
interesting and yeah ala decided to go
for H4 and it reminds the game against
Nakamura yeah that's true I I had these
memory these memories unpleasant
memories during the game that of course
uh my opponent plays Knight G5 when I
least expected and um okay he played a
line which was clear he wanted a big
fight I mean it's Cra Crazy this is H4
for example there's some line I think
like this
also uh some some Theory like this W
also also crazy stuff
I can see and so what I chose I think is
supposed to be like the correct way but
I couldn't remember like okay I thought
this is this is supposed to be the way
yeah this is like Theory I think um I
couldn't remember what to do so I just
made Moves which seemed logical like I
can play KN at4 any moment but of course
he he's in preparation like I'm not
expecting KN of four as an advantage for
black but all this sounds like you after
this game with Nakamura you didn't do
your preparation well you tried to
forget it or what no I I well I checked
it a lot of course this l but uh but of
course I forgot it I mean times you you
checked you yeah like but also let's say
you don't check A variation for even a
week two weeks I mean you the details
fade very quickly so I knew that this is
some sort of theory but I I couldn't
remember the details and okay I thought
what I did is very logical of course yes
of course there's also Rook B8 here I
thought he would castle and then Rook B4
as well uh and I was calculating this
yeah and I thought maybe he'll he'll
play D4 or something so that's why I
went for this because because it seemed
because okay he can't take with the
Knight I mean he well he can but Bishop
A6 seems very comfortable so Queen C4
Rook B this was my idea to play Rook B4
and then the queen has if it goes to C5
it gets trapped so Bishop D4 and Bishop
B6 so it goes back and then I get A5 and
I thought A4 because I thought after A4
actually there's one one move like Peter
was suggesting instead of A4 Knight F4
first yeah Queen F1 and then a using the
fact that Queen E3 is not possible and
then A4 because now G3 there are some
ideas with 9 D3 all the time yeah no I I
realized after that maybe I could have
included this first because I I didn't
realize A4 that G3 was kind of a a good
move MH and uh I mean it felt to me like
his Rook E1 was a very very strange move
because it doesn't do anything yeah it's
kind of like but maybe he wanted F3 so
yeah I mean but if you want F3 you can
maybe play immediately and then night of
four and um I I wasn't sure about this I
see of course yeah here A4 was probably
just a mistake but I was getting a
little bit lower on time just an option
let I I missed this or underes I mean I
saw it was like a move but I kind of
thought I should be well doing well and
I realized that he gets F3 okay so I
take take and yeah it wasn't sure I have
like million Queen moves I have to get
my queen somewhere to like A7 C7 where
it's out of the way of so I played Queen
C5 I thought F4 is the most natural move
but then I thought take take take I felt
like I'm equalizing this I don't know
computer says I'm worse no it's that
doesn't matter what says it changes a
little bit could be it could be this is
a safe choice for him I thought night
ab1 is like very ambitious but of course
Very double-edged
because his Knight no longer goes to C4
so my Rook on B4 stays alive well either
he takes it with the bishop which is of
course double- edged or it stays alive
on B4 did you see this final line after
take on e4 Rook takes Rook B takes here
and is completely crazy confus line and
queen C2 uh I actually didn't see this
this this was Perpetual I didn't see
this I probably would have played Rook
be before if I'd seen this Perpetual but
what did that's what was my question
like at this moment how did you estimate
the position I'm sure it's sharp crazy
but would you make a draw if you saw it
I was surprised by F4 I thought that
Bishop A3 immediately uhhuh and then I
was planning Queen A5 and I thought that
we can get this position for example
Knight D5 cd5 Bishop B4 Queen B4 and he
has this move d4 M otherwise I don't
know how he
like he do yeah yeah because if I get D4
it's also at some moments I'm very
dangerous and I thought I'd take Queen
D2 take Rook takes Bishop somewhere take
take I thought Bishop F2 and like Rook e
2 E3 I don't know I thought it was also
looks good for but I was very worried
about this position so I thought F4 is a
very strange move because he opens my
Bishop so I was just happy that my
Bishop gets opened and I didn't want to
think about other moves actually first I
thought H5 I was like that's why I spent
time here because I saw Knight D5 Rook
B3 oh and this is really beautiful
because Bishop C5 Bishop B2 mate and
okay he has this queen E3 but he's not
playing for an advantage for I can even
play Maybe Rook B1 and queen D5 and and
then there's also very beautiful line um
if he plays Bishop B4 Knight B4 Queen C4
I thought this was quite beautiful that
in this position uh Bishop G4 he's stuck
he can't take on e4 because Knight A2 so
he's just completely stuck and then I
saw Knight
E4 and I yeah I saw this queen D4 I just
couldn't figure this position out like
okay see the computer shows a draw but I
I thought here and then here and I my
queen and I thought maybe I have
compensation but I couldn't figure it
out so I decided yeah I decided to fall
back on my like secondary plan I thought
it's a better version I was surprised
that he took on B4 I thought okay still
he can play his position bishop4 Queen
like every move was critical but I was
wondering this moment when you played
this Rook F2 how far did you calculate
and did you see his idea Knight D5 is uh
sorry knight4 with all the threats yeah
I saw stuck or not somehow maybe some
technical
issue let uh is it following the game
yeah so here I already thought I'm
better uhhuh okay so yes yes he probably
playing only moves yes so let's say here
when you play this yeah when I did this
the only reason I was hesitating because
I saw that this is like safe mhm I was
just hesitating because I can also play
like Rook F2 immediately which is kind
of I wasn't sure Knight E4 or Rook C2
King B1 and like is it better for me
that I didn't take or not I couldn't
figure it out now I seeus 24 so I see
it's better it was working because yeah
I thought maybe I have like Bishop F5 or
something but I I just couldn't figure
it out low on time so I decided to play
it safe because I thought okay this is
more forcing take take here yeah and I
mean you took quickly Rook C2 this I
could see and then no but he didn't play
Knight C4 but I see that yeah I saw he
didn't play he I thought I didn't see
Knight E3 actually it's kind of
embarrassing was the only way is to hold
the position is 93 but also I'm like
borderline losing now so it's yes it's
actually crazy try to find those moves
Queen before before and then C5 huh I I
have to I mean like at least my hand is
forced after Knight C4 absolutely um but
yeah I didn't realize it so Knight E4 uh
yeah he play King B1 was not shocking
for you King B1 no no no all this of
course no I mean this is no I calculated
when I played Bishop D1 I saw the line
Until the End Game great but uh but
Knight D5 is winning like so many also
kn5 was winning here yes but I didn't
realize it's so winning like I
understood it's very dangerous for him
but that it's like minus 10 okay after
that it was completely winning for you
five congratulations once again how does
it feel to be finally on plus one I mean
in this tournament yeah well I'm still
probably not going to be in the lead
because I guess Wesley is winning this
end game but it's it's great of course I
didn't expect it I I understood that he
would go for a big fight but I didn't
expect that that I would get like
serious winning chances and win the game
um yeah it was kind of a crazy game yeah
it was crazy do feel great about it I
mean which move you let's say like the
most I think I like this H5 the most um
because I I don't know I like these kind
of positional moves in this like very
tense situation and you expect some
tactics and then you see some like
positional move like H5 quiet move yes
thank you so much fa the best of luck in
the next rounds and we are going back to
the studio because some games are
approaching the end thank you Anastasia
congratulations Fabby that was just
absolutely tremendous and with that
Victory Bobby moves up for the moment uh
a typ for first yes for the moment the
appropriate choice of words because it
does look like it's going to be a
decisive day Wesley so indeed having the
upper hand against leavon aronian and
well when it comes to the FED Fay
circuit leaderboard and the rating spot
well it looks like Anish giri will be
suffering his first loss of the
tournament which puts him not in good
shape for those two battles somebody was
mentioning lanir Dominguez in the
yeah yeah I think I think we start with
this one because I think Anish is
probably resigning pretty soon uh he
also didn't play the arm move Rook D5 he
tried keeping uh
uh the situation The Rook on D6 but now
after F3 Rook C1 L found this very nice
solution because the one problem black
had was this Rook on e4 was looking very
active but didn't really have moves but
now after Rook C4 if you take you very
simply lose to KN take C4 follow
following followed by 92 check so you
resign immediately so you have to play
Rook Rook E1 and then after Rook C3 once
this Rook just starts creating threats
currently even Knight D3 is a massive
threat because Rook takes E3 like if you
play A4 this just wins on the spot
because this is M and if you can't take
on E3 here you might as well uh pack it
in so I think Anish is just at the board
because he is going through the the
stages right uh he knows he knows what
this is there's absolutely after Rook C4
there's absolutely no doubt this cannot
be saved but
Ang you never you never really want to
not exhaust all the possibilities so
he's looking for a miracle and also sort
of saying goodbye to to the game which
was a very interesting very sharp very
hardfought game but at some point he
just lost control of it I feel and
linear never relinquished control uh
soer will be on plus one Anish
loses ala loses there will be a massive
shake up there should be only really
only one beneficiary uh the person who
will switch to next right but I suspect
I would need to check once all the games
I finished but ler might actually be in
second quite far away from Wesley if
Wesley wins but still ler might be very
close to second or just in second in
that R race yes wow and when we talk
about second by 10 points around 10
points I would say which is with three
with three to go is will be very very
difficult to make up they played each
other have they played a game between
each other Wesley because yeah if they
still have a game to play yes they
played in round five M yeah that was
that opposite color Bishop yeah of
course and that considering the news of
today the fact that ler had winning
chances there and didn't win might
actually be very very important because
had had had he won that game and
obviously this is not how any anything
Works had he won that game today's round
would look very very different
Everything Will Change but right uh if
we assume today's round stays exactly
the same he might he might be in first
remarkable uh how bad is it Wesley is
winning of course yeah Wesley played as
as mentioned Leon tried not to allow the
immediate King B5 King C4 by asking
whether you want to blunder a fork Fork
was not blundered right uh Knight went
to F4 and now we can just bring it over
to C4 and continue uh you know hinting
at at Tang's and the whole point looks
bad sorry the whole point there is we're
going to use the C Pawn as a decoy
Black's King is is forced to more or
less sit on the C7 square and the white
king is just going to March its way to
the king side and start picking up pawns
I thought I found one thing that we
needed to calculate which is after
Knight F4 let's say we play King B5 I
thought maybe we can play F5 now of
course you cannot trade because then you
leave yourself with the with the wrong
pawn and after bishop3 I thought maybe
we can play H5 and follow it up with
Knight G6 but we're just one tempo
short G3 n G6 Bishop takes H5 and we're
not in time to play F4 here or anything
yeah so so I'm wondering if I play King
C4 here have I blundered away a win
Machin says we're still winning but this
I think you would like not to not to
check right because two against one yes
you might still be winning but it
already feels like you're entering
slightly awkward territory right exactly
but yeah the engine says Don't Really
Care King comes over to to E5 we play C5
C6 the F Pawn Falls everything yeah yeah
and it does look like we are going to
see a result in the game between Anish
giri against lenia Dominguez and well
the line has followed exactly how Peter
has predicted and Kish playing Rook to
E8 attacking the Knight but well we're
expecting F6 F6 F Knight C4 might might
win quicker actually Knight C4 creates a
number of threats which Knight C4 Knight
D KN D2 and F2 yeah it feels like you
cannot really Parry threats like this
good point yeah this is this is very
very winning for in year and both of
them know of course KN to do two big
threat what an anguishing loss this
would be I mean as we know these top
professionals prize having the white
pieces they they have this let's draw
with black uh put um our opponent to the
test with white mindset to lose with
white hurts double it absolutely does
yeah is there some danger in the
position because I'm thinking okay
Knight C4 looked very convincing but say
you went F6 okay which is my alternative
which was the
alternative R takes Knight okay the king
the king is in the the beautiful part is
that if you King is within the
square we don't have to rush back with
our Rook but we can actually uh catch
the pawn with our King by the way the
Rook is just ideal placed this has to
stay on the first rank can't get active
no F6 but Knight C4 is also is
completely fine the returning to our
overriding topic of today the races for
the last two canate spots the saving
race for an Nish potentially is he is in
both races he's still very much in a
race for the F circuit right uh doing
badly here will hurt him it will
definitely hurt him because only the top
four finishes in this tournament gets
circuit points oh
but he's still
ahead it's not guaranteed he gets
overtaken uh so of course he would very
much like to nail it down by having a
good tournament and going down to minus
one with three to go is absolutely not
his ideal ideal scenario and this is
also why he played so sharply for a win
today he clearly understands that time
has has come for him to play to to to
play for points here draws are not
really getting him very much but he is
still not out of the race whereas with
ala 10 points behind uh West ly with
three to go two losses in a row which
must be a very very difficult thing to
to recover from when you have to pretty
much play every following game for a win
and also no other way to qualify he is
not in the circuit race as we understand
so Anish L has this kind of a backup of
maybe everybody else also does poorly
and nobody over takes him yeah is it
possible that Ali Resa can maybe fit in
another tournament just to gain those
rating points I have no idea what he
would play in to do uh to gain those
rating points uh which tournament there
are some there will be some tournaments
following this but I I suspect that the
lineups are closed now I'm I'm pretty
sure the London chess classic has
already announced the lineup there's
also a mystery event which we I don't
think we should we we have the the full
information about this but once again I
don't know if anes was looking to play
in that I don't know if he was invited
so and uh also just looking ahead for
Wesley he does face The Gauntlet though
of having black pieces against Fabiana
Carana tomorrow that's a challenge
that's a challenge then he faces off
with white pieces against
yashi and then finally he ends with a
buy so he only has two games remaining
oh he is the last he was the last person
to face off against and chist wow by the
way I want to talk about the Iron Man
lanir Dominguez no nobody has dented his
armor he's uh drawn or won all the games
he's ever played at the singfield cup
winning today with the black pieces
bringing himself themselves into the
candidates picture into the picture he's
done something I probably wouldn't have
done because these pawns are so
beautiful I would be very reluctant to
give them up even for a full
Rook wait wait seriously yeah he's he's
won a rook but he he gave up both of his
passers he's still completely winning
but yeah I why don't you play Knight C4
I don't know but because he he he played
uh the line that just wins The Rook on
E1 by force and the pawn H3 is also
falling he's not going to fail to to
convert this but of but from a purely
aesthetic point of view I would have
love to preserve the pawns on F3 and E3
for a bit longer they do look beautiful
don't they no he he will win this it's
not like he is thrown any any Equity
away he's he's still very very
comfortably converting this into a full
point mhm yeah Knight H3 check and a way
pardon me Knight F4 check and a way you
go and you can start taking all the
third like A3 is hanging H3 is hanging
the F5 Pawn is not going to really
threaten promotion at any point so this
is not difficult but no yeah Wesley
played G3 which is we're going to switch
our board from this camera from Anish
Gary to the wesle so game over to you
Peter yeah I've a bit curious to me that
he go to you know disturb disturb the
structure but I guess he wants them on
G4 and H5 and he's getting that very
quickly I think it's understandable
actually it's easier to control on G4
and H5 but I thought the the line that
you were saying just fix your Pawn on H5
put your Bishop on I think he was
touchable he was worried he might at
some point allow this F5 H5 construction
and maybe some some pawns will get
traded off and where whereas here you
know whichever way you go I play G4 next
very turn next move I play H5 I put the
bishop on F5 and eventually SWS will
come or it doesn't really even matter
okay uh so yeah feels like he's still
completely in control and it feels like
those are sort of
uh they are questions of taste mhm none
of this changes the result it's just
that I would have probably preferred to
keep it on G2 and he prefers to put it
on G4
but as long as
no tricks where were the dirty tricks
for leavon I'm not sure yesterday we saw
the day before the rest day we saw
leavon ronian play an unbelievable rook
and pwn end game against but to his
credit Ali Raza kept finding moves where
H2 H3 for example leavon had to find
this move are
there I can't find anything if we
continue going down this path let's say
black goes I don't know King D7 H5 King
C7 you know we right we put the bishop
on F5 Knight the four we go King G4 no
dirty tricks let's say King C6 yeah I
have a dirty trick for you King King E4
uh where here white yeah night takes
night takes porn although you haven't
you haven't even drawn this
amazingly it's not it's not getting it
you're not getting oh
that's your best cheap Nar yeah it's a
it's a fantastic fantastic chipo and
even this isn't drawing yeah so and the
point of course is that we want to play
King E4 and then after something like
Knight E2 we are by this point just
winning with Bishop G6 and then King F5
King takes F6 and then either collect H6
or play
G5 yeah wow so and this is maybe an
additional argument for putting them on
G4 and H5 because we're winning these
faster we can very very easily afford to
just give up on C5 as long as we know
that we're collecting the G and we're
we're collecting F6 and we're playing G4
G5 and we're promoting the AG Pawn uh
again for Wesley so and his many fans
they are just absolutely uh cheering him
on and he's just played the move G4 as
uh uh Wesley and in the game that we had
been watching between Anish Gary um well
uh there goes the
H3 pawn and with it it means that now
lanir has his own passer and uh well
that's just curtains I mean as soon as
black starts playing H3 Rook D3 check H3
you can just uh yeah I guess I guess you
go Rook D6 check and F6 but Rook D6
check that doesn't seem very hopeful
either uh King and F6 and I guess Rook
F3 yeah that's feels like the simplest
Rook F3 and then we F7 we play Knight E6
probably to make sure that the H Pawn
cannot be touched and then we go H3 H2
H1 Quin no behind the H for you it's
just not difficult it's not difficult no
no no nothing to be done nothing to be
done andish is also down to 2 minutes
which in a way is a blessing cuz he
can't really uh you know be said there
suffering for much longer exactly you
you really don't want to be staring in
this position it's a very dispiriting
idea I I understand this is pretty
hopeless for Anish but can he okay so he
gives a check to the king I was thinking
of going Rook H6 and then you know
trying desperately with the a pawn and
trying to trade off as many pawns as
possible yeah the problem
uh Wesley is uh confusing as all yeah
we'll we'll we'll finish watching this
because I'm pretty sure after Rook F
three the game just ends I I don't think
it gets played very far past the move
Rook F three yeah and then we can
discuss
Wesley and of course of course lenia
will keep an eye on the F6 porn you can
invoke the words of your favorite
author give me
your no I was going to say p porn is a
prisoner must under oh not n oh he's too
painful I'm sorry I'm sorry yes I had to
be done it had to be done huh no he he
had some brilliant witticisms you
absolutely giv nimzo credit for for for
those uh
Rook H3 to F3 is not a difficult move at
all but but lanir is one of those
players he he's very meticulous isn't he
he F3 plate he he takes his maximum
amount of time to play his moves F7 as
expected and now Knight
E6 and I think Anish
will throw in the towel after Knight E6
mhm because that stops the Rook from
coming the white Rook from coming to H6
attacks the pawn on
F7 opens the Avenue for white for for
for black to promote his H Pawn Yeah
nice technique there from lenia you know
once he once it converted into an in
game stage he was
absolutely perfect yeah no he's
meticulous thank you Peter for that but
yeah this is uh this has been quite a
tour to force by uh
lanir I'm not sure I would say he made a
mistake in this game we have a handshake
lenia Dominguez wins against really
disappointing o that is a blow that is
really but Peter help me out here did he
make a mistake in the I mean a a a
mistake I haven't seen one no today I
haven't seen one I've seen things which
I could maybe describe as
inaccuracies uh but I mean it's a it's a
very very difficult very unusual game
from a very off bit opening you will at
some point make moves which the engine
slightly disagrees with but nothing I
would describe as a mistake wow a very
very solid good game by performance by
in year okay you were about to tell us
uh that Wesley's performance yeah Wesley
is Wesley's confusing you a little bit
playing playing with his foot there a
little bit uh because after Knight F4 in
that position that we were discussing
like you can play H5 here and nothing
will ever get attacked instead of wish
he play Bishop F3 allowing Knight G6
threatening the pawn and the
fork he just played King D5 and said
yeah please please take my yeah your
knight is trapped very nice Motif yeah
we know and this is just completely
winning because we're threatening King
E6 if you go King D7 we go C6 check and
if you King E7 this this is now a queck
right cuz the Knight is trash yeah the
Knight Will Never participate and if you
go in the other direction the good thing
about the setup is that we never lose
touch of the with the pawn on C6 like
black can never give up material in such
a way that we have have to abandon the
pawn C6 and respon yeah Leon uh uh I
thought he played something after King
King G5 but yeah now he has just uh
refresh my board to catch up to the
players but the last move is King C4 to
D5 uh clock times no not really a factor
five minutes no Wesley just under five
minutes but this move King D5 intending
Bishop E4 as well as king E6 yeah I
guess if you if you want to try
something you give a check from
F4 yeah check on F4 okay and if if King
E4 we play Knight
D6 and Knight E6 yeah if King if King E4
you play Knight D6 and you pretend my
problem is I suspect pretty much every
single move in this
win including C6 including C6 which is
really gross because that was the one
move you're trying to stop yeah I mean
the simplest actually to return to D5 I
was wondering if if King F5 is winning
but it's always like it wants to return
to the better squares but the sort of
the quote unquote correct decision is to
go to D4 and not hurry uh at all and
after Knight E6 check you can uh you can
wait a bit you after night four there is
no immediate like five move win but
eventually you will put your pieces on
better squares in the
you know if you're feeling in an
impatient
mood isn't King E4 and then C6 just also
going to win um yes probably yeah yeah I
thought so as well but although I guess
you have to there's some chances right
for six after King six the engine starts
making moves which you might start
finding uncomfortable like Bishop D1 and
you have to be very certain that this is
winning but it is winning because it
wants to like after Knight G7 it wants
to put it on A4 and reestablish Ours
swangs from that side but now you're
allowing H5 you're allowing F5 you're
you're entering territory where engine
still very proudly says plus s it knows
you don't know so you're feeling a bit
iffy right about the whole the whole
thing so I'm expecting night of for
check and Wesley probably still needs to
uh put some finishing touches on this
but is this our remaining game uh this
is the our sole game and uh remind
everybody where we stand we've had a
very dramatic day it's a black day GES
finished and you can see Fabiano Carana
defeated Ali Resa fua in a superb game
it was a draw between Richard report and
Maxim Vash gra and a nishe giri lost to
Lena Dominguez who played chess marel
chess it's been also a significant day
when it comes to the live ratings we've
seen a lot of movement there for
instance Wesley so he wins he's
extending his lead
Al F who's dropping and Anish has also
dropped and now lenia has overtaken him
so wow everything to play for and it's
all happened right here at the sinkfield
cup in this round dramatic dramatic
stuff and also uh for the candidates
again Fabby we know has secured his
place Wesley might be securing his place
and to have uh lener potentially in
there we have Hikaru
in uh the mix uh that is going to be a
candidates tournament featuring
Americans and Indians yeah sounds it's
actually very exciting I imagine it' be
very fresh I mean to have players like
vidit yes in the tournament and then
also you if Magnus Carlson declines his
place then it will go to abasov exactly
that's going to be a first for him and
you have pragnan Anda maybe kukes maybe
Anish giri maybe Ali resua maybe Wesley
so can happen possibilities but this
game uh for Wesley I
mean and what it means for the singfield
cup what it means for the rating is just
uh it's a dream it's it's fantastic yeah
and once again we return to this uh this
topic that we uh discuss every now and
again uh this is how he wins games of
Chess right he he goes for something
which is supposedly somewhat unassuming
you know it's a it's a rookie van anti
Berlin it's of the sharpest lines of the
rookie Wan an Berlin but it's still a
rookie W an Berlin something he played
with black and held with black even he
he knows very well that he is not you
know going for large advantages but the
moment he's given a sniff the moment he
is given a sniff it's it's like you're
completely lost it feels like you just
can't give him chances and today is yet
another example of him getting a small
advantage and then just only increasing
it exploiting every mistake take you
still have to assume that this end game
once it's appeared on the board on move
23 was still drawn like I'm pretty sure
the with perfect play Black should hold
it from the beginning but once Leon
started going going wrong there's just
no coming back against him he is
unbelievably good at converting good
positions into full
points and uh yeah this is a mark of a
very very strong player of course that's
what we're seeing here King E4 uh King
E4 played I think you should play Knight
D6 to at least ask the question
and c I guess Wesley can also repeat
moves right of course you can go back to
and then play a little bit more
calmly yeah u c C6 is not going to be
such an easy decision to make in
particular because after King D6 there
is still this Dynamic where actually
Bishop D1 now is the only move that wins
the only move that wins yeah like if if
you go along this diagonal I suspect
this is a draw although it it's now once
again saying we're still winning but
it's it's becoming
like actually awkward yeah cuz I've
established this is very strange
actually because I would be thinking
that this is easily winning because I
would think okay the king comes and now
the bishop comes to D5 like let's take
away some squares okay you're not
threatening anything it is winning but
the issue is at some point you have to
go away from the King side and allow
either F5 or H5 and you have to be very
certain that you still after that I go
F5 and yeah the only thing that wins
here is G5 giving black a pass
it's not difficult to understand that
the bishop still controls any passer
that black chooses to create so it's not
it's not a massive problem but it's
definitely not the the easiest
conversion
right by the way we have King
E4 no wait a minute just a second I
think I'm seeing a knight on G6 Leon
Leon went back to G6 yeah he gave a
check and went back to G6 and Wesley
once again chose not to play H5 okay
and we are going to go straight to
Anastasia who is there in the studio by
the playing Hall with a with a
guest I have lard Dominguez here
congratulations what a game you beat
sish giri with black pieces but it all
started with this G3 move and you spent
like 10 minutes thinking what to play
tell us a little bit about that yeah I
wasn't expecting uh something like this
um so I thought good we'll have some
kind of original game um probably from
the start and that's more or less what
we got so I was in Creative creative
move more or less I play decided to play
this H5 but it was very interesting
position yeah I I wasn't sure how to
evaluate it I felt that black was doing
all right but uh yeah there were many
many uh possibilities and and it was
hard during the game to know what what
was going on but yeah once uh of course
I think the critical moment was when he
plays C3 and then a me this queen G3
from that moment on I felt that I was
very close to to victory yeah I mean so
where did you really actually start
liking what was the moment you start
like liking your position I felt that
after this um in this position yeah it
was more less Balan but I I didn't see
um I didn't think I was better to be
honest so I thought some move here
because maybe if he goes uh Queen B5 I
can play Queen B4 and take CB and this
end game it's probably fine I always
have this idea maybe to play Knight H7
Knight G5 eventually and and black has
some potential but I thought if white
goes some move like A3 instead of this
um it should be maybe around equal no
not here but instead of Queen
B5 I see uh but yeah I felt that uh that
I was doing fine maybe not more than
that but uh but yeah after C3 definitely
um I saw the I mean I saw this queen G3
and and queen C5 I mean it's not the
same exchange now you have this pones
right also um I was wondering if you
noticed that you made the move number 40
with one second on I realized yeah but
you were tickling our nerves you know we
were yeah no I I I thought I had time
but then I looked and I had one second
so really at the moment you looked at
you had one second so you had to make so
I didn't I mean it's not like I saw when
I had one second and I play fast so I
made the move thinking I have time and
when I looked I had
so thanks God it worked this way imagine
when wiing like this yeah it would have
been sad but yeah it's
uh um in that moment you feel a little
strange yeah because okay so so close to
but then it's uh it's just over and
believe believe me we also felt very
stret we couldn't believe our eyes
anyway so after that actually what you
were thinking about at this moment let's
say you were choosing between two moves
I guess yes four
um I thought Rook G8 was very direct
because he cannot play Rook G2 but then
Rook C2 and U yeah finally I thought I
don't have to yeah this is also winning
of course check and Knight D5 with the
idea Rook G2 yeah it's completely
winning and I felt that I should uh win
more or less with any move that doesn't
my position torture him yes why to win
quickly let's yeah should have played it
faster of course but yeah after Mo 40 I
I realized that why this B Bally lost
here there there's no no chance because
I have um such a good coordination that
um the boms are just simply too far
there's no way to to fight them here
yeah um finally victory in the
tournament after so many draws how does
it feel yeah it feels great yeah of
course to win to win a game at this
level and especially with black it's uh
it's a big deal so I'll I'll enjoy it
and and keep going did you feel anything
special today in in the playing h i mean
three games almost probably will finish
decisively was it like T tension special
tension today no I mean I was just
really into trying to focus on my game
but yeah at some point I did see that uh
that probably today uh there's a lot of
of blood somehow and um yeah but it's
good I mean it was it was about about
time to for it to happen yeah maybe
after 3 day what did you do yeah know I
was just uh relaxing
tried to trying to save energy and uh
not really preparing much and yeah I was
kind of right because G would have
killed in any case all your preparation
so it was good good decision yeah thank
you Lor so much and all the best of luck
in the next round thank you thank you
indeed our congratulations lanir as it
once again for the moment he's tied for
first he is tied for first alongside
weso and Fabiana Carana Ronan I yes Leon
aronian but everything hinges on the one
remaining game that is being played
right now where wle so has a winning
advantage against leavon aronian and
this game is important not only for the
standings it's also important for the
FED rating spot for the
2024 candidates and in my attempt to
understand exactly what will happen with
the results we already have and also
this game in progress I I
checked uh what happened in the past you
know rating period And if ala fails to
qualify by rating which now seems likely
right it will represent an absolutely
unbelievable Fall From Grace for him
because
he uh apparently is currently losing 26
points in the one rating list that is
about to about to come he had a bit of a
nightmare in Grand Swiss and he is
having a nightmare here and he was so
high red that it it it will cost him an
unbelievable amount of rating yeah he
was basically home home and dry yeah he
was so far ahead of Wesley when when
this month of calculation started that
he really needed to perform way way on
the par for what is part for him to to
for there to even be a question and we
are watching this now unfolding with him
uh seemingly letting go of what probably
seemed like an unsalable lead oh my
that's very very sad it is very sad but
is there any Saving Grace like if he
wins three games in a row oh no then he
could be right back in he only didn't
you tell me he only had Wesley only has
twoy Wesley only has he has three okay
Wesley will get a Buy in the very final
round yeah I mean ala and this is the
difficult part because he he lost a
painful game in round five a game in
which he he was fine and then he wasn't
and he was fine again then he wasn't and
then he lost this very very sharp
fighting game today after the rest day
and he anybody will feel very down after
this and yet he will have to play
sharply for a win including the games
with the black pieces for the remaining
three there's no time for him to like he
can't really take a game to catch his
breath you know to stop the bleeding so
to speak he absolutely need to come back
tomorrow playing Black against a very
very strong player whoever he plays
tomorrow is going to be a very very
strong player yeah well let me and play
sharply for a win with the black pieces
so he will be playing against tomorrow
in round seven a tall tall challenge but
really every single one he does play
dudo so he will be getting a
buy only two games so he only has two
games you so Wesley has two and lza has
two so it feels
like yeah and
uh we're entering the territory where
Wesley needs to maybe lose
too he doesn't lose very many in
particular when draws are just perfectly
good enough for him exactly uh how
steady are Wesley's nerves because he's
so close now to perhaps securing the
feed days he's always impressed me uh I
I think of him as one of the best
players nursing a lead whenever I see
Wesley in the lead in the tournament he
really is extraordinarily good at
maintaining uh that lead um as we're uh
just seeing some uh b-roll of w
uh you you you mentioned that he's
playing with his food a bit here in his
game against Leon yeah it it feels like
he is very very unwilling to play H4
H5 and then just switch to the winning
plan here isn't he he seems to be trying
to win without the king's side right he
is trying to shift away the The King The
King from C7 get his own King to B7
which would of course instantly win the
game but black this is the one thing
that black is reasonably well equipped
to fight against right what you should
be doing at some point is like even here
let's say you play H5 you wait for
Knight E7 so that you don't blunder the
bishop you play C6 right and then you go
like in this position you find a pass
like here I'm I'm a bit worried actually
that I BL that you might have and this
might become might become less than
obvious yeah right so this I think
explains why none of this has been
played yet and by the way Wesley's down
to three and a half minutes and he's not
going to get any more
yeah that's impractical but I was going
to say in defense of Wesley I mean
there's like a a grind Master rule in
Jaz in the end games that you delay
pushing pawns for as long as possible so
you try every other means possible and
he he's delayed it to the at the last
minute you play H5 and by then you tired
out your
opponent tired maybe you tired out
yourself too right at this point I was
exhausted the grind Masters have
excellent stamina they come out in so
what are we doing Peter after H5 Knight
to E7 we're going to be using our C Pawn
as a decoy but it'sa
uh what's the road to uh success yeah
I'm slightly stuck yeah 97 will played
yeah are we going to see King C4
yeah and then we'll see King D7
or do you want to play the move C6 well
I played the move C6 on my screen and
then after Knight C8 King C5 knight7 I
was kind of Unsure how to proceed
because if we if we drop the bishop back
we're really entering very very e
territory drop the bishop back well I
mean the pawn we can go back to B5 but
we've been there maybe we just go King
D4 here but that also feels King D4 yeah
e because after King D6 black has
established you know the kind of a setup
you you might find it difficult to break
through right right no this is and this
is why why there is still a question
because you it seems like you've
positioned everything absolutely
correctly but okay we have H5 97 on the
board uh um Wesley to play and there's
something about the move C6 that I'm not
eager to do yeah I mean but I didn't
understand why not case is C6 I I like
that move because I like fishing Pawns
then Knight C8 Knight C8 and King goes
to C5 and then Knight back to E7 yeah
and here I was just thinking just move
the bishop we're allowing a five yeah
but then you got G5 I'm not sure this is
winning if we move our Bishop doesn't
matter we we'll we'll choose later whe
whether this is 5 G5 I
take you go you go H6 I go G4 you go H7
I go n G6 and I want to play F4 F3 and
disrupt everything and yes maybe it's
winning but you you have three
minutes and yeah King D4 honestly this
looks like this is a draw now yeah okay
but one can be a bit more precise with
the bishop yeah you can choose a
different Square I'm not sure which one
D5 what H sorry hang on F3 I want to go
Bishop F F3 King G King F5 okay King F5
yeah but you you have you have to
calculate
F2 F you have have to calculate of
[Music]
two yeah our producers are telling us
that these positions are wi if this
positions are winning this is very very
straightforward of course if you can
allow F5 and play G5 and this is still
winning F4 we do have to move Bishop to
E4 demonstrating why the Bishops are so
strong yeah and if G3 I guess the king
comes over and if F3 King E3 and the
pawns will eventually just fall yeah
yeah this makes sense yeah
so it is
winning it just feels somehow less gasp
so the idea is again uh from the current
position we've just seen the move C6 we
are expecting Knight E7 then the idea is
yeah King C5 King D no wait sorry that
that I'm going to have to refresh my
board I apologize uh just to H get to
this position c69
E7
we are expecting King C5 right no yeah
King C5 that's what I wanted it is C6 so
I have to go here Knight C8 KN C8 King
C5 Knight E7 Knight E7 and here I you
suggested Bishop H1 but there also
possible to go Bishop D5 and gain some
time okay Bishop D5 with the same idea
that you're meeting F5 with G5 and we
are I also was wondering whether I could
go Bishop F7 as well but I'm no no no
maybe I don't yeah this is just uh the
most straightforward line I could find
we put the Knight on G6 you have yeah
then the king just comes over and
collects everything slowly I guess King
D4 anytime you play F4 I meet that with
Bishop I think that probably is the
conclusion yeah yes and after G3 I come
back with the King after G3 they no
longer run so we can take as long as we
want to just pick them up one by one and
the important thing is there I guess is
Even If eventually we the resulting
Position will force us to abandon the
pawn on C6 very often even that will be
lost because the KN in the corner so
horrible yes uh the the power of the
bishop over the night Bishop can dance
at two weddings off there on the same
same diagonal uh there was a a book
series probably you were very familiar
with it uh I loved it when it appeared
in the English Yuri arbox series of of
endgames book books yes that they became
kind of a Bible uh here and uh for me in
America and I I really liked the
examples he used of Bishops dominating
Knights and vice versa Knights I think
for their time they were absolutely
absolutely groundbreaking I'm sure the
the engine has fine-tuned many of the
examples but it's still I think it still
stands the test of time because uh the
understanding of the end games you're
still going to struggle to memorize
everything of course so in a way an
endgame book which explains the concepts
concisely right is still unbelievably
valuable because this is what you want
you don't want to be memorizing specific
lines you want to Yes uh read the book
and leave with the understanding of what
you're aiming for which which which ones
you like which ones you don't like which
ones you're aiming for which ones you
trying to avoid when you let's say when
you're playing for in vice versa when
you're trying to draw something and I
think it still does a good job of that
exactly so this is our position three
minutes on the clock for Wesley nine for
leavon they've made the first time
control there is no second time control
so the players will be forced to play on
their 302 increments throughout and here
we've been looking at a position where
at a certain moment black plays for F5
Leon has no Leon needs to move the
Knight to one of the two squares
available to it and then put it back on
on E7 and I know I know how we winning
this maybe cleaner no no please I
thought I can maybe go King D4 first
wait for you to play no I mean sorry
Knight knight8 I don't have a choice at
all yeah I was looking for a triangle to
to do with the King like King C4 Knight
E7 King C5 mhm the issue is nobody will
play Knight D7 there you will play
something
smarter and what happens if uh say you
do go King C5 and you do wait with the
bishop and black doesn't go F5 like but
then you have to give me either the D5
or the D6 square and the game ends
you're absolutely obliged to play five
because everything else loses very very
straightforwardly after I just thought
maybe you could pass with the Knight
yeah but King D5 King D5 King E6 the
game just yeah once it lands on E6
there's really it is curtain yeah
there's really not very much you can do
you absolutely have to play F5 and in
response I suspect you absolutely have
to play G5 so Wesley will have to
calculate returning us back to
my vet's rule of winning chess games
against against a good defense you will
at some point be absolutely forced to
calulate to calculate one variation to
the
end I remember uh there was aghani barev
who barv who became the third highest
rated player in the world at a time and
he annotated a game for new in chest
magazine where he he called it like you
know a game of great Beauty he didn't
and have to analyze calculate any single
variation everything was just a very
smooth path to vict that's always the
dream perfectly play are unicorns though
yes exactly unicorn yeah you don't see
many of them that's for
sure but it was very nice
interesting I was I was trying to figure
out what Leon is even debating instead
of the Knight moves and you can play
King D6 in the Cent position no way
really you can play King you can play
King D6 King B6 King
E5 wow
wow I would have thought that was just
abandoning ship yeah exactly but no
because well if the bishop stays on the
H1 a diagonal black wants to go Knight
tak6 and the5 and that actually might be
a draw so the bishop has to go to a
different Square such as F5 and then we
go back to D6 and you can't play
C7 so we have to switch to a different
mode of winning this position you can go
Bishop to D7 Peter yeah and eventually
you go around you you go around the back
you go King C King D yeah this is still
winning I'm not saying this saves the
game but I was just I I could surprised
that it was I couldn't figure out why he
was thinking I thought King D6 just
loses on the spot to King B6 on the C
pawn queen but it doesn't Queen I mean
eventually maybe it does but it takes it
takes he does go Knight C8 and uh I was
going to say Wesley didn't play King B4
King C4 anything kg whatsoever he
immediately played King C5 Knight E7 and
this is where we're expecting Bishop G2
Andor Bishop H1 not F3 though I suspect
F3 might not be fast enough right cuz
you give a for G5 G4 G3 right so but D5
G G2 H1 well D5 is probably okay he
wants he wants an additional minute on
the clock after B5 he needs to be very
sure he's not blundering a three-fold
but I think he is pretty sure he's not
blundering a three okay so fine we we we
we toss in an extra minute on his clock
as if that's going to be all important
yeah this is still fine L one will now
in in desperation double check his score
hoping against hope that it is a
third time he's playing Knight D7 but
it's only the second so it's Bishop G2
or Bishop H1 the problem with Bishop D5
is it takes the the square for your king
you're yeah sure we want to do that I
think it has to go back yeah but uh even
of three wins we being told which is
kind of surprising to me but yeah
because that was a one square I wouldn't
want to put it intuitively I want to
meet after Bishop G2 the move F5 with a
move G5 if I put my Bishop on G3 oh
pardon me if I put my Bishop on F3 I'm
kind of encouraging my Bishop were here
I don't think I don't think this is a
very human thing to do because why give
black an extra Tempo but Bishop G2 is
curtains yeah Bishop G2 seems to be of
an Endor Hy H1 as we've established
right so it's a little bit confounding
Wesley seeing some ghost is it
nervousness what's going on well
he's I'm guessing quadruple checking by
this point it's not really double I'm
pretty sure he's gone through this in
his mind already many a time and doesn't
want to be at the board he's gone like I
don't want to see Bishop G2 I don't want
to see Bishop H1 in in games is all
about that principle of hurrying but not
rushing hurrying so I
yeah King D4 King D4 completely throws
it away if you play King D4 here after
King D6 it's a draw okay wow so that's
the one thing you cannot do but King D4
is such a counterintuitive move why you
can't give black the D6 Square it just
doesn't make any sense make any sense no
but uh withdrawing the bishop and just
saying to to Black
I I'd love you I mean right here with
the The Bishop's on its most perfect
square the king's on its most you would
love to pass and say black please make a
move you'd have to move the Knight and
then the king would just instantly go to
D5 and E6 and Bishop E4 in that position
is also the only winning move but we've
sort of established that the position
which we get after f55 yeah but Bishop
G2 F5 G5 they take we go H6 H7 they go
G4 King D5
F4 and in that position nothing wins but
Bish B4 but it's kind of unsurprising
cuz we want to stop a 4
F3 cutting our Bishop off from
everything so you be the Knight yeah
yeah and then and then the king cly
collects everything
exactly
Majesty
wow so here we are all a tither waiting
for the moves Bishop G2 or Bishop H1 and
not the move King D4 that would blow it
that would blow it and okay he drops his
Bishop to G2 and there we have it a
little nervousness as well where his
clock ticking down two one and a half
minutes there he's making so now Wesley
under two minutes on the clock I'm
pretty sure Leon knows that facial
expression says yes I will now recheck
again because what else can I do but
yeah he knows this wins yeah he's been
calculating nothing else for the past 10
minutes feels and for sure it's just for
him said that he has absolutely no
choice there was no way he could avoid
it
right
yeah and in the end though the result
has never really being in doubt not for
the last 253 moves I mean somehow when
they entered this ending we thought it
was going to be easy draw that leavon
had it this is move this is move 73 oh
excuse me it's really yeah they repeated
quite quite a bit yeah for theast yeah
for the past 40 moves it felt like it's
only a question of when not not what
exactly
um yeah very clean game by by what just
happened I mean the bubble burst we were
having this draw virus of two draws out
of the 20 games played we were at 10%
and suddenly Snap Crackle
Pop three out of four games decisive Joy
the the stakes have risen so much that
people feel like they're unable to just
be satisfied with the draw when we have
Anish he needs to have a top four
placing if he wants to stay at top of
this the feed day circuit and we also
have uh Wesley and Ali Resa as in
particular who wanted to secure the
freeay rating spot to the candidates
and everyone came in a fighting mood
reinvigorated by the rest day and as you
saw we saw a very complex battles where
one side just lost control I mean this
is perhaps the only technical game that
we saw that was a gift for
Wesley uh impressive uh play also by
Wesley I mean you know okay leavon might
have you know presented him but uh he
never let it uh get away from him either
the win uh that is to say um anisha's
approach would have been loued had he
won it was brilliant play one G3 and let
lanir uh choose
his problem a very complicated position
I mean you you guys at one stage thought
that the upper hand had shifted to a
niche and then it got very complicated
the players were in time trouble and
then one wrong move and that's it the
Leno was just effective with his own
Counterattack great stuff just great
stuff Bishop G2 Peter
and what uh well uh we're going to pause
our analysis here for a moment I think
we've exhausted ourselves tell us about
uh the peak for tomorrow what's going on
Jo and there you can see it Fabiana
Caron will have the white pieces SC and
there will be no mvl Duda oops come back
with that graphic we were just getting
into it we bring bring that back here we
go D and Leon aronian faces off against
Anish giri and Maxim vasra will have a
buy as Yan Kristof Duda did withdraw
after the second round for nepi he will
have the white pieces against Ali Resa
fua but for lenia Dominguez who now is
in the fiday rting spot for the 2024
candidates he will have the white pieces
against Richard report so for the rating
spot and for us to have a particularly
exciting last couple of days we want
Fabby to beat Wesley and for ler to win
again right yeah and then they will be
kind of level is they'll be close I
think I think there will be a 10 points
difference now so if one wins and one
loses they that brings them very very
close together and then there will be
each will have one final game to play we
assume yeah there's still exciting
possibilities ahead of us in terms of uh
all of that but
once again to restate the obvious Wesley
doesn't lose very many games of Chess no
no he does not and again um Peter I'm
looking at this position I I understand
leanas but there's nothing beside F5
there's just absolutely nothing any
Knight moves invite King D5 E6 if you
move the Knight anywhere for example
Knight C5 King D5 followed by King E6
and the King simply collects his Pawn
you move your king
it's even well it's even worse that just
allows the king to come uh screeching
right in King
D6 everything is is is on tap for white
which leaves us this one and then
there's one very important move right
here that we throw in Bishop E4 hitting
the Knight and the bishop keeps these
two pawns under control and just to show
show this relation to the end after
Knight h8 the simplest is just to go
after that Knight we go King E5 F3 Y and
here we demonstrate that we understand
that those pawns are very easy to
control we go King F6 F2 Bishop
G2 and then when and we go King G7 takes
h8 King G7 H7 h8 Quinn exactly and all
of that is entirely Unstoppable exactly
and uh if our King were anywhere close
to h8 we'd be in with a
shout not even then not even then
because we can go Bishop D5 oh yeah
controlling both G2 and the yeah let's
let's demonstrate what we're talking
about for King D6 let the black king
even get to f8 and still yeah like this
yeah
exactly even this isn't a draw because
we go Bishop C4 G3 Bishop D5
yeah and look at him go they're racing
towards that our variation and and the
King on f8 has to release the King on G7
and it's a win so the players are
getting to the variation that we've been
talking about and for Wow for Wesley
this is just absolutely a dream come
true
candidates uh he's that close to it now
yeah can almost feel it uh help me out
here uh for Wesley obviously made the
candidates before but how many times
will that's people I think twice right
he played Moscow and he played Berlin
yes and Moscow was sort of mediocre
Berlin was an unmitigated disaster right
and he hasn't qualified since as far as
I can remember and he's just played uh
H7 yeah if you play F4 white will play
Bishop F3 and you will not even get the
pawns past those two squares so you kind
of have to play G4 and then as we keep
on mentioning uh King D5 F4 you have to
find Bish B4 but you will find Bish B4
because no other move makes really any
sense whatsoever yeah F3 was well that's
pretty lame yeah that's not
great a certain moment Bishop H5 might
be yeah no not
good no and uh well G4 played on the
board yeah and the players both on their
last
minutes and for Wesley it's just
being accurate exactly that's all he all
he has I wonder I want that the check of
the move King D4 here throws away the
win it it's it doesn't but it takes much
longer if you play King D4 I can but
once again why would you why would you
give never there's just no reason
whatsoever to do that exactly in fact
you do want to make a Bel line towards
that Knight and uh promote your Pawn
Yeah King D5 on the board F4 really the
only conceivable move here and now the
only move to win is Bishop E4 but
unfortunately that move really suggests
itself you get your Bishop away from F4
F3 which would shut down your bishop and
maybe cause a real
problem okay and uh when it comes to
Wesley and playing the candidates he's
only played in 2018 in Berlin in Berlin
so there was a yeah a fail I played
Moscow and I still failed I still failed
to appreciate that he wasn't
there
but but I can I can sort of explain
myself there because by 2016 he was so
strong that like my mental picture of
him playing it was very
much kind of natural for me to think he
played canid talking about natural
Bishop E4 played on the board oh or is
that me I think that's me I apologize I
think that's me yes there is a natural
though well thank you very much the
statement
stands uh on that note by the way I
don't know if you've ever played those
games uh with the other Grand Masters by
the way we have G3 Bo surprising
because now white cannot go King E6
because Knight f8 check of course but
some a move like Bishop F3 and black is
just immediately in in complete sang you
can't really even do anything I'm not
quite sure where he's intending to look
for chances once he's played that G3
perhaps he's just heading his BS on a
cheap
trick
trying um I wanted to say have you ever
gotten into those memory contests with
uh players like uh who who won you know
New York
1924 you know who were the players and
the inter zonals you know Bobby fisers
who was the 20 victories of Bobby fiser
and things those specific things no I
I've seen I've seen people do sort of uh
there's their famous famous videos of
let's say Magnus recognizing chess
positions right exactly that kind and
that that is an incredibly spectacular
video by the way for anyone who hasn't
seen it yeah Magnus just not only uh you
know naming the players and the move and
how the game concluded but also very
often naming correctly the plays the
year in the round right of the game
which crazy it is quite stunning yeah
yeah yeah I tried it myself like I I I
can do maybe
30% down to his last seconds he'll play
a four no and no he extends his hand in
resignation and Wesley so wins so Wesley
now is the sole tournament leader one
point ahead of the
rest is it just me or is it Wesley does
Better In classical chess than rapid and
Blitz like the longer the time control
the better his results well here yes OB
recency bias but yeah I'm not sure I've
it feels to me that when he's playing
well he's playing well in anything story
yeah so when when it's his tournament he
can he can be extremely strong in both
formats but recently maybe maybe a
little bit so yeah wow uh huge just
simply a huge victory for Westy I mean
significant day of Chess my goodness you
know having an impact on this tournament
but also on the live ratings as Wesley
notches another five rating points yeah
they're discussing this slim we're
discussing and Ali Raza losing five
rating
points and unof unofficially
unofficially uh but we think uh also
lanir has passed Ali Resa now thanks to
his victory today that is dis the
standing is then Wesley sort of then
Clear Blue Sky then ler then ala and
then an I think
Anish also l so is in clear second now
right somewhat
clear wow and then Al then Anish mhm yes
and the 10 points we were talking about
is in place so he needs to lose and ler
needs to win for them too get together
in the middle uh as we as we wait uh for
a interview coming up uh Peter you said
something to me that just kind of of
blew me away which was like you start
November Ali raaza and you're completely
in in the driver C and then you lose did
you say 26 rating points I I checked
that there's obviously I for people
interested in these things 27 2700
chess.com keeps very very upto date
track of all of these things and I think
the minus 27 point something included
today's loss to uh to fabes that's
that's an unbelievable amount of points
to lose and one list what did he do in
the aisle of man you were the
commentator commentator 50 percentage no
huh 50 perish I think yeah he didn't do
so well he had a few mishaps here and
there wow well here
are Let's see we Wesley
Wesley you in
our correctly predict what's wrong with
so would be at the top of the table
after six rounds but he is at least
Anastasia has some somebody who's in
plus well is
there and I have someone who's on minus
one well I spoke with Anastasia she said
to me look uh Fab's been having such a
fantastic year F Fabby Fabby Fabby she's
not uh she's not giving that up I would
have said Magnus but he
wasn't in the tournament I'm going to go
with Magnus on this one no no uh well
again our we tip of the Hat uh to Wesley
and his fans as is just fabulous stuff
he's just absolutely wonderful play by
Wesley there precise until the very end
I just like the technique you know it
took a long time but it was always Aur
yeah the whole patience and pushing the
pawns gaining a minute on the clock
although that might have been excessive
by some standards but in any case he
never let it go no he was seemed like he
was completely in control throughout and
yeah very very nice conversion by him uh
that as we keep on repeating the rating
the rating race appears to be now
heavily skewed in his favor but the
singfield cup is still wide open he's
only half a point ahead I mean plus one
ahead of Fabby and lineer with three
rounds to go Fabby gaining steam is very
dangerous this year so I think they play
each other tomorrow as well I think that
was was on our
screen probably finally having the white
pieces after three blacks in a Rob yeah
so still lots to watch for in terms of
the singfield cup specifically because
with Fabby going to plus one he's not
going to finish dead last uh let's just
take a look at those who joining as late
the standings after six rounds of play
Joy there you can see Wesley so having
played six games has four points and
then we see Fabiano kowana also Len
Dominguez also on plus one and then we
have Maxi r fromi
uh players who actually have just drawn
their games and then the pairings uh
coming up for tomorrow and that was what
we were talking about the Fabby Wesley
so the guy who's is it
ever and also it would be very nice to
see that now that Wesley so is in the
lead in the tournament and also in the
ratings race will he be able to maintain
his composure as he plays with the black
pieces against Fabiano Marana a man who
just showed today he was in impressive
shape uh mvl taking the buy but for
laner by the way he going to have uh
White in round seven and I believe white
also in round eight uh fabulous stuff
coming up Fabby versus Wesley so that
could really be for all the marbles that
helped me out on this Anish Gary
situation Anish Gary needed to be in the
top half of the singfield cup to assure
his circuit his speed a circuit get some
points explain that a little bit more
for I think the formula itself I
wouldn't be able to tell you how many
points you get but if you finish well in
a tournament only a certain cut off from
the top earns points in any given
tournament okay there would be quite a
lot of points on offer here because of
how strong it is but you needed to
finish in a top four to gain anything
okay and it seems likely now that he I
mean not assured but likely that he
won't because if it's minus one because
of his current St of position of minus
one and then people have a better chance
of catching him up there is a very
hungry pack of people who are still
playing events in particular GES I think
will play to London chest classic is
starting really really soon and there
might be another event on the on the
horizon after that so and and he will be
in such an uncomfortable spot because
there's nothing you can do you just
watch right you watch and see if gukesh
does extremely well and perhaps
overtakes your score so yeah you have to
you have to feel for him uh he was in
the running for for the rating spot he
was definitely in the running for the F
of circuit if he ends up whing on both
it's going to hurt and also Anish was in
the aisle of man is that right too that
he was in their swinging in that yeah he
good and here are the live Grand chest T
standings if the tournament was to end
in the current yeah situation it would
be Fabiano Carana walking away as grand
chestor champion and in second place
would be Wesley so third place Maxine
bashra those three players we get an
automatic invite into the grand chestor
2024 yeah for those of you wondering
dingler uh and this is the actual coming
into the event yeah uh current standings
yeah ding Lin was not playing in our uh
Grand chestor he stepped out yes he did
at the top of the table Fabiano Carano
with what looks like an unassailable
lead there 33 Grand chest tour points
over Maxim bashra who just has
22 and well we said it that Fabiano
Carana was virtually assured the title
unless he had some kind of collapse and
of course as we saw today there is no
collapse no collapse in this one uh by
the way uh I did see a report that
dingler in is going to be playing in the
T he finally returning
I'm so happy uh to report that great
news and looking for him we all want him
it will be very interesting to watch how
he does in vik after such a protracted
break from from active chess
exactly and again we're just waiting for
Wesley to join Anastasia in studio I can
very well imagine there in the Central
West End he's probably uh being tackled
by uh all you know autograph hounds and
selfies and stuff like that uh you
almost need a security escort yeah Wes
what is it that he has to do next
obviously you know he has to secure some
drawers to maintain his standing at the
top but that's easier said than done
when you're
facing Fabiano Carana
true yeah with the black pieces against
Fabby a huge game tomorrow but it's
beyond that I mean again
I'm thinking about Wesley has been I
believe number three highest number
three in the world but I mean his
Ambitions he needs to tune it up he he
he every time we have an interview with
Wesley he says oh Fabby is such a great
player Oh Faby is such a great player
come on Wesley tune it up we will find
out because Wesley is with
Anastasia yes exactly the hero of the
day Wesley you just won the game against
leevon I mean congratulations now plus
two in the tournament how does it feel
uh it feels amazing well I mean today
there there were three Heroes yeah it
seems yes you're right I mean three
decis of games but you still their
leader it seems like a very different uh
tournament today but I mean I'm very
pleased I mean I probably win plus two
in super tournament maybe once every two
years so I got I got to enjoy the moment
yes you do and actually what happened is
that quickly you went for this ending
and did you speak with Leon after the
game what did he tell you like he
thought that it's like Jo or well only
only briefly we had the but first the
opening yes I mean I decided to play
this line although white black of many
ways to equalize I thought he'd play
D6 but I think uh I think Don Chen was
it no who's that German guy I think
hosen bet beat Navara in the is of man
tournament with some D6 and here G5 is
the best but yeah he beat David Navara
where David had to play like 15 only
Moves In order to equalize uh it was in
this game but so I decided to try it
although black has many ways to equalize
it's hard to find ideas in the Berlin
but he played this line I played this
against lenier two times last year in uh
speed speed chess in Grand Chester
actually MH I play Bishop C5 then take
Rook d8 take
and then uh black has to suffer a little
bit to make a draw but it's pretty it's
very drowish like I I don't expect to
win with white pieces okay that's JY but
I was surprised when played King
F2 and here I only looked at this but
then played Rook C7 in fact if you look
at database I
think sabba balog played this against me
11 years ago with black pieces so it
happened already un I I think if you
check the database I think bog played
Rook C7 too unless I'm totally crazy no
I'm pretty sure this
was but uh I didn't remember until he
played Rook C7 so takes I guess Queen E5
is pretty force and here
Leon I think Saba played something like
this yeah unless I'm
really unless I'm really mixing it up
like T how did this game finish well
draw of course was draw yes uhhm yeah I
think black puts the Knight here and
then
plays F6 like if King King and then F6
or Bishop here mhm and then basically
black plays F6 next move like let's say
some random maybe C4 is the move here
but let's say white plays like this then
now it's a fortress because ah so you
cannot really go through yeah I think
that's what Black's hoping for like
there's no way in yeah I mean like go
here then here here here here so I think
we made the draw with a structure like
this I'm pretty sure he played Rook C7
so what did Leon do wrong I mean what
happened in this moment like what what
do you think was his crucial mistake in
this game well he was very critical
Knight D5 I think he just got to he just
relaxed for a moment like he played
Knight D5 quite quickly like I'm sure he
knows the
Fortress but he played Knight D5 quickly
and then very surprised because after
C4 I guess the point is that
the Knight on E3 is running out of
squares like let's say G3 or G4 oh you
have this move okay yes and the Knight
it's it's scary to play like this
because Knight cannot Retreat and then
so he went here I guess it's still a
draw but I didn't like when he played C5
yes so this C5 I think was the let's say
big mistake yes here so after C5 like
what did you feel like now it's a moment
that I'm trying to play for victory was
it something like that well I was trying
play for victory since move one yeah
like I'm not worse yeah no that's true
but I mean when you really feel that
position you have to push now and I I
mean I'm pushing but I'm very surprised
when because he played C5 quite quickly
okay if the knight's on D6 then it's a
fortress but his Knight is running out
of squares you Bishop yeah and here's a
very bad position I guess because black
will always be in suwang mhm like let's
say if here I don't know h four yeah
yeah yeah I mean all the time Peter also
showed so many positions you weren you
you were about to win every time let's
say whatever black is doing just you
showed really great technique in this
game yes no
actually well thank you but again you
know all my all wins are because of
Jesus Christ of course no and actually I
I messed it up like I thought okay I was
playing very beautifully here like here
here here like I thought I was going to
win for sure at this point because the
king INF filtrates like I even had the
uh choice of way to win like I think A4
is also winning yeah like something like
this m okay but maybe the way I played
this better bum bum bum like I thought I
was winning very easily here but somehow
leevon kept finding resources so a big
you know Leon he's very tricky it's it's
not that easyest win even winning
position against him yeah I thought I
was going to win very easily here but
big Kos to liveon for defending so well
I mean okay maybe like like it seems
like I was going to win easily here but
okay maybe C5 is not the best but I was
very critical of playing G3 here like I
think uh because in the game black uh I
think the pawn is better on G2 than on
G3 I think I should just play Bishop F3
and then like H5 M that was this option
as well yeah
and then yeah with the pawn on G2 it's
very easily winning but I was very
stupid yeah like I played G3 this was a
very bad move I think because with the
pawn on G2 everything's defended mhm I
mean well with the pawn on
G4 here
like um black always has uh this
something something like this it
takes F5 yes yes this is and then the
like actually I was wondering what Leon
was playing for like of course from afar
I was going to play Bishop F3 followed
by H5 and I thought it's just completely
winning but then I I started seeing
ghosts like I thought hey he's playing
so confidently maybe it's a fortress but
I should just play Bishop F3 and then
Bishop F3 like he has no moves because
H5 even G4 okay or G3 oh not G4 and you
get to the passer mm yeah Bishop F3 H5
and then I win very easily but okay but
still at the end of the day never
happened that you were in trouble it
seems like okay was with a maybe not the
perfect play but still you managed to
win this game okay Wesley we will not
analyze everything you know we have seen
so many lives from Peter and everywhere
you were winning um I wanted to ask you
the final question do you do you pay
attention to this race ratings what is
happening like are you aware of the
current situation like where are you now
in this in this race well I mean I got I
got people you know friends who I guess
the spectators want me to qualify for
the candidates more than I want to
qualify myself like again my M main
priority is to qualify for next year's
grandchester which thanks to an
important win today I think I have
pretty good chances I think top three
still qualifies for next year's gr yeah
this is what you told me before the
tournament I remember this very well but
now now that you has you have plus plus
two have you even checked the standings
or or not like are you leading um no I
think I have pretty after today think I
have pretty decent chances to qualify by
reading at least because F you lost you
you are 10 points ahead of everybody are
you aware of
it well it's not my priority but I I
mean I check here and there see
people like I mean f just lost
27 rating points in a month yes it's
crazy yeah
so I mean of course I would love to
qualify to the candidates very much I've
only been there once and it's got great
experience you play against great
players and then maybe you have a
chance uh so you know I'd be very happy
if I if I if I I I'm really happy to
hear that because I never heard it from
you before so all the best of luck for
you Wesley so many goals you have in
this tournaments um see you tomorrow
thank you and we go back to the studio
yeah y looks hungry
it's dinner
time Dinner Bell is ringing thank you
Wesley thank you Anastasia
congratulations no serious that's a huge
huge Victory remind everybody the
standings abely do it with pleasure yes
sir there we see Wesley so at the top of
the leaderboard with plus two four
points out of six but there are players
chasing him Fabiano Carana is three
points out of five and Dan Dominguez
also three points out of five and take a
look at the games played and you'll see
a discrepancy that's because Yan Kristof
dudo withdrew after round two exactly
unexpectedly for us Peter the event
exploded we didn't see that coming
whatsoever final thoughts on today was a
fantastic day of chess the the grand
chest stour itself the winner of the
grest tour is more or less decided with
today's result but the race to qualify
for the next year as Wesley keeps
reminding us is very important and that
race for the second and third place is
wide open right uh we still have the
whole Intrigue of who wins the singfield
cup this tournament is really blowing up
in the last couple of rounds plenty to
watch for a fantastic game tomorrow
between Wesley and uh Fabby so tune in
we we'll still be here wonderful joy as
always a great pleasure call with both
of you it's Brant the G the players
really spoiled us
I thought a fantastic fantastic Parting
Shot there by Wesley right absolutely
and we are going to say good night
goodbye to all our viewers but tune in
tomorrow because you can't you don't
want to miss the action that will be
happening same time same place thank you
all for watching see you
[Music]
then
a
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited